Good morning.
All right.
Do my gavel thing.
I now call the September 11, 2019 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
I'd like to commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strauss, will you please lead us in this Pledge of Allegiance?
Would you all please rise?
Face the flag.
Right hand over your heart.
Ready?
Begin.
Thank you.
And we are now going to introduce our new student board member, Brenna Pangilinan.
And I'm going to administer the oath of office to you, I guess, in the center here.
We're the largest secondary district in the state.
And we are located, thank you.
We're located south of San Diego, right next to the international border with Mexico.
We're also very proud that we are home to your new student board representative, Brenna Pangilinan.
You already know her bio, but she's an outstanding young person.
Besides great academics, she's the ASB president.
She's a varsity water polo and swimming team.
But she's also very, very, very aware of our social emotional concerns of our youth today.
Last year, she was part of a task force that organized our first annual suicide prevention community forum, where it was well attended by students and parents.
Brenna and I also share a common cultural background because her father and my mother are both from the US territory of Guam.
And so that's of Chamorro descent.
And so we're very excited about that as well.
But my main reason today for attending is to recognize and acknowledge Brenna for her leadership and her student advocacy.
As the student board rep for our district last year as a junior, she made it her mission to seek out diverse student voices and share those perspectives at each of our twice a month board meetings.
Each meeting, she would share a grow and a glow aspect of student life from individual campuses across our district.
She posed a lot of difficult questions for us to answer, as well as a lot of solutions for some of our district's priorities and decisions.
And we know that many students have the opportunity to apply for the state board representative position, but only one gets selected.
And Sweetwater is very proud that Brenna thrived through that interview and rigorous application process.
We are confident that Brenna is the best choice for this position because she's strong enough to represent those students who know how to navigate their way through the educational societal system.
And she's also compassionate enough to seek out and advocate for students who see themselves as invisible.
So on behalf of our Board of Trustees and the entire Sweetwater District, all 39,000 students that she represents, as well as all the students in the state of California, you inspire us every day.
Congratulations, Brenna.
Oh, and of course, her parents and her brother, Mr. and Mrs. Pangolino and her brother, Caden.
Sure, now that we've had the oath and the pictures, I'd like to really truly welcome our new student board member.
As you've heard, Brenna is a senior at Eastlake High School in the Sweetwater Union High School District.
She's currently the Associated Student Body President at her high school.
She's been a strong advocate for social-emotional learning through the founding of the Eastlake High School Mental Health Task Force.
She's been involved in nonprofit work as a Champions Council Member for the Nothing But Nets UN Foundation Campaign.
So let's formally welcome Brenna to the State Board.
Do you have any thoughts or comments you'd like to share, Brenna?
Hello, everyone.
I just want to say thank you so much.
I am extremely honored to hold this position and to represent such an amazing and diverse state.
And I look forward to working with every single one of you.
Thank you so much.
We are so happy to have you.
I'd also like to announce that the State Board of Education Office posted the annual fall recruitment for service on SBE Advisory Commissions and the 2021 Student Board Member.
Applications are due on October 9th for the Instructional Quality Commission.
Applications are due on October 10th for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, Advisory Commission on Special Education, California Practitioners Advisory Group, and the 2021 State Board of Education Student Board Member.
That's all October 10th.
More information is on the SBE website under the tab for commissions and committees.
There is one public hearing on our September agenda, item 4, which will be heard later today.
On consent calendars, there is a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent calendars.
The proposed regular consent items are items 6 through 11.
The proposed consent waiver items are W01 through W15.
I'd like to remind board members that any members wishing to remove any items from the proposed consent calendars should please advise our Executive Director Karen Staff-Walters by 10 a.m.
today.
We will take up the waiver consent items and the regular consent items later this afternoon.
In terms of public input, speakers should sign in at the table just outside the room.
Binders are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Signing in on the page that identifies the item number on which they would like to speak will help ensure that we keep track of all the speakers for a particular item.
Item 14 is the general public comment item during which members of the public may provide comment on items that are not specifically listed on the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker.
In order to ensure that everyone gets their minute, there is a red timer at the podium that will flash a red signal to each speaker when the one minute time limit has been reached.
The board will now go into closed session to discuss and or take action on the following litigation as noticed on the meeting agenda, MSC v. State.
I ask that the members of the public please clear out of the boardroom and turn off the microphones.
Bye.
OK.
So we're going to move right ahead.
This is, as you know.
Yeah.
This is, as you know, a one-day board meeting.
We're going to move expeditiously through the agenda to try to finish by about five o'clock so everybody can catch their modes of transportation.
And we're going to move right into item one, which is our mega accountability item.
And I think the CDE is recommending that the state board approve the top of scale range methodology for incorporating
CAA into the academic indicator.
And if you wonder what that means, we'll find out from Cindy in just a moment.
Modified status cut scores for the academic indicator for DAS schools and a revised status cut scores for the graduation rate indicator.
Cindy Kazanas will present this item.
Please begin.
Good morning, members of the Board, Chief Deputy Akola.
It's a pleasure to be with you.
This is Cindy Kazanis.
I'm the Director of the Analysis, Measurement, and Accountability Reporting Division.
And on this day of remembrance, I just wanted to acknowledge there's a reason why some of us are here.
We're here because we are committed to public service.
And I am grateful for those that I work around every day to do things to help our schools, to help our students, and to help our teachers.
And so today is another step in that direction for the 2019 dashboard.
President Darling-Hammond mentioned, we do have a couple of action items, and then we have a couple of things for information purposes that you'll take action on in November.
Before you go to those, I realize that I did not announce the results of the closed session.
In my eagerness to get to accountability, which is the most exciting thing, after we finished the closed session, the board discussed and or took action on the following cases, MSCB State.
That's all I need to say.
And now you can proceed.
Thank you.
So in your board item, there were several attachments.
And the first ones, the first three that we're going to talk about are for action.
And then the final two attachments are again for informational purposes.
And as President Lyndon Arlinghamen mentioned, we do have a recommendation of approving the top of the scale
range methodology for incorporating the California alternate assessment into the academic indicator.
We're also asking that you approve modified status cut scores for the academic indicator for our dashboard alternative status schools and revised cut scores for the graduation rate indicator.
So let's move straight into attachment one.
I do have my colleagues from the assessment division here to assist if it gets too technical.
So feel free to ask those tough questions if you do have them.
So just as a way of orienting you all on to this assessment, this is an assessment that is for our most significantly cognitively disabled students.
They are administered what we call the CAA or the California Alternate Assessment for English Language Arts and Mathematics.
So this is limited to about 1% of students statewide.
So if we think about the majority of our students taking the Smarter Balanced assessments, the California Arts Loan Assessments is, again, for that 1% of students.
It's been operational since spring of 2016.
So we've now had several administrations of this assessment.
We've had the scores for this assessment in the dashboard since the dashboard was operational in 2017.
That was an action this board took in September of 2017 when we recognized that it was going to be a little bit more challenging to have a crosswalk between these scores.
So both sets of dashboards, if you were to look at any school or district,
in those schools or district had students taking this assessment, you would see the results of those scores embedded in the additional reports on the California School Dashboard.
What the display says is the number of students who achieved one of the three levels.
Again, that was not used for incorporation in the academic indicator.
That's what we're acting on today.
So what we are bringing forward to you is that for this coming dashboard and future dashboards, that you would see a combined calculation of not only the Smarter Balanced scores, but the California Alternate Assessment scores into one number for the academic indicator for both English language arts and mathematics.
So just to read a refresher on what the academic indicator is, it's based on distance from standard.
Of course, this is methodology that this board approved, again, a couple of years ago for those of you who are new as of today or even as of this year.
For Smarter Balanced, those assessments are aligned to the California Common Core State Standards, and they have four achievement levels.
And what we're measuring for accountability purposes only is the distance from a student's score on Smarter Balanced and how to get to standard met on the achievement level.
So that's range level three rather.
So we can see this graphically or rather visually on this slide.
So this particular student who was in grade five had a score of 2505.
To get to the lowest part of the range for level 3, the student would need to have hit 2528.
So the gap between 2528 and 2505 is 23 points.
So when we talk about distance from a standard, that student is negative 23 points.
We do this calculation for every single student and then aggregate it up to the school and to the district level.
So turning over to our alternative assessment, how it is different, first and foremost, is it's based on a different set of standards, the Common Core Alternate Standards.
And students are evaluated against their level of understanding.
And as you can see in the slide, rather than meeting the standard as is required by the Smarter Balanced assessments.
They have different reporting scales with distinct distributions.
So they're very different tests.
They're structured differently.
They, of course, are testing different sets of students as well.
We also have different ranges.
So we have three levels for the California Alternate Assessment.
Of course, the Smarter Balance is four levels.
And then the sample size vary between the two assessments, which means that 99% of our students are taking the Smarter Balance assessments.
And again, just over 1% are taking the California Alternate Assessment.
So how did we get to today?
We took the methodology that you see today not once, but twice, maybe even three times to the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
They had some very strong feelings about making sure that this methodology was understandable to the field and to practitioners so that they could be used for making changes for these sets of students.
When we took it first to the Advisory Commission on Special Education, they made some recommendations, so we brought it back again.
And in July, July I believe, or August, July, they were very strongly, they wanted to make sure, like we said, that they unanimously approved the methodology that we are bringing before you today.
That is not the only stakeholder group that we take, of course, our dashboard considerations to.
We always go to the California Petitioner's Advisory Group.
We will take it to the Local Control Funding Formula Stakeholders Group, and anybody else who wants to listen to what we have to talk about, although we're getting pretty technical in accountability, and I think it's been harder for some of the larger audiences to follow along.
But all that said, we have made adjustments and considerations for this methodology and direct response to stakeholder input.
And when we keep in mind that our goal, at least the goal that I think from the outset of this discussion about thinking about students with disabilities taking, or rather cognitively disabilities, taking this assessment was to make sure that these students were represented appropriately in our accountability system and fairly and that we
make sure that they're a part of our system.
They are, of course, our students, and we need to make sure that they're reflected in our accountability system.
So keeping that in mind, I'm going to walk through rather quickly the three methodologies, just so you have a perspective on what was considered, and then, of course, a walk through why we ultimately decided on the top of the scale range.
So the first is the effect size.
And the effect size really looks at trying to convert the scores so that it is, you can use what, if you want, let's get into a little bit more detail here.
We're using where the standard represents the understanding of alternate standards rather.
So we're converting the California alternate scores using standard deviations for the two assessments.
There is a calculation involved.
And the example we use is if a Cal alternate score is 0.5 standard deviations from level three, that score is converted.
So for a Smarter Balanced score, it's 0.5 standard deviation from level three.
And I think that this shows it nicely.
So you can see the standard deviation for the Cal alternate score of 370, and then below for the Smarter Balanced.
So that's how we equate our effect size methodology.
For middle of the scale range, the approach that we took was looking at, again, the California Alternate Assessments.
We would substitute their score with the mid-range score on the same achievement level for Smarter Balanced.
And again, the example below shows using a grade three student scoring anywhere on levels two for the California Alternate Assessment.
For English Language Arts, we received this midpoint score of level two on the Smarter Balanced English Language Arts, and that number is 2399.
Ultimately, we are recommending the top-of-the-range approach, which you hear, top-of-the-scale range approach, which you see here.
So a student's California Alternate Assessment score would be substituted for the top score of the same Smarter Balanced achievement level.
And the example we use is still a grade three student.
If they scored anywhere on level three, they would be bumped up to the highest score of level two on the Smarter Balanced English Language Arts, which in this case is 2431.
So for each of these methodologies, we provided a lot of detail in our agenda items.
So if you didn't look at the tables, we have lots of tables today for you to get your hands on.
One of the things we wanted to look at was whether or not including students who received the lowest attainable score made an impact.
And these are students who cannot orient to the test.
So they may sit at the computer, but they're not able to
They may not be able to answer a question or maybe something is not happening.
We don't know because these are individually one-on-one administered tests, but that is a population of students that is notable.
And so we did run simulations including those students and then excluding those students.
And ultimately what we're recommending is because schools are being held accountable for this measure is to exclude the students who received the loss.
We also found through our analysis that the distance from standard for students with disabilities improved under all methodologies.
So you see the tables with all students, and then you see them with students with disabilities by themselves.
So we did extensive analysis in that respect.
see that students who take the California Alternate Assessments, if they received a score that it was not a loss, that they are generally closer to level three than those who take the Smarter Balance.
So again, schools are able now to get credit for these students engaging with the test and that result will be reflected in their academic indicator should this methodology be approved.
So I do have the impact.
I'm not going to spend much time on it.
If anything, you'll be able to see the difference on the far right-hand column, how it changes between each of the methodologies.
So the first is the effect size.
The second is the middle scale range.
And these tables are all in your agenda item.
And then finally,
You can see the difference for the top of the scale range.
And this is when we include all students.
Again, when you look at it with students with disabilities, you see those numbers go up slightly.
So with that, I wanted to just close out this particular section by, again, reiterating that we are recommending the top of the range score be used to incorporate our California alternate assessments into the academic indicator.
I talked about the support we've received for this methodology.
It is one of the easier items to communicate, one of the easier methodologies to communicate, which was important for our practitioners and was important for the California, the Advisory Commission on Special Education.
And then you can see that the bottom reason is why we did not recommend the other two methodologies.
So with that, I wanted to turn it back to President Darling-Hammond.
If there's any questions, I can answer technical clarifying questions.
We'll keep moving.
OK, so attachment two, we're talking about a modified method for, again, the academic indicator, but this time for schools with dashboard alternative school status.
And just to orient everybody, since, again, some of you are brand new and others have been here a little longer,
This item came to us in something that we had on our to-do list for a while now, because our Dashboard Alternative Status Schools, so our students serving high-risk or high-need students, mainly at our county offices of education,
thought that it needed some more looking into.
So what we're suggesting and what we're proposing today is a modified set of status cut scores for the academic indicator.
So if we think about our alternative schools that county offices run, whether it may be students who are expelled, students who are pregnant, parenting rather, students who are in schools of
special education that are again operated by counties.
This last dashboard was the first time they ever saw the results in our accountability system because we were bringing this set of schools on board.
So now that we're in here too, we've had a little bit of time and this is one of the changes we're suggesting that be made.
We are not suggesting that we set different goals, so for change for these schools.
That is not something that
we saw any noticeably different.
We saw that DAS schools are making progress like our traditional schools and that we think that we should have the same set of goals and expectations to continuously improve and for these schools to keep improving under not only our accountability system, but under the standards that are being measured, especially for the academic indicator.
So we are looking at
One of the reasons that we were asked to look into this, again, this is also in cooperation with our Alternative Schools Task Force, which is a joint group that's run under the Gardner Center at Stanford University, is that that group felt that the scores weren't as fair for these types of schools.
And when we look back at how we
did the distributions for our different distance from standard.
Those did not include our DAS schools.
So when we include our DAS schools and we think about maybe setting different cut scores, you can see through the tables that we've provided in the agenda item there are stark differences between these schools and these school types.
So specifically, the current distributions for our traditional schools or non-DAS schools and our DAS schools revealed that there are significant differences at the 50th percentile.
And depending on grade and content area,
65% to 95% of our schools that are DAS are in the very low status compared to 5% to 20% of our non-DAS schools.
So really looking at this from a numerical standpoint, you can see for what we are proposing, where the current cut scores are in the middle column, and then on the far right, the proposed cut scores.
And that was for grades three through eight, which there are just a handful of DAS schools.
The majority of our DAS schools are, of course, serving our high school grades.
So for the academic indicators, since it only applies to grade 11, these are the distributions that we're seeing for our grade 11 students in DAS.
So what we are recommending is a shift for low and very low only.
And the impact that we have done using the analysis that we did, we saw the shift of changing the cut scores for status would move this for English language arts for grades three through eight, you would see a shift in 12 schools from very low to low.
For mathematics for those same grades, 19 schools.
For English language arts, 56 would move from very low to low.
And for mathematics, 45.
So it is a slight shift in giving them a nudge from being very low to low.
This may or may not change their ultimate color.
As a reminder, you need not only status, but you need change.
And some schools may actually have
may not maintain or they may actually decrease.
And so that would change their color.
But this is criteria that we think would be appropriate.
A modified method would be appropriate for the dashboard alternative schools.
I also wanted to make sure that I reminded you that this does not affect
the federal definition that is required to look at schools for comprehensive support.
Of course, the first thing you look at is whether or not they met the graduation threshold, and that's how several of our schools that are DAS are getting in because they're not meeting the 67% graduation threshold.
And so we did receive one question from the field.
We went to go to the county superintendents who are responsible for special programs, and there was a concern that they would lose funding.
Ultimately, if they're not getting over the threshold for the graduation rate, they're already going to be receiving funding.
So this recommendation does not affect that shift for ESSA.
So our recommendation is that you adopt these shift for the cut scores for status in very low and low for DAS schools only for the academic indicator.
We did take this out to the field.
There was some engagement from some of the stakeholders, others not a lot of feedback.
So I know for the California Partitioners Advisory Group, there was some conversations.
But of course, they don't take a vote.
You only know from how audience members are suggesting that they feel about something.
So with that, I can turn it back to you for clarifying questions.
Anybody has sort of technical or clarifying questions at this point?
Lisa, no?
OK, so we'll come back to your philosophy in just a little while.
Okay, well moving on to the cut scores for the graduation rate indicator.
Thank you.
Thank you for self-reflecting on that.
Okay, so we're gonna move on to something that you asked us to follow up on.
I want to clarify, you did not ask us to, you did not take action on this measure in the item in July.
But what you asked us to look at was now that you've approved a combined four and five year graduation rate for our non-DAS schools for this upcoming 2019 dashboard was to look at whether or not we should think about changing the threshold status score
So looking at the 67% threshold, perhaps moving it up, so setting a little bit of a higher goal to determine eligibility of schools under the comprehensive support and improvement under ESSA.
So this is maybe one of those philosophical conversations, but we went through the actual data runs that you asked us to.
And so we did two data simulations.
And let me first talk about it's currently set at less than 67%.
And then, as I mentioned earlier, that schools that are below 67% are automatically the first schools we look at for being identified for comprehensive support.
After that, we're looking at the 5% of Title I schools.
So that identification process will still be in effect.
And while, again, ESSA does not require a new threshold score, the two simulations that we conducted over the last several weeks were at 68% and 70%.
So we are recommending that, based on the analysis that we did, that should you choose to act on this, the recommendation would be to raise it to below 68%.
And we would need to have new status cut scores for both non-DAS and DAS schools to ensure consistency in LEA and school eligibility for support.
Charts are in your agenda item and let me just walk through what the results or the impact of that would be on On our current population again from using prior data So we do see that additional 41 schools would be identified for comprehensive support.
So again, I
receiving additional funding due to the federal requirements for this measure should this have been adopted last year.
And 16 of those were DAS schools, and 25 of those were non-DAS schools.
We also noted in the agenda item that two are currently identified for CSI under Title I, so they would move from that bucket to the graduation rate bucket.
So just something to
Keep in mind, but that is the impact analysis we found.
And I'm happy to respond to any questions in this regard.
Any clarifying questions at this point?
OK, so I'd love to ask Sue Burr and Eileen Strauss, our accountability liaisons, if they have any initial comments.
And then we can.
So we do have another piece for informational purposes.
I'm not sure if it's appropriate to proceed before.
Go right ahead, yeah.
OK, so this one is a preview for November.
The English Learner Progress Indicator, which we are very excited to have on board again this fall.
It's a transition year for us, so there is a proxy that we're suggesting that be used.
But I wanted to make sure we had a preview, and I was very happy to see a lot of good feedback in the public comment letters around this piece.
So you are not taking action on this today, but again, trying to help set this up for November.
So as a reminder, of course, our English Learner Progress Indicator is unique.
because we're looking at progress.
So we need two years of data to create status.
And so we now have our second year of data.
So we are able to create status.
And that is something we'll bring back to you in November.
But by thinking about progress, we need to look at students who increased at least one level to get credit for improvement, right?
So in that regard, we do have a full file now.
So we've been working with our assessment division to make sure that we have a good understanding of the results that have come in for our English language proficiency assessments for California, our ELPAC results.
The file is robust.
We are full steam ahead and looking at the two options that I list here.
So one of the things is looking at splitting out performance levels and then
looking at how to set those status cut scores.
So, I'm going to very high level walk you through this.
So as we note in the agenda item, and this is actually something that we did previously with the English Learner Progress Indicator using the prior assessment results, was breaking up our levels to allow for schools to demonstrate, or rather students to demonstrate more progress.
Because we know based on research that it takes five to seven years to get to that ultimate level four.
and being able to show proficiency in English.
So with that research in mind and our past practice, one of the things we are looking at is splitting up levels two and level three, which is where the concentration of students are right now.
So that, again, allows schools to show progress in this indicator and get credit for helping students to learn the English language.
So that's the simulation we're doing in regards to splitting the levels.
We're also looking at grade spans.
We did notice using prior year data, again, only one year of data, that there was some differences between our grades 1 to 8 and then 9 through 12.
Now that we have a second year of data, those concerns really seem to be going away.
So I don't know that we'll come back to you in November and actually recommend different cut scores for the grade spans.
We will show you the results of our simulations by those grade spans, though.
So you do have that when you make your decision.
You'll have that information in front of you.
So those are the pieces that we are working through right now and creating the tables that you will see come November.
Of course, the English Learner Progress Indicator is very important to making sure that students or schools and districts are held accountable for showing progress in this area.
And so with your action last November, we will bring forward in this November how we incorporate this to determine which schools and districts will be eligible for support.
So we're looking at LCFF, of course, for differentiated assistance for our districts and for schools under the federal requirements.
So, I did provide, this is a slide we used in the field that seems to have been effective.
So, I won't make you take the test, but really what it is showing is how we are thinking about displaying and orienting folks to using the words very low as opposed to a color as a proxy.
Because right now, of course, we don't have change.
So we don't technically have a color, and we don't want to confuse the field.
So in this example for Crystal Unified, we see over two different priority areas for the English learner student group.
You have very low, and then you have red for chronic absenteeism.
So this district would be identified for differentiated assistance based on what we see here.
So this is just an example of, again, that very low being used for district eligibility.
For school eligibility, as a reminder, we have these color combinations that we had to put together to get our state plan approved by the federal government.
And so these are the color combinations, and they are in hierarchical order.
So first we look at all red indicators, all red but one indicator with any other color, five or more indicators where the majority are red, and then all red and orange indicators.
When we think about school eligibility, English language arts for this one is red.
Math is red.
LP is very low.
Again, a proxy for showing that they would be potentially selected.
And then chronic absenteeism is orange and suspension rate yellow.
So these are examples that we're using in the field.
It seems to resonate with, we just last week went to the Bilingual Coordinators Network and had a very good conversation with them about how this is being brought on board and they felt that this was very helpful to be able to start disseminating information to their colleagues on the support piece.
I just wanted to point out that between now and November, we have a very aggressive schedule to get out our simulations and to get feedback on those simulations.
So our English Learner Progress Indicator Work Group, which is our main advisory group for creating this policy, will be meeting not only once, but likely twice.
We will go back to the Bilingual Coordinators Network.
And then my colleague, Shanine Coates, hosts the Every Student Succeeds Act Stakeholder Group.
in October and we'll go to the California Petitioners Advisory Group in October and then finally we do have an LCFF.
stakeholder group.
But with anything that we bring out for accountability, we're invited to monthly meetings of educators or teachers or community members.
These are the topics that we will be discussing with them.
So with that, I am happy to turn it back to you and just point out that we do have a lot of outreach activities that we've done over the last several months.
And next week, I was supposed to lead with this.
I forgot.
We will be doing dashboard week.
So we are going to spend the entire week talking about the dashboard.
So if you don't see it on Twitter, if you don't see it on Facebook, then we failed.
Janet Weeks and I just did a blog yesterday over at CCEE.
And Jenny and I were just featured in AXA's monthly newsletter.
We did a webinar.
They hosted us at their location.
We are getting out as much as we can.
We are getting out of this building.
People are coming to this building, though, to talk to us.
So please be aware that we are doing our best to make sure that everybody is prepared come December.
I told you accountability would be exciting.
So I'd like to turn now to Sue Byrne and Eileen Strauss, our liaisons.
And then if there are additional clarifying questions that anyone has, we'll take those before we go to public comment.
Thank you, President Darling-Hammond, and thank you, Cindy, and your entire staff.
I just want to say that, to me, this item, even though it's a little bit eye-glazing when you get into the details, I appreciate that, it is an example of what we talked about many years ago when we first put this together, that we were going to be about continuous improvement.
And I think that's what you see reflected here.
The staff, both the department staff and the board staff, take this very seriously, the impact very seriously, and come to us with recommendations for tweaks as we need to.
So that's really what you're seeing here.
The other thing I want to commend you for, and all of our stakeholder friends, is the amount of outreach that you're doing.
And I know I can speak for Vice President Strauss that whenever we have our liaison calls, the first question is, did you talk to, and we rattle off all of the folks who we know are very interested in it.
So to me, again, very good example of both continuous improvement and stakeholder engagement.
So I just want to express my appreciation.
I'll just follow up by saying at the CPAC meeting, there was a lot of discussion and input and really thoughtful and appreciation for the continued tweaks and improvement on this.
And I just wanted to, that was actually one of my comments that Sue also just said, is that the feedback is broad.
So you have stakeholder input, but CPAC gives us practitioner input, which are people who live with this and use this in their districts on a regular basis.
So I feel like this is a thoughtful process where we're hearing how it's impacted, particularly like, say, on the DAS schools where we had some issues last spring, and now we're trying to address the cut scores, and a lot of support for the recommendations.
So by the time it comes to us, to the board, it's gone to lots of stakeholder groups to see if this is addressing a lot of the issues, including the technical design group who actually does the technical advice.
So just a support for the process and the outreach.
I did hear yesterday about the dashboard week next week and I would just say I just so appreciate all the variety of social media.
So while I didn't listen to your blog, I do follow the tweets.
And I do think that they're trying really hard to help people understand it.
And we're a really big state.
We have lots of counties, lots of districts, and lots of different ways to get to people.
So I just appreciate the state board and the CDE team figuring out a variety of ways to reach out to people, including your list that you post of all the stakeholder groups and different coordinator groups that you present to.
Are there any other clarifying questions at the moment?
And then we'll go to philosophical conversation after the public comment.
Clarifying on the technical?
Yes, Member Sun?
Question on the graduation rate.
If we were to raise the graduation rate to 68% per recommendation, does that impact our ESSA plan or anything like that?
We would need to submit an amendment to our ESSA plan.
So Shanine has been keeping details because we probably are the folks that require the most amount of amendments out of that plan.
So that is a November item.
But of course, we will be first.
And then Shanine will be afterwards to present those amendments to you.
Comment?
We have five speakers for item one, Gerald Guzman, Liz Gulen, Jan Correa, Angela DeRamos, and Michael Joke.
Would you please line up, please, and come to the podium?
Good morning.
My name is Gerald Guzman, and I'm an English language development specialist and teacher in LA County.
I'm representing the English Learner Leadership and Legacy Initiative of California's Together.
We are pleased to see the continued progress being made with the implementation of the LP and support the direction taken by the SB and CDE on this.
We appreciate the fact that the staff has conducted data simulations using the LPAC summative assessments results to determine the feasibility of splitting the LPAC summative overall performance levels 2 and 3 for the LP and for identifying options for setting status cut scores.
We support CDE conducting additional data simulations to assist in determining whether splitting the LPAC performance levels two and three is necessary and conducting data simulations on different grade spans to determine the most appropriate methodology for setting LP cut scores.
In addition to these additional data simulations, it is recommended that the board direct CDE staff to publish on the CDE website the LP performance of each LEA by grade level, not just by grade spans.
Thank you.
Hi, good morning.
Jan Correa, CEO for the California Association for Bilingual Education.
And I echo the words of appreciation for the work and focus from the Department on the development of the accountability system in general that reflects our culturally and linguistically diverse student population, and particularly our English learners through the lens that we have at CABE and our lens of multiliteracy and bilingualism as well.
We appreciate the work done particularly on the LP, and we agree with continuing the data simulations and different grade spans to set the LP cut scores.
We would ask that a report is developed that shows the distribution of math student scores by grade and performance levels for November and to help the field understand the different process with the cut scores.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
In our letter for the Equity Coalition, we expressed support for the inclusion of the combined graduation rate.
But we're very concerned about the ability of the community to understand it on the dashboard.
And we wanted you to implement the recommendation that we heard from CPAC that the performance and change for both years
be reported on the dashboard.
We think that will be easier for stakeholders to understand and to understand the progress.
We also echo the request of Californians Together and CABE about reporting the grade level performance for ELPI.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Ephraim McCollum, Children Now.
Assuming a letter on item one, we wanted to reference a couple of key pieces.
We want to applaud the work on the grad rate and really agree with the direction it's going, but also think that it should be reported for four-year and five-year, just for the parents to understand what that is, and also hopefully to trigger some discussions around what that means to be four-year, five-year, et cetera.
On the LP items, we do agree with the Cal State California's together recommendation to share that data, and also just want to think about the five- to seven-year time frame for moving an English learner to proficiency.
And just keeping in mind the idea of what if a kid comes in kindergarten, first grade at level three, should it really take five to seven years?
So what signals do we send to the field, and how do we think about that?
Thank you.
Good morning, Angela de Ramos on behalf of CTA.
And CTA supports the staff recommendation on item number one.
And I wanted to give a little, this is interesting timing because yesterday I sat all day in a data analysis meeting, which all grade levels in my school are, I teach sixth grade.
So all sixth grade teachers were required to come to this data analysis meeting.
And we look at our scores and we sort of figure out what we need to do.
But what it sounds like, and it literally is like this, is you need to move six kids from yellow to this color.
It's still, we're still there.
And the results, and in the room there's three sixth grade teachers and one special, we have a special day on our campus.
So those scores are rolled into the
how many kids need to move from this color to that color.
So I just kind of wanted to give you a little reality of what sort of this translates to at a school site.
But we do appreciate the looking at the data and how it affects what triggers, what it triggers in the results.
Thank you.
For the public comment,
For any other items, are there public comment or just that one?
Okay, all right, so there's, we're ready for philosophical discussion.
Member Batiste Lacombe was, I know we're going to give us a philosophical treatise and also Member Sandoval.
Okay.
Just briefly, regarding the top of the range, top of the scale range methodology, I was present at the Advisory Commission on Special Education meeting in August where this was reviewed in detail.
And every commissioner voted in favor of this methodology, felt that it was fair, relatively easy to communicate, and was pleased to see the progress on this.
So I just wanted to share that as the liaison that it received unanimous support.
Member Rucker?
Well first of all let me begin by saying I'm looking forward to Dashboard Week and my family, my two brothers always look forward to Shark Week on the National Geographic Channel so I'm certainly hoping this will be this will be something I'll be far more interested in.
I also want to say thank you very much for the analysis and the way that you put the item together concerning the recommendation.
concerning the top scale range.
I was greatly amused at the very gentle way at which you explained maybe you might not remember your high school calculus course and understand standard deviation.
That was just the nicest way somebody ever told me maybe you just don't understand this.
So that's another way of explaining what it means to be transparent, so I appreciate that.
More importantly, on the top scale range, I think the other thing that this is going to show over time, going back to what member Burr has already said, our goal is to focus on growth and change over time.
This recommendation, particularly on using the way that the student scores will be interpolated onto the scale, this is going to be inclusive over time of more of the students
who actually do take the California Alternative Assessment.
I think that that's the most important takeaway from this decision.
We are not excluding students who have taken the Alternative Assessment and in the way that their scaled scores will be placed on the scale, we are actually
maximizing the number of students that will be identified and that we can understand their grade level performance compared with their peers.
And I think that that's an important takeaway from this decision and this particular recommendation.
So I really want to compliment you not only on the analysis and the work, but on the recommendation because I think that this is the best way to go.
Other comments?
Member Ortiz, are the comments ready?
Not as ready as I am for item two.
But I think for me, the graduation rate, I'm happy that we're now seeing two scenarios, 68% and 70, because if we recall, adding a fifth year cohort was going to have the most impact in the lowest performing schools.
And so there was a possibility of having schools that would otherwise be identified under ESSA for graduating less than 67% of students
they would go unidentified if we cluster the fifth year.
And so I'm glad that we're considering 68%.
I think that's the right thing to do.
And even though it may change our SSA plan, well, that little plan has been a little patchwork.
So one more amendment or one more revision, not a big deal, considering everything it's gone through.
In terms of the comments around the LP,
I'm wondering if there has been follow-up conversations with some of the requests that have been made about additional data simulations.
And I want to focus, so I'll give you an opportunity to respond to that.
But I do want to focus on this very low category.
And I understand the hesitation with assigning a color, because it's basically two years of data.
It's progress towards, so it's not status and change.
It's status, status, and next year we'll have the change.
But I do think that very low may confuse folks as well in the field.
So you may see colors and then there's a word or a phrase, very low.
Is there a consideration to add an asterisk on the dashboard that explains very low is a proxy for red?
And how are we communicating that to the field so that when they receive or they see their dashboard and they see very low,
it should indicate you need work.
This is red for your L students.
And how are you going to address that?
And then again, in the next item, we'll talk how that will be addressed in the LCAP.
But if you could respond to the data simulations, some of the comments that were heard, and how if we plan to add any additional detail to the state board dashboard to make sure that people know very low is equivalent to red.
I am happy to respond.
Some of the issues that were brought up were brought up after the agenda item was posted.
We will take the next eight weeks to come up with a more comprehensive plan than what we have shown you already as far as the communication to the field.
As far as the data analysis, we are looking at it by grade spans.
There was interest in looking at it at grade levels.
Of course, the grade level information is available on our assessment website.
It will be available before November for LPAC takers.
So we will do our best over the next eight weeks to try to figure out how to tease out some of these issues.
The very low piece, adding an asterisk,
hasn't worked so well for us.
It didn't work well for us.
And that's why we went through the whole redesign of the dashboard.
So there is a hesitation on saying, oh, but this really means something else.
And so we do tend to do, when we have those kinds of situations, we'll do a special flyer around it.
We'll definitely spend time
through our webinars and getting out to the field this fall on talking about what it means.
Because what it really means is how it impacts a school for, ultimately, could be identified for support.
But it will also show something for, I mean, we were finally able to show a category for this group of students on this indicator.
So all schools should be addressing it in their, or rather all districts should be addressing it in their LCAP.
So we'll definitely spend,
the time between the two meetings to come up with something more comprehensive.
So when we come for action November, hopefully these comments will have dissipated.
I have a couple of questions.
The grade level versus grade span reporting, I think what you just said was that the grade level reporting will be on another page and available to schools and you want to report grade span in the dashboard.
Is that right?
What is being asked is that we report grade distribution of each LEA by grade level and scores across proficiency level and state performance by grade level with distributions across proficiency level.
That is exactly, and Michelle, perhaps, I don't know if you'd like to say anything, but that is exactly what the assessment websites do.
Keep in mind that accountability is not about grade level, it's about
school performance and district performance.
So some of the things that are being suggested are inappropriate for the dashboard because it's not about grade level, right?
It's about looking at- The grade level data are available elsewhere.
They are available elsewhere.
That's what I wanted to confirm.
Okay.
And the question about splitting the bands in terms of reporting, I'm assuming that allows us to get closer to a sort of a scale score where you're able to see growth more
obviously by virtue of having more touch points along the scale.
Is that the idea?
That's correct.
And so say a little bit more about where we are.
I think that's a good idea, and I'm just curious where we are getting to that.
Keep in mind, we want to make sure that we're continuing to show progress.
So I think that the comment that one of the last people made was about a student starting in kindergarten or in early grades in level three.
And then I think that my comment was misconstrued about five to seven years.
I would hope that a student that starts in level 3 in kindergarten or grade 1 would move up to level 4 very quickly, much, much quicker.
So, there is continuous improvement in this system.
You cannot, you know, if you're stagnant at a level, you're not progressing.
You're not going to get credit for this indicator.
This indicator, you need to show progress.
So, with this splitting of the bands, allowing for
increased demonstration of progress, especially where the concentration of our students are, again, in the twos and threes, is something that we did for the prior version, the prior methodology for the English Learner Progress Indicator.
So we are adapting it to this proposed methodology, again, that you would take action on in November.
Terrific.
And then my last question is just to confirm my understanding.
I heard one of the commenters ask about
representing the four-year graduation rate and the five-year graduation rate separately.
I think we had already agreed that that would be the case.
Is that true?
That is true.
And I think we're going to maybe be able to bring in an outside consultant to help us display that data, because it's actually probably one of the most complicated pieces to display.
So we are actively working on how we'll do that.
The kids who started ninth grade in a given year, we'll get to see them after four years, and then we'll get to see them
Terrific.
Those were all my questions.
Are there other questions that people have before we move on the recommendation?
Seeing none, do I have a motion?
I move the department's recommendation that's shown on the PowerPoint to approve the top of the scale range methodology for incorporating the California alternate assessment into the academic indicator.
to approve the modified status cut scores for the academic indicator for our alternative schools and to revise the cut scores for the graduation rate indicator.
Second from Member Strauss.
Thank you.
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Motion passes.
Thank you very much.
And we're now going to hear from State Superintendent Tony Thurmond.
Thank you for
Your report.
Thank you, Madam President, members of the board.
Brief report.
First, let me start by welcoming our new student board member.
We're glad to have you here.
And your perspective is welcome and needed.
So welcome.
So please call on our staff when you have any needs or in ways that we can support you.
We'd like to start by acknowledging that today is the anniversary of 9-11.
and to call attention to many memorials that are taking place throughout the state and throughout the nation.
Earlier today, the names of the 3,000 people who were lost were read, every single name.
And so clearly, we continue to remember so that we never forget.
And so we'd like to, in conjunction with that, pause now to take a moment of silence on behalf of those who were lost, the first responders,
including many of whom are still suffering from cancer as they were impacted as they rescued many in the tragedy.
Now a moment of silence.
Thank you for taking that moment to recognize and acknowledge
We'd like to also just welcome back all the board members and to all who are here today as this is the very first meeting of the board since school has been back in session across our state.
Just a few brief updates that we'd like to share on behalf of all the staff at the Department of Education.
It's good news.
As the budget process closed for the state, we saw many key resources to help our students.
$50 million in new funding to support mental health programs for our students.
The Department of Education staff will be working closely with the Mental Health Advisory Commission to create the criteria for how these dollars will be allocated throughout our state.
On that note, I'd like to also acknowledge that right about the time that school began, the Department of Education facilitated a back-to-school safety effort that included mental health first aid that took place in the Inland Empire in San Bernardino as part of a CalSTOP grant that the department has received to promote school safety.
400 educators participated.
and were engaged in a training being provided by the Sandy Hook Promise Organization.
And through this grant, we will be able to serve 180 schools on addressing ways that we can prevent gun violence in our schools and address the needs of students who have mental health needs in our schools.
The budget included millions of dollars for professional development, many in the program areas that our board president has advocated for over the course of many years.
Congratulations on that great work.
It also included funds to create a new position at the Department of Education, a computer science coordinator who will work with districts throughout the state.
We all know how important the opportunity to expand computer science is to support our students.
Later you'll hear about the STEAM symposium that CDE supports every year.
We think this is a great opportunity for CDE.
And the budget included a new item, first of its kind, a teacher housing grant program to provide resources to school districts to build affordable housing for teachers and classified staff.
I want to thank all the staff at the Department of Education and the State Board for their consultation to make this happen for the first time.
And I would share with you just one final item, $275 million in resources for school facility upgrades and modernization that was recently provided through the state allocations board.
A few things coming up that you might want to follow or have interest in.
The CDE is convening a town hall on a new requirement being proposed.
by the CSU.
It's a fourth year of mathematics, quantitative reasoning.
I was thinking about this when you talked about the trigonometry that you were talking about, or calculus.
I think I blacked out in that moment on all of them.
I had some flashbacks.
Needless to say, there's a conversation underfoot about whether or not a fourth year of mathematics should be required.
There is much debate on all sides of the issue.
The Department of Education has decided to host a conversation to pull in school districts, students, educators, to talk about what those impacts might be.
That is going to take place on September 18.
The public is open to attend.
The department is also hosting a virtual town hall on closing the opportunity gap.
We are inviting all 1,000 school districts in the state to participate in a conversation about closing the gap.
We're approaching it in a slightly different way.
While we care about best practices, we're also inviting districts to talk openly and candidly about where their struggles have been in closing the gap so that we can provide consultation to districts and how we support them in their ongoing efforts
to help close the gap.
We also will be celebrating here at the Department of Education throughout the month of September, Latin Heritage Month, recognizing the accomplishments of Latino Americans in our state.
There will be displays available in the lobby, and we invite you to join in with us as we continue these celebrations.
This concludes my report, and we are available to answer any questions that you may have, Madam President or any of the members of the board.
Any questions?
Thank you very much.
Great report.
Should we take a, do we need a break before we go into?
Yeah, we have a long item coming up, so we're going to give you a quick break.
Let's be back in our seats ready to work by 10 o'clock.
Thank you.
Okay.
We're going to reconvene here.
Thank you.
Hey Kai, how are you?
Welcome.
All right.
We are now prepared and fully assembled to take up item two, which regards revisions to the local control and accountability plan template.
And no action is recommended at this time, but the CDE is requesting that the state board provide feedback regarding the draft LCAP template prototype.
And this item will be presented by Jeff Breshears of the CDE.
Jeff, please begin.
Good morning.
Jeff Breshears of the local agency system support office.
As you said, this is an information item.
Yeah, pull that over there.
Can you hear me now?
I need to wear the big boy.
All right, how's that?
Better?
OK, good morning.
So item two, as I can say, is, as indicated, it's an information item.
We're going to talk about the LCAP, the Local Control and Accountability Plan redesign.
It was brought about by Assembly Bill 1840 that amended Ed Code 52064, asking for and promoting a change to the LCAP template for the 20 through 23 LCAP three-year cycle.
Again, no action is requested.
We're seeking your feedback.
Attachment 2 is the prototype that we'll talk about as we go through.
We've also provided attachment 1, which is a current template, just as a sense of reference.
So here's our project timeline.
Here we are in September bringing you the prototype and receiving feedback.
And looking then to, in October, providing the instructions for the prototype and the new template.
in October through an information memorandum, and then bring in the entire package to you for adoption in November.
Statute allows for adoption in January of 2020, but we really accelerated the timeline and did this approach to give more time for CDE and its partners in the field to roll this out and really make the transition from the current template to the new template.
So that's why we're looking at this and have taken this.
understanding that, and you will see the feedback that we have received so far in the outreach that we have taken, but knowing that with this, especially with this truncated timeline, we will continue to seek stakeholder feedback.
A little bit of the process, and I will explain, I guess I will explain now, is that we have a planning group which is comprised of State Board staff and CDE staff, and then we have also put together an advisory group of practitioners that include
county offices of education, school districts, charter schools, the CTA, and then a representation of advocacy groups.
They were our advisory group, and part of the process was to go from stakeholder feedback, take that to theme it, bring it back into the planning group.
kind of massage it some more and process what the feedback was, and then come to the advisory group and say, OK, what about this, and how can we fully do that?
And I'll explain that a little bit more as we go.
So here you can see the stakeholder input that we have.
They said we can build this out more.
But in April, we started with a World Cafe stakeholder feedback session at Sacramento.
And what we did with that group is we just gave them the instructions and gave them a stamp sheet and said this is what the LCAP template is supposed to look like.
So not looking at the old, just if you build from EdCode, how would you build an LCAP?
And so we got some pretty interesting feedback and we got some pretty interesting ideas and we took that to the advisory group.
and said, okay, this is kind of the theming, this is kind of the hopes and desires of what the template might look like.
And then from that, the advisory group put together two or three, sometimes four prototypes of each of the sections of the LCAP and then brought that back out to the public and said, again, in the stakeholder feedback, I'm saying, okay, so what are these prototypes, what do you think?
And then from there,
We got some feedback, again, themed it, brought it back to the planning group and the advisory group.
And from there is what you have now, is what you see, actually, which has also been tweaked since we have put this prototype together.
We also presented before CPAG in both June and August.
In June, we did very much like a World Cafe session that we did in the public in Sacramento and then also in Ventura.
A Tuesday at 2 webinar, we had over 300
participants in that webinar to give us feedback of that.
We also presented monthly at the state and federal program directors meetings as well as the LCFF stakeholders group.
So that's the feedback that we've received so far and we'll continue with that.
So just a little bit about what the changes are by issue through EDCODE and one is the accessibility of language
So consistent with statutory requirements, the prototype itself does not include any technological, technical language.
It is really outward facing much like our budget overview for parents.
It is accessible to the public.
The instructions are where the detailed requirements are and the technical details for LEAs to complete
to complete the LCAP.
So outward facing is really more ease of language and more technical inward facing.
And that's where October those instructions will be.
And some of the feedback we've received so far is that angst about what is being requested or shown in the prototype itself that actually will be reflected in the instructions.
So that timeline, again, is sent through the information memorandum in October.
And again, receive feedback.
We are working on the draft instructions as we speak.
The advisory group is meeting next week, so we'll have a draft for them to massage it and look at it and see what best fits to meet the needs of statute and the template itself.
Also, when the instruction statute says that the instructions are to encourage LEAs to prioritize their approach based on really to take their planning process differently and to look at priorities of planning process and outcomes, both local data and dashboard data, and have the ability then to focus on really to close an achievement gap and close gaps to approach through a prioritization one or two goals.
much in the continuous improvement science approach, and then have one goal that would allow to monitor the success of LEAs having in other metrics within it, but have that, again, priorities approach.
You'll see that in a few minutes as well.
And then this is kind of interesting.
The summary table is to consolidate all the
expenditures within the LCAP and then broken down in different ways.
Increased or improved services requirement, I think that is the next slide, but also it is going to be broken out by fund source and then broken out by personnel and non-personnel expenditures.
The reference to CSAM has gone away and actually the reference of breaking out base supplemental and concentration grant funds has gone away.
They are LCFF funds.
And with these tables, it should, in theory, substantially reduce the length of the LCAP.
Part of the feedback that we got at the last CPAG meeting was, have you tried this?
A couple of members were pretty excited about the last template, and it was OK.
It is better than before.
were getting better, but it was still clunky, and so they asked, have you put a real LCAP into this prototype?
And so our staff has worked on that, and we've taken a 114-page county office LCAP, and we've put it in there.
It's taken a little bit of literary license to reword some of the actions and the goals, but to put it in there.
We've gone from 114 pages
To right now, we're working on it still, and I think we're going to come in under 50 pages with this new LCAP and with this new template using the expenditure tables.
So part of the expenditure table is a summary of the increase for improved services, those actions that are addressing the unduplicated student population.
And this is interesting because it is, one, this is well received by parents.
We had a pretty good parent turnout in our Ventura
They like this one particular table in the expenditure tables because it has all the expenditures, all the actions, all the dollars that are being used to serve the unduplicated pupils and to address that increase or improved services requirement.
This table does not take away the requirement in regulations to explain
how and why you are meeting the increase to improve services percentage requirement.
That is still in the increase to improve services section in the Word part of this template.
This is just a summary.
It is just a snapshot.
It does not
advocate the LEAs from not explaining how and why they're using funds or actions and services on an LEA-wide basis.
Again, the parents like this because it was all in one shot and you could look at it as a component of this is what is being done in an Excel spreadsheet table.
A new requirement is, and this is in the instructions, it's not in the requirements, the LCAP template itself, the way that statute is put out,
But the instructions must specify that LEAs must include actions or services for its EL programs in the LCAP if an LEA has a numerically significant subgroup.
They must report on the metrics to talk about their English language development program as well as professional development.
Again, it's not a section in the LCAP, because that would really kind of mandate how to write a goal or where to put it within the goals or within the LCAP, but the requirement, and it will be in the instructions that say if you have a significant population of English learners, you will have actions within your LCAP to address them, the English Development Program, and professional development activities as well.
This is not in the template itself, but it's a change in the statute as far as where LEAs must post their LCAPs.
And school districts and county offices must post it on their webpages, and the language you can see here is they must prominently display their LCAP or a link to the LCAP on its webpage.
It must be there.
And then also county offices must prominently display, but not on their homepage, the LCAPs of the districts within their county.
So we'll look at some of the proposed changes.
Again, this is where we took the feedback from the stakeholders.
We themed it within the building and then brought it to the advisory group.
And this is where we came up.
It's not set in stone.
This is the feedback that we want from you.
And even I have some suggestions based on feedback that we received since this was posting of some changes that we might want to look at.
And the first is the stakeholder engagement.
The change here is on the left-hand side, you can see all the groups that are required for county offices and districts to engage in the stakeholders, and then a description how that engagement impacted the development of the LCAP.
One of the considerations would be to move this from a vertical-type approach to a horizontal approach because this would just add pages to the LCAP if one of,
say the Parent Advisory Committee has a more robust response that's just going to add pages to the LCAP.
It might just size-wise, the ease of reading is to go from this vertical approach to a horizontal approach, but still requiring all of these groups.
And you can see on the last, on the left-hand side, any other groups that the LEA has chosen outside of statute that they, at the local level, has engaged in that process.
One of the feedback here is asking, you know, the development or the impact is like, what did they ask for and where is it in the LCAP?
And we found that that is kind of, we talked about that at the last, the last template here is that kind of takes a regulatory approach of like this and respond to each and every comment and it's not consistent with statute.
And here those is, and again, the instructions will say,
What was the stakeholder engagement like?
What did you do?
And how did that impact the final outcome of the LCAP?
So here, going back to the discussion about the prioritization of goals, there's a lot of real estate between option A and the goals and actions and services supporting prioritization.
You'll see those actions and services that would fill between these two.
But this is the idea here is
Our focus, one or two focus under option A is what do we want to accomplish and how do we get there?
Kind of a root cause analysis, if you will, but why is an LEA focusing on one or two of these either programs or metrics outcomes?
And then the second goal then is a description how you intend to maintain the progress of the other priorities and metrics that aren't addressed in the prioritization of goals.
So in between those two goals, excuse me, and then option B is very much like the goals that we have now.
And it's just a broad stroke goal.
Some of the feedback that I've received on and we've received on both of these approaches is some of the smaller counties and smaller districts like option A because it allows them to focus and really kind of
focus and stream and hone their resources that they have on one or two issues.
Others that we feedback that they like this generalized approach because it allows an LEA to then align these goals to their strategic plan and it marries well for both.
There are positives for both and it allows the local control of both these approaches.
Those that are working with counties and working with LEAs and differentiated assistance really like, again, the priority, I mean the option A, because that goes for that continuous improvement and to look at those focused areas that one might want to do.
One of the other benefits of the statute is it brought the annual update requirements from a different section into the section for the LCAP.
And so that, again, will reduce the size of the LCAP because you're not, in essence, replicating the entire
LCAP in the annual update section, but here you can report on the metrics and you can see, again, much the analyzation of the goals is very similar, if not exact, of where it is now, but it is with each goal instead of a separate annual update section.
So here is how this has been progressed.
How is progress being measured?
That is the metric.
Baseline in 1920, actually the wording is poor, but
And that needs to be tweaked, but it's the baseline now as you're developing your LCAP, where are you at with these particular metrics?
And then on the far right-hand column, where do you want to be three years from now?
And then actually the three middle columns, the three, four, and five columns will be blank as you develop the first LCAP, because these are the actual outcomes for the ensuing years I'm looking at.
The actions and services system very well could be in two places.
In the expenditure tables and the Excel side, if we can talk a little bit about what this looks like electronically, this whole new e-template or this whole new redesign really screams for being an electronic version, either an e-template or another electronic approach, an electronic template.
If an LEA chooses to use a Word doc and Excel document, as we develop and we're working with our technology services division, very much of the input in the Excel will probably be web-based anyway, but it's an option.
But this one particular part will probably live both in the
expenditure table, the Excel site, if you will, and then also within the goals, actions, and services.
And the feedback here was people, one of these actions and services attached to the goals so they can see the story of what is trying to be accomplished here.
Again, and then you can see the total funds, the breakdown of the funds will be in the expenditure table.
And whether or not these particular actions or services are contributing to meeting the increase for improved services requirement, again,
More detail would be in the increase improved services section, which is not in here because it's changed minimally.
And then it also would be in that summary table of the Excel document as well.
The goal analysis, again, it's not a separate section.
It's following each goal.
It's very, very similar.
to what is in the annual update section now.
It's like, how's it going?
What are you doing?
What is going well?
What isn't going well?
Are there any material changes in the budget expenditures that you anticipated?
And then what changes will you be made?
So actually, the third and fourth prompts probably we'll come back to in November and flipping those again and talk about budgeted material differences and then any changes to the goals moving forward.
So that is easy to read, is the expenditure table, and this actually would not be outward facing.
This would be very much like the budget overview for parents is inward facing for LEAs to do their data entry.
You can see across the goals and actions, which would be referenced back in other areas in the template.
whether or not these actions are contributing to meeting the increase for improved services requirement, the scope, are they serving at LEA-wide within the school, school-wide, or just targeted to a specific unduplicated student group?
Where?
Time span, is it ongoing or is it a one-year?
It's not, it's just that, it's just to let the public know and let those reading the LCAP, it's like, is this a one-time, one-year thing, or is it ongoing?
And again, so you can see the breakdown of personnel, non-personnel,
the LCFF funds, other funds, local funds, federal funds, and then total.
And from this data entry, then you'll have the other tables, and one is the total expenditure table.
All in general, what are you spending in the LCAP?
What is the budgeted expenditure in the LCAP for all the goals, all the actions, with the breakdowns, the breakdown of the funds, whether or not it's contributing to meeting that increase for improved services requirement, and then the totals are at the bottom.
Here's that summarization of the contributing table.
Again, this is not where LEAs would justify and explain how and why they're meeting their increase for improved services requirement, but rather this is just a snapshot of what's being used.
And again, this is what was well received with the parents.
They could see it in one fell swoop of what is being provided to their unduplicated students and the monies that are involved.
So this one is going to need, just going to say, it's going to get a little bit of tweaking as we look at it.
But here it is.
This is, again, the annual update part, the total planned expenditures, and then the estimated actuals when it's really being written.
How much did you spend on these budgeted and these actions and services?
There's our outreach.
where we've been and what we've done so far.
We've had the 12 in-person presentations with approximately 850 participants.
I said our webinar.
And then again, we'll have more Tuesday at two webinars.
And then we're developing an online survey with each of the sections and the instructions itself.
asking for feedback and we will push that out through all of the listservs and again talk about it at the LCFF stakeholders meeting, state and federal program directors that are meeting.
Tomorrow we will give them an update or Friday we will give them an update of any feedback that you provide for us and then moving forward.
I think that is it.
I am happy to answer any questions.
Let me turn to our liaisons, Irene and Sue, for comment.
So, let me just say, Jevon, I just want to thank you so much for all the outreach and stakeholder engagement.
I was at the CPAC meeting when you did this presentation and the opportunity to give input from practitioners.
And what I'm, what the voices were was this seems so much more, so clear and is not as long as it was before.
it's clear to understand.
And that's been one of the complaints is these LCAPs have grown to be just these huge documents and it's hard to explain it as well.
So I just wanted to tell you how much I appreciate that.
The other comment was is that we've talked about the future vision of some of these cells being pre-populated at some point as an E-template.
And I know we've had some conversation about that.
And what is the thinking about that?
Again, I think that this whole design and requirements just begs for an e-template type of approach that would allow them to, if you go back to
This table itself is the data input table, and this would pre-populate and automatically populate those other expenditures and other tables as well.
It would also, much like our e-template works now, is it takes the goals, actions, and services and rolls them forward into the following year.
So there's not just that data entry cumbersome, just busy work, if you will, of filling that part out.
So I think that that
both with the e-template system would allow any information that would be consistent and constant to carry through year after year, and then also be able to update any figures like the annual update section as well.
Does that answer your question?
Yeah.
And we had a discussion at CPAC about the benefit of an Excel spreadsheet versus not.
So you might want to highlight that and also highlight the conversation about option A and B, because I thought that was helpful as well.
OK.
if an LEA chooses, until the state board chooses to say we are going to go to an e-template system, we will go to, you know, we have the option of the e-template that the department has worked with San Joaquin to develop our e-template system that we have now.
And if not, we have the Excel.
We'll have kind of two platforms.
One is an Excel document and also the Word document.
The benefit of
Any of this approach is you can take any of these tabs and share them as, you know, sharing them to the public as a standalone.
You could almost put together a custom presentation for your public for each of those, you know, pages and would help minimize it.
But it's, in a Word and Excel document, it's a little bit clunky because you have the two and they don't, and those two platforms don't talk to each other.
It's hard to, so I'm not sure if I'm addressing your needs for that.
And then the option A and option B, again, I think has been well received and not liked.
There's feedback on both option A and both B of liking it and not liking it.
And I think, again, the pro for option B is the ability to write generalized goals and have those aligned with an LEA's strategic plan.
The benefits of option A and having those prioritized goals, two or three of those, one or two of those, again, allows you to really focus.
This is our need.
We have other needs and we have other things that we're doing well.
But this is our focus.
And then the secondary goal to support that prioritization is how are you doing it.
I love to cook.
And I kind of think of it as the success in supporting the prioritization is my sauce that's simmering while I'm really focusing on the main parts of the dish.
And so I'm focused here knowing that I'm hopefully being successful over here as things are simmering.
But that's kind of the thought, if you will, with the prioritization of goals and also the maintaining success.
We're coming into lunch.
Then it's just looking how well you're doing on your metrics.
Much less exciting.
So thank you, Jeff.
First, I'll just stipulate to what I said in item one.
To me, this is an example of continuous improvement and very serious stakeholder engagement.
So I really appreciate that.
And that's what you're seeing here.
The difference is, and I want to just be clear about this, is the redesign of the template is a result of a legislative mandate.
And it's also the result, like all things in the legislature, of compromises between competing interests.
Who wants this?
Who wants that?
So I just want people to be aware of that, that we are implementing what the legislature has asked us to do.
Because we're going to hear from, and we've seen in letters,
I think people who had requests to the legislature that maybe didn't make it into the statute or quite the way they wanted to.
So we just need to be aware of that.
Related to that, too, is I think because this is such an organic process and changes are being made, I do believe that many of the letters that we receive do not reflect the current template that you have.
So kind of keep that in mind.
And this is just a discussion.
It's not for action right now.
But I think sometimes we get a little confused when we're not working on the current version.
The other thing, I just want to emphasize sort of the underlying reason for this, because it's easy to get caught in the details.
I think the intent really is to try to continue to send a message to LEAs that this should be your strategic plan.
This is what you should be focusing on.
I think for the last several years,
We continue to have this competition between the LCAP as a compliance document versus, no, no, this should be a planning document.
It should be reflecting what your district is about, what your expectations are for your students.
And two good things to me in this process are, one, and Jeff emphasized a lot, is it allows LEAs to set priorities, to say, we're going to deal with these three
goals right now, that's really what we're working on.
I like your analogy, I love to cook.
Other things are happening over here on the sauce and it's simmering, but right now I really gotta focus on cutting up this pepper or whatever it happens to be.
So just remember that, that really is a huge improvement in my view in allowing LEAs to focus.
And the last thing is that it does continue to emphasize this notion that we're moving to a coordinated funding system
and away from categorical funds.
So, you know, let's not, you know, put these kids in these little boxes because that's what matches up to money.
We care about all children, and we especially care about the children that we're providing extra funding for.
So, just that's my opening comments.
I do have a couple of suggestions after we hear public comment.
Thank you.
At this point, we can take clarifying comments and then save your big philosophical thoughts until after the public comment.
Okay?
Kim, did you want to?
Yes.
So I just had a procedural question around today is about continuing to seek
feedback from the board, but also through public comment.
What's a little less clear to me is how and whether we'll see a preview of the instructions that will come forward in November, or whether in November we will be seeing them for the first time and also voting on them then.
The instruction we'll provide to you through an information memorandum in October, and that one, it gives...
preloads, front loads the entire package for you as the board, but also affords the public the opportunity to read those and look at those and respond to those instructions as well.
And again, with that, seeking the feedback, we are developing an online survey.
We'll go out, again, to CPAG and also the LCFF to seek feedback.
But your first look would be through an information memorandum in October.
Anyone else?
You're going to wait also?
Okay.
Member Rucker?
So my question is about the two options on the two templates.
And I was going to ask the same question that board member Brownson also asked concerning the instructions.
But beyond the instructions that the LEAs will receive for using the templates, I want to understand what are the changes in the training or the consulting work that the county offices
are going to be doing in working with these new changes.
And again, I'm concerned that we'll be hearing about that in November when we're asked to vote on the item.
There is an impact about the work of the counties that I think also needs to be considered on this work going forward.
So I'm hoping that we can hear from or get an understanding, not only about what the counties are doing, but even
in the advisory capacity that CCESA has in the training that they're doing, I think we need to understand the impact of this legislative work that we're trying to implement, how all of that's going to look, because it's just not on the work that you all have done, and it's not just about the instructions that will be written.
We have a context that that decision has to be made in that I think has to technically be considered as well.
Yes, we have 20 speakers signed up for item 2.
We're going to ask for the first 10 to line up when we call your name.
Rachel Maves, Marlene Batista, Olivia Yaha, Emma Romero, Norma Camacho, Elizabeth Jimenez Salinas, Ruth Brajas, Bernice Ulfrey, and Eduardo Munoz.
Good morning.
Dr. Marlene Batista representing CABE and currently the Director of English Language Services for Oxnard School District.
Working in a school district that has committed itself to parent engagement, we pride ourselves in being inclusive.
with our stakeholders in planning and writing the LCAP as a collaborative process.
However, CABE and other advocacy groups realize that many, this may not be the case in all districts in California, especially when it comes to parents who are non-English speaking.
We do not see that the new LCAP template addresses this and ensures that LEAs are held accountable for meaningful parent input.
We'd like to recommend that SBE require districts to provide reference to the LCAP activities and goals that were impacted by stakeholder feedback.
We've provided you in our letter a suggested format with a third column in the meaningful stakeholder engagement attachment where districts could explicitly provide the impact or changes made to the LCAP by stakeholder input.
We see this as the only way to ensure that this important process happens and it allows our stakeholders to see their footprint on the LCAP.
Thank you.
Good morning, Olivia Yaya, CADIS president.
In reference to agenda item two, section E, goals, actions, and services, it is important for school sites that are receiving supplemental and possibly concentration funds be able to identify what specific actions and services are being provided to the various student groups.
We are including the sample school site allocation template for your consideration.
We would also like to recommend that different goals need to be set for the various student groups, specifically ELs, foster youth, and low income.
If we are expecting all students to grow the same percentage than the students' groups, we will never be able to reduce the achievement gap.
We will always continue to have parallel lines.
For all student groups to increase in their achievement, districts must establish specific differentiated targets for EL foster youth, low income, Latino, African American.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Emma Romero.
My son attends San Ysidro High School and my family is one of 1,200 families affected by the Sweetwater Union High School District decision on elimination of school buses for San Ysidro High School.
I drove for more than eight hours to have one minute of your time and bring to you this information
I want to inform you that many parents, students, and teachers do not agree with the superintendent, Dr. Karen Janney's decisions.
And I come here to ask you for your help to return the school buses for San Ysidro High School students.
Honor Tony Thurman, please help us.
Thank you so much.
I just want to say welcome, Ms.
Pangilinan.
Your voice is an invaluable gift as we further develop and refine our new system of support.
Thank you for your contribution.
Over the last few months, I have had the opportunity to participate in the LCAP Redesign Committee as the COE representative.
I would like to take this opportunity to express my gratitude for the state's modeling of continuous improvement and engagement of stakeholders.
In joining the committee, I brought my lens as a former teacher, principal, superintendent, and now senior director at a county office.
My perspective was greatly broadened as I listened to concerns from public advocates, CTA, CDE, SBE, charter, district, COE colleagues.
In developing a tightly nested system, the necessity of working together as a unified team to assess, design, and develop strong systems and structures within our educational landscape is vital for success.
I cannot speak for the other members of the team, but will speak for myself in saying the rich dialogue and discussions provided opportunity for greater understanding.
Thank you to the members of the State Board for providing cross-organizational collaboration, and thank you, Mr. Breshears, for your leadership throughout this process.
It is my hope that continued opportunities are brought forth for us to model the breakdown of silos, just as we are asking districts to do the same.
Thank you.
Good morning, I'm Elizabeth Jimenez Salinas, and I'm here from Californians Together.
You know, language matters, and the LCAP development process that we're all going through right now, where we're looking at words and phrases and making sure that they're clear and that they say what we really want them to say, is such an important part of the reason that a template is being developed.
And local control, which is part of this, means that decisions and planning are expected to be made locally with participation from community stakeholders.
In order to do this properly, local school districts must reach out to the families in their communities, participate, and not all of them speak English.
We ask that you direct the CDE to take responsibility to translate the final template into the languages of California's identified school communities.
This would reduce redundancy of effort, cost to taxpayers, and increase timeliness and assure clarity, consistency, and accuracy, and not increase the local workloads.
The final, excuse me, okay, thank you.
Good morning, I'm Ruth Barajas, also representing Californians Together.
And I'd like to comment on how much we appreciate the inclusion of the language and the reflections of identified needs, where you're prompting areas of low performance and performance gaps among students.
And the steps that are taken to address those is an improvement.
However, the prompts as proposed will allow the LEAs to provide generalities to the whole student as a response.
And we believe this significantly weakens the identified needs of significant subgroups.
So we believe the stakeholders want to have a document that's at a glance.
They can see what's happening, reflecting their priorities.
And so we recommend that these templates specifically request them to the LEAs to identify subgroups for each of these sections that are the subgroups that are performing at the two highest performance levels and the two lowest performance levels for identified needs.
And if these are admitted, the county offices of education may not be able to necessarily review for them.
So we'd really like you to consider that.
Thank you so much.
Good morning.
My name is Dr. Bernice Onofre from Santa Monica.
Today I'm representing California Together.
Attachment one, page nine, the template regarding service to unduplicated pupils, students should be desegregated by English learners, low SES, and foster youth.
Attachment two, page three, the second column for stakeholder engagement template needs to have a summary of their input.
And we strongly recommend the third column to indicate the district response and the impact on the LCAP.
The LCAP, as I heard, the strategic plan for the district and the single plan of student achievement is a strategic plan for the schools.
Therefore, I strongly recommend that the school site council be added a stakeholder group because it formulates and submits a single plan to the district for approval by the board.
In my decades of involvement as a parent and community member and in conducting research in my dissertation, I found that there is lack of English learner parent engagement.
Time.
Time?
Thank you.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Charisse Guerrero.
Martha Hernandez, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Lorraine Richards, Mary Perry, Liz Gouin, Pakola Mandiga, Monica Scott-Green, Sasha Shane, and Leticia Garcia.
Good morning.
My name is Norma Camacho.
I'm a director of EL Services in Azusa, and today I'm representing Californians Together.
The current law requires LEAs to describe in their LCAPS services for ELs when they comprise a significantly numerical student population in the instructions, which will require many LEAs to address this requirement as EL students comprise over 1.2 million students in California.
We recognize the prototype reflects current law, but believe the law does not prohibit language in the template from going beyond the instructions.
We recommend that there be prompts in the template mirroring the law to include, at minimum, language acquisition programs and professional development opportunities specific to teachers serving English learner students.
We hope that these prompts with the instructions will provide greater transparency regarding the services and programs offered to English learner students and that similar prompts be included to address the efforts for foster youth.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Harold Omooz, and I'm an assistant professor at San Jose State, and I'm also here representing here Californians Together and the parents of the English language advisory committee, one of which I'm a president.
I'm here to express my concern about the parent engagement.
While it's substantial progress with regards to what we have so far, still invites for vagueness in terms of what it means to really involve parents in the process.
Whoever has been in education, I have seen how often we have parents who are used as rubber stamp.
Often districts are complaining that parents are not participating enough and such stereotypes like parents not caring about education is something that falls on English learners often.
If we show parents that actions are completely tied to their input, then they can see that there is follow through and that may be inviting to participate in the strategic plan that was mentioned earlier and not just an instrument for compliance.
So connect actions to specific feedback in order to get parents and engage as it is the spirit of the law.
Thank you.
Good morning, Lorraine Richards, California Teachers Association.
CTA supports new changes to LCAP template stakeholder engagement section.
In particular, CTA appreciates having a detailed list of stakeholders and a description for how stakeholders will impact the development of the LCAP.
The LCAP is designed to be a collaborative effort with all stakeholders.
As a parent of a seventh grader, it is imperative to report
The report gives details on how stakeholders are truly being engaged if the LCAP process is really collaborative.
We feel the new table in the stakeholder engagement section is more transparent and easier to read and appreciate the clarity.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Cherise Guerra, District Relations Administrator for the Sobrato Early Academic Language Model, also known as SEAL.
And I'm a former site principal and Director of Curriculum Assessment Instruction for California School District.
and I'm also representing Caltalk.
The promise of LCAP is local control with authentic, meaningful stakeholder input.
Based on my experience, local control has been realized.
Meaningful stakeholder input has been reduced to compliance.
Initially, when LCAP was first implemented, my former district, like many, took stakeholder input seriously.
Surveys were created.
Meetings were held at different times of the day to accommodate families.
Childcare was provided.
white butcher paper filled with ideas and innovation were gathered.
When I left the district in June, LCAP had been pared down to five meetings a year, 4 p.m., no childcare, and district employees who were mandated to attend.
Parents, families became discouraged and stopped attending because they realized the district was gonna do whatever it wanted regardless of their input.
The district was going through the motions of what the law requires and lost the moral compass and spirit of LCFF.
This is a facade.
My name is Martha Hernandez, and I am the policy director for Californians Together.
Caltalk has long advocated for LCFF's promise to greater equity for high needs students, specifically to close the achievement gap.
We acknowledge and appreciate
all of the improvements to the template to align with the intent of AB 1840 and the input received from the multiple stakeholder meetings that were held.
And we also appreciate the goal to make the LCAP a strategic plan for the district that focuses on continuous improvement.
With regard to the increased and improved services summary, however, there remains a lack
clear guidance in the required description section.
In addition to the box provided to explain the proportionality obligation, which is a welcome improvement, additional language, a prompt, should be included offering guidance to districts, asking them, prompting them to provide a description of how services for English learners, foster youth, and low-income students
as compared to services for all students are being increased and improved by the percentage required.
Thank you for this opportunity.
Good morning.
I'm Mary Perry.
I'm with the California State PTA.
And I really want to echo this need for the LCAP to be part of a strategic planning process.
That's the way that actually you get meaningful stakeholder engagement rather than it being a separate LCAP meeting.
But I also want to talk a little bit about the format itself of this template.
Mr. Breshears characterized the technology right now as clunky.
Well, it's just as clunky as it was four or five years ago when this process started.
And one of the things I hope this board will do is make it a priority.
to move forward with using real technology that exists today so that ultimately it isn't a barrier to family engagement and we don't have to worry about it being 50 pages long, hooray, but rather a real information tool.
Thank you.
Good morning.
Martha Zaragoza Diaz representing CABE and Californians Together.
And while we appreciate the fact that we will be provided instructions in November that hopefully will address our concerns, we still believe that it won't be enough and we need to go beyond that.
So, I would like to reiterate our three major concerns.
The first is the need to include prompts in addition to the instruction describing the language acquisition programs offered to English learners and a description of professional development opportunities made available to teachers in the description of the template.
We believe that existing law does not preclude that from happening.
Second is the need to include prompts and instructions in the template directing the LEAs to provide differentiated target growths.
for all the student groups in addition to the student general population in order to get to the issue of closing the achievement gap.
Without this information, it will not be clear enough in terms of how these student subgroups need to, or what actions need to be taken to close that achievement gap for each of the student subgroups.
Then our third is student engagement, I mean parent engagement, and you've heard the recommendations from previous speakers, thank you.
President Darling-Hammond, members of the board, I'm Dean Drescher on behalf of EdVoice, and I also would like to echo some of what's been said earlier, especially around the increased or improved section of the LCAP template.
We think it should prompt LEAs to demonstrate that each of the services funded and provided on a district or school-wide basis are principally directed and effective in meeting the needs of unduplicated students.
It's our view that better transparency and clarity in that area actually does help improve accessibility and understanding for parents and communities.
Thank you.
Hello.
I'm Liz Guillen.
I'm speaking around stakeholder engagement section on behalf of the Equity Coalition.
The template
is too general around stakeholder engagement.
We agree with some of the prior comments about what it will elicit and our concerns about what it won't.
We believe, too, there should be, while we're at it, identifying, asking for specific stakeholder groups, we think that there should be a prompt to say what
process did you use for engaging students?
I want to emphasize that the CPAG really agreed with us on the stakeholder engagement piece.
They were very concerned that it was so general.
In response to concerns about what we're asking for being
taking a second bite at the apple in the legislation.
The stakeholder engagement section isn't even required in the statute.
And what we're asking for is not a detail as if it was a regulatory process.
We're just asking for a summary so that parents and community can see that they were heard and that it's in the LCAP.
Good morning, Karen Sweat with Making Sense Work.
Why do you not want fiscal accountability?
The plan, the template clearly addresses achievement accountability and you're working towards that, but without SACS resource codes and object codes, there can be no fiscal accountability and there can be no verification.
Please consider encouraging districts and school sites
to include more transparent information as to the specifics about the kind of money that they're using specifically with supplemental and concentration.
Thank you.
Good morning Leticia Garcia with Riverside County Office of Education, we'd like to take the opportunity to thank staff, both at the department and board for all of the stakeholder input sessions that they hosted we were an active participant in those sessions.
We also are here in support of the prototype.
We think it's a vast improvement from the current LCAP template.
We believe that this is the prototype is instrumental as a platform to allow districts in their quest for continuous improvement.
We specifically like also the options A and B.
Because it allows districts to choose an option that best meets their local context, as well as the size of their districts, as you have heard earlier.
And lastly, we look forward to the continued input sessions on developing the instructions that will be coming before you in November.
So thank you for the opportunity to provide comment.
Good morning, Board of Education.
My name is Pakolia Manigault.
I'm a public school parent.
I'm also a current school site council chair.
I'm also a former LCAP coordinator and I'm the executive director of Bay Area Plans.
So I've worked on LCAP before.
It was LCAP before we had LCFF.
This is our 10th mobilization to you to please listen to the voices of students and parents.
You made a commitment to equity and equitable engagement.
from the LCAP process from beginning to end.
You stood here in 2014 and passed regulations that said that you would ensure districts engage families and students from the beginning and yet we are here today to say this template does not reflect that commitment.
Please do not dismiss the commitment you made to us in 2014.
We would not like to immobilize students and parents up here yet again in November
because the commitment to equity is not there.
We do agree with many of the comments around making sure that in the stakeholder engagement section that there is a response to exactly where is that stakeholder engagement reflected in the LCAP.
We also really want to continue to lift up language access.
We still do not have LCAPs across the state as diverse as ours that are translated in languages that parents and students understand.
And we definitely, definitely encourage you to continue to explore the online platform that would help alleviate a lot of problems in districts and counties across the state.
Thank you.
Buenos dias, my name is Alexander Shane.
The proposed changes to the LCAP template dismisses the call for action, transparency, accountability of supplemental and concentrational funds being principally directed to low-income foster youth and English language learners.
Every year districts struggle with providing, increasing, and improving
services for English language learners.
It is clear that the districts and counties are struggling with explaining how the specific needs or circumstances of these students lead them to choose the actions or services in the LCAP and whether it will be effective.
We ask you to continue to explore how we can make sure that the investments with the supplemental and concentration
concentration are clear in the template.
We also agree with the translation of the template.
It is important.
Please keep accountability in the LCAP template.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Monica Green.
Seven years ago, my husband and hundreds of other parents came here as parents of public school children asking for engagement, meaningful engagement.
And we were as excited when LCFF passed as my parents were when the Voting Rights Act passed in 1964.
Today, I stand here similar to the way my parents stand now.
trying to fight for the continuation of engagement and transparency and accountability.
Just as voting rights are being suppressed, unless the template is explicitly asked for, how are dollars being spent?
Where are the voices being heard?
Unless it is asked for, you will not see it in the LCAP.
And the accountability locally will be lost.
So I ask you, please, to send the message to protect accountability, transparency, and engagement of families and students.
Thank you.
Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, state board members, John Affel from Public Advocates.
In particular, the prompt for the Demonstration of Increased and Improved Section does not meet the regulatory standard, and it needs to.
It's way too general.
Bearing in the instructions how to comply with the regulations is not working to date.
LAUSD has nearly $900 million in one
item on their LCAP, all SNC money that is justified in three sentences, none of which explains why it's principally directed or why it's going to be effective.
There needs to be a table in the prompt that says, why do you think this is first and foremost delivering on high-need pupil goals, and why do you think it's going to be effective?
That's very simple.
It's not technical.
It needs to be in the prompt.
And that was the grand bargain.
that we struck in allowing much greater flexibility and getting rid of categoricals with that level of transparency.
And it needs to be in the LCAP.
Thank you.
For public comment, let's open up the discussion.
Yes.
First of all, I want to thank everyone that came here today to provide public comment because I wasn't here in 2014 when this was initially passed, but it's been sustained advocacy on your behalf and trust that this will be implemented.
So thank you for that.
I know that sometimes less is more and sometimes less is less.
So, I want to focus on the EL language acquisition programs and services because I do believe that we need to give it a home.
It needs to be a prompt somewhere.
If it's in the instructions, my guess would be that it's going to be overlooked.
And I highly doubt that a county office of education will deny an LCAP template because it does not address the services.
And I think that we've also, in the August memo, made a case for why this is needed.
So when the EL student subgroup in the academic indicator became ELs plus RFEPs, there was a lot of concerns that the performance of students, of English learners, would be skewed by the reclassified students.
We know that in general, some schools and some districts were able to bump up to yellow.
because of the reclassified students.
But the memo in August said that if you look at those schools that were identified in the red and you disaggregate the reclassified students, they are far from the LD3.
And so we know that as students reclassify, they're not being served and they're not being monitored as we said they would be if we put them in the same category with the L students, right?
Because we wanted to see them from initial to reclassified.
to monitor the progress.
The problem is that we don't have a codified anywhere.
So we set it, it's in policy, that's what our L subgroup is, but there's nowhere, and in fact, the expectation's not even known that they're expected at the school site level to monitor these students post reclassification.
And so I think that not only do we need to describe the program available to our English learners and the services, but we need to go a little bit deeper and look at our reclassified students and know how they're doing.
We need to monitor them.
And if not the LCAP, then where?
Because we set that policy, but we didn't indicate where the monitoring would take place.
So, that's one.
Two, when we're identifying schools or LEAs for comprehensive support or under ESSA, there's nowhere in the template that indicates what prompted the identification.
What subgroups prompted that?
So without knowing that, how do we know that the program goals and the resources are being properly aligned to address the needs of the LEA and the schools?
So I think that we need to do a better job of identifying what subgroups prompted identification
and what areas, under what state indicators.
Without that, how do we know that the rest of the LCAP is even relevant to the need of the LEA?
So, those are two big ones there, but I have a lot more to share, but I'll just stop there because I do think
that we need to be specific with the prompt of the L students, that we need to monitor reclassified students, and that we need to call out where the students, what subgroups prompted identification.
There is a push under LCFF with the new state superintendent on narrowing the achievement gaps, but our LCAP is not really reflecting that right now.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Whenever I get this item, I feel like I have a split personality because I have to look at it from a policy perspective when I'm up here and then also a practitioner perspective.
The two sometimes do not reconcile.
I know in the past that I voted for LCAP changes in the template.
And then when it's a weekend in the evening and I'm trying to fill out the template, I'm like, who voted for this?
Why are we doing this?
This doesn't make any sense.
So I understand that, and I'm trying to balance the two here.
So first of all, I appreciate the process you went through and the willingness to just not even look at the old template and going back to the law.
and kind of reconstructing it from scratch.
So I think that's a great approach, because often we get stuck.
We spend a lot of time developing something, and all we want to do is just tweak around the edges instead of re-looking at it.
So I appreciate that process.
I also appreciate the looking at an option A and B, and this is the first time I've heard a little bit of allowing LEAs to be able to kind of maybe choose which direction they want to do to fit their needs.
The issue with the policy and practitioner piece of me is that we continue to try to design something that's trying to fit all of the LEAs in California.
And that's why nobody's happy.
Because there are districts with hundreds and hundreds of schools, and then there are districts with one school or two schools.
And we're trying to develop a template that is trying to meet the legislation
and then meet the needs of all of these different districts and all of the different geographies.
So I think that now that we're starting to broach on, oh, maybe you could try option A and B, we might look at
templates that might meet more of the needs of an LEA that have two to ten schools, and another set that might meet LEAs with a different set of schools, and the large, large districts is where I'm hearing a lot of the angst and the lack of stakeholder input, that might need a different template as well, all meeting the law.
and the legislation, but perhaps structured in a way that makes sense for that particular LEA.
So I would like us to explore that.
On the budgetary pieces, I'm not sure, looking at it, and I have to kind of see how it all fits together, where I'm hearing our stakeholders saying is that they're not seeing how the concentration grants
and the additional funds to best serve those students.
How would you actually be able to tease those funds out?
And having filled one of these in, sometimes it's not that clear in a school or LEA budget because you're supplementing certain things with a mixture of different funds.
So it's not easy to split them out.
I'm not sure if this is still clear enough to be able to do that where
You may have to have professional development classified, and these specific positions are with the additional funds, and then these positions are not.
So I'm not quite sure if it gets to that.
And also a point I wanted to make is that our LCFF funding is now plateauing.
We're not getting the increases as we have in the past.
So to show the increases in services from where it was before is going to become more difficult.
to do that, and so I don't know.
That's just a comment on the difficulty of trying to complete this, meet a strategic need, and also be as transparent as possible with the funding, and especially doing that in large LEAs that have so many schools, and so many different types of schools.
Well, let me begin by saying this is a good opportunity to practice that exercise in plausible deniability.
So when I meet with stakeholder groups or practitioners, particularly my friends, or at least those who still claim me as friends in my former district that's now part of the Twin Rivers Unified School District, I often begin those conversations on the LCAP with, it's not my fault.
So we're sitting here, I was on the board in 2014 when we started down this road of trying to craft this template.
And we knew at the time when we implemented the first template that it was insufficient for the purposes and goals of what we were trying to implement with this broad idea that's called the Local Control Accountability Plan.
And I recall at the time, there was actually one county office, when the first round of LCAPs were submitted, rejected all of them.
For many of the reasons we are hearing today, that is of great concern.
And so I think that it doesn't really matter what the size of the district is.
Planning is planning.
And good planning that reflects feedback and input from stakeholders that forms the foundation of a strategic plan is good planning regardless of the size of the district.
So I think that what we're really hearing, not only from the stakeholders, but also from the frustration of the fact that we are still working on evolving and continuing to grow and improve a planning template, we have to think about what it is we're actually trying to accomplish with this planning template.
And there's a clear tension about what is going on.
The template itself is serving a purpose of implementing a legislative mandate.
And as a compliance document, it serves a number of needs for meeting the requirements and the mandates in the legislation.
But as you are clearly hearing from stakeholders, and this has not changed in the six plus years that we've been doing this work, what has clearly not changed is that the stakeholders expect this plan and the guidance to implement the legislative mandate
to do more.
So what I clearly heard, and I understand from parents your frustration about the one minute.
But that one minute of time that you come and give your feedback, you are clearly heard.
And I clearly heard your frustration that the document remains not transparent.
That there are other things that the plan itself
could do in creating a clear outline of what the work of the district will be and what the goals of the district are.
And for the students that clearly percolate to the top as the local priorities, how those differentiated needs and services for those students should be articulated in the plan.
And so while we set a table and we set some standards about what districts should be doing, I'm clearly hearing from stakeholders that there's nothing wrong with exceeding those standards or exceeding those expectations.
In fact, we want our students, if your child comes home with straight A's on their report card, clearly they're exceeding the standards and we're very happy about that.
Parents are asking districts and expecting the leadership of districts
to do the same.
So that's one thing that I clearly heard.
But the thing that I also heard that's actually more disturbing, and this gets to the other part of the other half of the tension in the room, even from the outset there has always been this desire to some way shape or fit the LCAP in the mold of what we always have understood the school planning model should be.
or has been.
And so I'm not going to say it's resistance to changing the way we plan.
I think that there's a comfort with doing things the way we've always done it because it helps to understand or create a model for what people seem to think is a good practice.
So what I heard today that really concerns me for many of the stakeholders is the feeling that there's some level of salutary neglect
In the work that has gone on with implementing the LCAP in many districts, it's gone from being a real stakeholder engagement model to being a compliance activity with fewer meetings, fewer interactions with stakeholders to simply complete the plan, complete the update, and check off a list of activities that are required to do the planning.
If the template does nothing more than create a model for the type of questioning
the type of engagement, and the type of work that districts are expected to do, we have done more than the statute requires.
But if the template continues to simply refine how to make developing the LCAP easier, then we are going down the road of concern that many stakeholders have voiced today.
So this would be my philosophical advice.
I think it's important for us to, I think the work that's been done to create these two models is a far cry of improvement from what my mental model was at the time the Budget Act added these requirements and implemented these changes.
So I think the imagination it took to create these options and the work that your team did was absolutely excellent.
But I think you need to hear what stakeholders are saying
that it does nothing to improve the practices of leadership and strategic planning that should be the model for the effective use of the LCAP.
So either in the way the guiding questions for completing the template have been done or in the way that you write the instructions, there needs to be something done to stop some of the ineffective practices that are leading to the kind of neglect
or even the kind of static practices that do not enhance or even do not encourage good stakeholder engagement.
So while I am not asking you to change the template, I am asking you to consider how can you write guidance, how can you work with county offices and CCESA to make sure that the concerns you heard today
can be crafted into guidance and to instructions that will alleviate the very valid concerns that I'm hearing.
Because that's been my longstanding concern from the outset.
And I'm concerned right now it's not, it doesn't seem like it's going to be resolved unless we take some affirmative steps and assert in some aggressive ways in the guidance and in the instructions on how to do this best.
Member Navo, and then Patio Brownson, and then I'll come to Member Sandoval.
So, Jeff, having lived this, I appreciate the efforts that have been made to try and modify what has been, for locals, a very time-consuming and hours of input into the original template itself.
What I would say to us is I think we're living continuous improvement.
Because we're actually living the idea or the principle that every improvement requires change, but not every change leads to improvement.
And we're living that in this template model.
And I think that what we would consider is the only way to put ourselves in a situation as a state where a change leads to something other than improvement is to continually test and modify that tool.
I mean, so if we don't practice that,
The bane to improvement is trying to be perfect every time and trying to be perfect out of the gate.
So maybe, Jeff, something to think about.
is how we're going to test this tool with the focus that board member Rutgers had on what we're trying to specifically improve for the stakeholders, and then modify the tool as it continues to be used, incorporating the stakeholders that we heard today that are so valued, and then those stakeholders with boots on the ground, county offices and locals.
Certainly, I would think that no one in the field is thinking that this template is going to be the template.
It's going to have to be modified.
One of the things I would suggest that we might consider is one of our speakers pointed out that words matter.
And I think as much as we don't want to wordsmith the tool, there is an element under the focus of goals where we ask the districts, what do you want to accomplish?
And how will you define success?
When we ask the locals what they want to accomplish, it could simply be that a local district wants to accomplish an event.
They want to put an event on.
And they define success by actually holding the event versus asking them, what do you want to specifically improve?
And how will you know that that change is an improvement?
So in other words, if we're going to model the theory of improvement,
We might reframe the questions so that the locals come into it with, what are you specifically trying to improve and for whom?
And how are you going to measure that improvement, as opposed to what do you want to accomplish and how do you define success?
Because the accomplished success is exactly what is the tension here.
I can do things, and I can say I did them.
And most of our districts are learning the theory of improvement as we go.
And that might be something to consider, Jeff, down the road.
And then I have members Sandoval, Pangelina, and then Burke.
So I'll just align myself with board member Ortiz-Lacombe's earlier comments about the need for greater prompts on the Yale section.
And then more broadly, I just want to return to this topic of data around disparities of both expenditures, goals, and strategies, and outcomes for children being specifically articulated.
I think several of the folks who offered public comment lifted up this issue of wanting greater transparency of both the funding flow as well as the changes in programming that are available to children.
I think part of the bargain that LCFF struck was to create greater local control and accountability, which presumes that parents have the capacity and the data and transparency necessary to be able to know what is happening with local funding.
And it is a little disconcerting that we're moving in the direction of lumping all LCFF funds as one sort of
undifferentiated whole when that's not how the formula works.
I think the direction from the legislature was around largely plain speak and a lack of technical sort of insider speak for school districts.
But I don't think there is a accompanying push to make that component of wanting to uplift disparities data as part of the legislative push.
I don't think that was part of the legislators
intention or language offered.
I think the inclusion of targets and goals are also on the last page of the template, I believe that's page nine, has been signaled as something that just needs to be more robustly spun out.
And also I think aligns very much with CDE's desire to make sure that we are actually making a dent in the achievement gaps that are not unique to big urbans or any particular geography.
It is, it inheres in every corner of the state and there are fewer districts that are getting it right than there are that are getting it, that are falling short of the mark.
The last thing I'll just comment on is on the additional engagement components.
I think there's already been some progress, I think, between the time of the initial release of the agenda and what was presented in the PowerPoint around articulating which groups were heard from and what impact was made.
And I think you have willing participants to negotiate with.
several of whom are in the audience who I think could provide a lot of useful feedback.
Lastly, I'll just say that that piece around strategic planning that board member Rucker and also board member Burr lifted up as sort of shining a light on what the ambition is rather than the sort of minimum compliance expectation is something
That is, in some ways, I think it's an honor to sort of be challenged as a state to think more robustly about what that can mean.
That communities are saying they want to participate and actually be more active co-contributors in the shaping of their local educational policy is both a challenge, but it's also an invitation and one that I think we should actually be honored to meet.
Before my comments, I have a question about plans for a translation and also interpretation of the template.
If there are any that exist right now.
Currently, the current template talks about anything in reports adhering to this, to statute of any reports being sent home, being translated in that, in that, um, that's that, um, baseline.
Um, certainly we can work with, um, our clearinghouse in, in the building to look at translating the
the template itself, you know, and explore that.
You spoke, looking at it, certainly to explore that.
I just, I really appreciate the memo and the very clear recommendations from Elizabeth Jimenez Salinas with Californians Together.
Very clear recommendations for translating the written template.
but also accessing resources throughout the state where we have translators and interpreters in so many different languages, and working with them as partners to actually make this document more accessible.
And then the need for video interpretation when written language systems don't exist, and also including American Sign Language as well.
So using video technology to really increase access and promote
better engagement with our stakeholders, our parents, and our families.
So I just wanted to mention that as being very important.
Thank you.
So as a student, I definitely wanted to give my input just on how the community might view this new template.
So I do think that it's a lot simpler on the eyes
When I first saw my first LCAP, it was extremely overwhelming, but this definitely is more streamlined, but like many people who have spoken, I do agree, I'm a little concerned about the stakeholder engagement portion.
I know the last template said explicitly how, when, with whom, and I think that my district specifically really tries to engage with their stakeholders, but I know that that's not the same.
for every district, and I do want to reiterate what board member Rucker was talking about.
Again, I think that it's really important, if you use this tool to keep districts accountable, it's very useful, but if it becomes more of a compliance piece, then a lot of what the community wants to provide input, it is just overlooked.
So that's really all of my concerns.
So, I want to reinforce a couple of things.
First, I do really appreciate Matt's comments about talking about improvement versus accomplishment, because I do think it can be seen as an end, not a means to an end, which I think is what we're trying to get at.
The other thing, I just, I resonate with a lot of the comments and certainly with the public input around stakeholder engagement.
I'll just say for me, and there were a number of people who said, you know, they were here at the beginning.
They continue to be here.
I can remember the hundreds of especially students who would come and talk about how important their voice was, but also parents and other members of our stakeholder communities.
So it sort of breaks my heart to hear that that's very, that that's fallen off in some communities.
And I don't think we want to do anything in the template to reinforce that that's okay.
So I really would suggest that we look at the stakeholder engagement piece again.
I'll just say, this is a lot to talk about words, and I think I can't stand the word impact.
It's not supposed to be a verb, for those of you who used to be English teachers.
impacted the development I really don't like, but I do think that we need to think about how do we ask for, how is it solicited, and how is it reflected in the LCAP somehow in that way?
And I want to offer you a suggestion about a resource.
The California Collaborative for Educational Excellence has a community initiative that's funded, that's working in San Bernardino County to try to look at what does robust community engagement look like?
And I don't know if you've consulted with them yet or not, but incorporating those suggestions about to make sure that folks in their individual contexts can engage in that kind of robust engagement and talk about what did it mean to us on our planning process.
That's really what we're trying to get at here.
And I worry a little bit that it's being reduced to a little bit of a checkbox.
And then that sends a message, just as we heard passionately from our stakeholders
that that's OK to just do a checkbox.
And it's not OK to just do a checkbox.
So I really hope that you'll look at that.
The last two things I want to mention, the instructions.
I just want to reinforce what board member Patio Bronson said, that we'll get a memo in October, and there will be explicit opportunity not only for board members, but for board members to react to that.
before we have to take action in November.
So just, again, want to kind of get that on the record.
I wrote down the last thing.
Oh, and the electronic, yes, I knew fleas.
This notion about an electronic template just seems to me to be such a no-brainer.
I mean, Mary Perry from PTA, I think that was kind of her comment.
So we worked so diligently to get the dashboard to a place that, hey, it actually reflects the technology that we develop in California.
and that we know works and that is accessible to everybody who needs to access it.
I think we have to do that here.
That has to be a high priority so that the drilling down and some of the information that you know is there, you use the term forward facing, inward facing, et cetera, but the way we're looking at it, it looks like a static document and it's so hard to kind of wrap your head around.
Whatever we need to do to encourage the development of this and the accessibility of an electronic template to all LEAs, I strongly encourage.
Just to reinforce a couple of those points, I think that the focus on improvement rather than just accomplishment is a really important strategy and for whom is really important.
press for an electronic platform, which may require some resources, and we probably need to look into that and figure out what that would be so that we can really represent what people are trying to communicate in a way that others can receive it and make sense of it.
So I appreciate that as well.
Wonderful comments.
Thank all of the people who spoke to us.
The for whom is so important, and I was struck by
You know, we're so happy to welcome Brenna to our table today, and she represents the Sweetwater Union High School District, and the paradox of then hearing from Emma Romero, who drove eight hours here to tell us about a thousand kids who've lost transportation to school in that same district, and the for whom is really an important question for, you know, districts to be conjuring with around the way in which they're representing the LCAP.
challenges and strategies that they undertake.
So I think we've heard a lot of great comment.
It's great that people are hanging in there with the process.
And we appreciate all the good work that's been done to simplify.
And I think you've got some clear recommendations about areas to continue to work on so that this really accomplishes what we're hoping for.
We do not have a need to vote on this item.
So we just want to thank you very much for the presentation.
Thank everyone for their comments and input.
We're going to take this opportunity to adjourn for lunch, because if we go into the next item, you'll be really hangry before we get to the end of it.
So it's 1130.
We'll be back at 1215.
All right.
Thank you.
Okay, we're going to reconvene after our lovely lunch.
What an indulgence to have time for lunch.
Okay, we're going to reconvene and move to item three, which is our mega assessment item.
And thank you very much, Michelle.
The CDE recommends that the California State Board of Education approve the following.
And it's coming up.
The SSRs for the CASP and the, that's the student reports for the CASP and the LPAC as described in attachment two.
And the state superintendent's proposed CSA preliminary threshold scores beginning with the 2018-19 administration as shown as attachment three.
CDE further recommends that the state board authorize staff to make technical edits as necessary in the documents associated with the recommendations above.
And the item will be presented by Michelle Center of the Department of Education.
Thank you.
Michelle, please begin.
Sure.
So well, thank you, President Darling-Hammond.
You did my first slide here, which were the recommendations for actions.
So thank you very much.
The presentation I'm going to do, just to let you know, will speak to these two actions.
And then at the end, I will give you a short, just a few informational tidbits for you to have that are also in the item.
I am going to do this a little out of order, so I apologize.
But the presentation just spoke to me in a different order, which is we're going to talk about the CSA, which is our California Spanish Assessment Threshold Scores.
Then we'll talk about the student score reports.
And then I will give you a few highlights about some other things that don't require your action.
So the first action for approval is the proposed preliminary threshold scores for the California Spanish Assessment, or the CSA.
That includes the overall scale scores for grades three through eight in high school, and that is included in attachment three.
You did have a revised version of attachment three that was sent out, so just want to make sure everyone has that correct version in front of them.
Before I begin, I just want to acknowledge and thank member Ortiz-Lacon.
She was able to come and observe, as well as members of CABE and Californians Together.
They also were able to come and observe the threshold score process that we went through.
So let's start with a little bit of background.
This test, the CSA, replaces the standards-based test in Spanish as the CAST primary language assessment.
It's aligned with a common core in Espanol and is administered to students in grades three through eight and high school.
The test measures a student's reading, writing mechanics, and listening.
This slide shows the timeline that we have used to work up to where we are today.
You can see that the development began with the initial approval of the high-level test design in 2016 by this board.
The board then approved achievement-level descriptors and blueprints in 2017.
The first operational administration of the CSA occurred this spring.
Then we had the standard setting workshop in August, followed by conversations with members of our technical advisory group.
And that brings us to today, where we are asking for your approval.
So the standard setting plan was submitted to you as an information memorandum.
It was submitted to you for August.
It provided you details about the CSA standard setting approach that we used.
The approach for this particular standard setting is called the bookmark method of standard setting.
And the method relies on and utilizes professional judgment of teachers for setting those threshold scores.
So I am going to briefly go over that methodology.
I know it is new for some of the individuals here.
For the CSA, there are three achievement levels.
Therefore, there are two threshold scores that need to be set.
So the panelists, who are California teachers, were tasked with becoming familiar with the range achievement level descriptors.
So range descriptors describe performance across a full range of performance.
So for example, there is a range descriptor for grade three, level two of the CSA.
That describes what students know and can do at that level,
as measured by the CSA.
And in this example, it would be all of those blue characters or clothespins, whatever you want to call that, in this example.
Next, the panel was tasked with defining the borderline student.
In other words, what does the performance look like for a student who is just in level two?
So our visual, that's our blue student with the little bubbles and dots on it right there.
And so that's described as the threshold achievement level descriptor.
And that is a student who is just in level two.
As you can imagine, the kinds of conversations that our educators engaged in to be able to define what that student would know and be able to do was, I think they found it.
In fact, they told me, several of them, they found it to be a great professional learning opportunity for them to engage in those conversations with their peers.
So we also utilize as a tool,
an ordered item booklet.
So an ordered item booklet is basically a booklet of test items, but it is unique because it is in the order from the least difficult to the most difficult based on actual student performance on the test.
So each panelist finds the place in that ordered item booklet that separates achievement levels.
In other words, they're using that borderline student definition, that blue with the little bubble in it student there, that they defined.
They're using that definition to place in this ordered item booklet where they believe the threshold score should be.
During this process, they engage in conversations, they get impact data, and they may revise their individual judgments.
It's not a consensus approach, though.
These are individual judgments that the panelists
engage in.
So who are these panelists?
Well, in this case, they were 56 California bilingual educators who teach Spanish language learners.
Their experience was teaching general education, including English learners, students with special educational needs.
They teach students who may have taken the CSA or may take the CSA in the future.
They all indicated their familiarity with the Common Core State Standards in Espanol.
And those experienced educators were then grouped into grade spans based on the students that they teach.
The panel's judgments are in attachment four.
The CDE then consulted members of its technical advisory group
before coming up with its recommendations, which are in attachment three.
Briefings were then held with members of Californians Together, CABE, PTA, as well as our bilingual coordinators network.
We wanted to make sure that we shared with them both the educator panel's judgments as well as where our recommendations were that you see before you in the item.
So this is consistent with what you see in attachment three.
There's a few columns removed just to simplify it, but these are the threshold scores that are in there.
So they are not identical to the threshold scores that you see that represent the panelist judgments.
They are not identical.
But they do maintain fidelity with the work of the standard setting panel.
All of these threshold scores are within one conditional standard error of measurement of the panel's recommendations.
So in other words, they reflect only slight changes or modifications to the judgments that are within the natural error variance that you would see in the panelist judgments.
We also recommend, and you'll see this term used throughout the item as well as in this slide, we also recommend that you consider these preliminary until further data can be collected.
Unlike our other CAS tests, the CSA is optional and is based on standards that are not yet widely taught.
So, by approving these threshold scores as preliminary, you allow the CDE and its contractor to collect and analyze additional data and information.
So, as part of this optional test, what we did was we collected additional information.
We collected information about a student's classroom instruction in Spanish along with their English language acquisition status.
That additional information is found in attachment five of your item, and it provides a more complete picture of the variability of the CSA test-taking population.
We asked students if they received instruction in Spanish during the 17-18 year.
And results indicated a wide variability with a high of 95% in grade five and a low of 69% in grade nine.
We asked students about the type of programs they were enrolled in.
Results showed that the majority of students in grade three through eight were enrolled in dual immersion programs, whereas in high school, the results showed that the majority were in Spanish as a foreign language.
Probably not surprising.
Lastly, we asked about the percentage of daily instruction that they received in Spanish.
The percentage of instruction during the day decreased as the grade level increased, with over 50% of grade three all the way down to less than 25% for high school.
Again, not that surprising.
Additionally, we looked at the English language acquisition status of the test takers.
We found a large variation by grade.
Grade 9 had the highest percentage of English learners at 62%, compared with only 14% at grade 12.
We also had students whose primary language was English take the test.
That was 33% at grade 3, and only 8% at grade 9.
So our goal is to continue to collect information about this test-taking population.
As you can see, it varies by grade.
I think that's evident and probably expected to some extent.
We also want to continue to find out more about these instructional programs beyond just the labels that you heard me describe just a second ago.
And we want to do that over the next couple operational administrations before we would come and recommend to the state board that you take action on any permanent threshold scores.
So looking beyond today, based on discussions with our stakeholders and testing contractor, the CDE is recommending that a special study be conducted.
It will gather that information that I spoke about in terms of instructional programs.
In this study, the testing contractor will gather information from educators, and our partners, CABE and Californians Together, have already agreed to help us identify schools and districts and help us fashion those questions that we might ask those educators.
Additionally, we want to make sure that we prepare materials for our LEAs to help support them in having those local conversations about these results, making sure that they understand that these results really need to be taken into in the context of the programs that they are operating in their schools and districts.
And we know very well that those programs are very different from site to site.
So I was just going to continue on to my next topic, if that's OK, and have questions at the end.
Does that work?
Unless there's any quick clarifying questions on this item while we've got a question in our minds.
All right, keep going.
The next action before you is the 2019-20 student score reports, or SSRs.
The department asked the board to approve the updated CASP and LPAC student score reports.
The CDE continues to develop the student score reports for all state assessments to provide a consistent look and feel for our families.
The student score reports can be found in attachment two of your item.
Exclusive of the CSA, the 2019-20 CASP student score reports have been updated with technical edits.
Additionally, the parent guardian resources section has been revised to direct parents to the Starting Smarter website
which is available in English and Spanish, and provides families with information about their student score reports, a look at sample test questions by grade level, and a guide to prepare for parent-teacher conferences, as well as access to other high-quality resources.
For the 19-20 school year, the summative LPAC student score report was redesigned with input from parent-focused groups
and educational stakeholders, including PTA, CABE, Californians Together.
These student score reports have been updated to match the design and usability of the CASP wherever possible.
All student score reports meet the accessibility standards for online viewing.
And the CDE has responded to parent and stakeholder input by simplifying the language, using fewer words and more graphics, and streamlining the two-page report.
With the inclusion of the LPAC for the CAS contract, the LPAC student score reports have been formatted to accommodate translations.
With input from parents, the oral language and written language composition graphics have been rearranged horizontally.
We did that in consideration of the Chinese translations that will come.
Finally, the CDE has added a score history section to the summative LPAC report.
Now on to the Spanish report.
Given the preliminary nature of the CSA threshold scores as well as the variability of Spanish instructional programs, the department is recommending a different layout to the student score report for the CSA.
The layout focuses more on describing what a student can do and less on assigning that score into an achievement level.
We hope this change in reporting will provide the meaningful conversations between parents and educators
about the goal and focus of their local Spanish instructional programs.
As you can see, the new student score report provides an overall scale score on the front, along with descriptors on the back that indicate what a student can do within each scale score range.
The maroon bar indicates what scale score range the student achieved.
Additionally, the department is also looking for ways to modify the public reporting website
to more closely align with the student score report that you see before you.
So I was gonna go on to just highlight some updates, unless Linda, you wanna pause for?
Let's just pause and see if there are any clarifying questions, yes, member Ortiz-Nicole.
Thank you, and I wanna say that I had the opportunity to observe the process.
It was very thorough, so I wanna thank all the educators, everyone at the department and ETS.
So I have a question about the,
The 2019 2020 for the California smash assessment, the report, so we're getting, and I'm a parent of a child who took this assessment and so there was a lot of interesting discussions and I had a personal interest in being part of those because, you know.
I got the SBAC scores.
I want to see how he's doing in Spanish now.
But I won't get a number, a level.
I'm going to have a range.
Is that what I'm hearing correctly?
So the report will not show this equals a 1 or a 2, but it's going to be a range that I will be looking at.
Let me state it another way, just to make sure that we're perfectly clear.
It will have a specific scale score.
So it will have a three-digit number that is a scale score.
The proposal is that it not have a level of one, two, or three.
Instead, it'll have a scale score, let's say it's 600, just for example, and then it will show a range.
600 to 650, this is the meaning of that range.
So it doesn't have the level attached to it.
I would say that we would definitely need to have talking points for the field because, again, I was thinking based on the discussions, I was anticipating my son coming home with a very low level, because that's where the trends were.
But now I think that this is
a better way to reflect the data.
But I do think that there's going to be a lot of need for talking points because in my case, my child is in a two-way emergent program.
So whatever I see on the SBAC in developing proficiency in English, I would expect to see something similar in Spanish in terms of his proficiency level.
And if I didn't see that correlation, I would ask
what's happening with the dual two-way emergent program.
I think a lot of parents and a lot of educators would have the same question.
So I'm glad that we're moving more towards a range.
Thank you.
We're getting deeper into the conversation, so let's kind of wait until we get public comment to go back to this in a deep way.
Okay, so now I'm just going to provide some fun highlights.
unlike the rest of the item, which also had a degree of funniness to it, right?
So, the Summer Institute training on interim assessments was held at eight locations across the state in July and August.
We had over 900 educators and other LEA staff participate in the two-day training.
The primary goal of the Summer Institute was to help educators understand the purpose and recommended uses of the interim assessments and the digital library, and the process of analyzing student responses using scoring rubrics and hand scoring to determine instructional next steps.
We continue to look for ways to increase access to this training.
We think it's a very well-received training that we do.
Over the summer, the CDE and ETS convened a meeting for our science cast, which is our California science test standard setting.
We had only, we had about 45 California science educators there.
And we will be providing you with an October memo that describes the standard setting methodology, which is a little different than the methodology that you just heard me describe for what we used for our Spanish test.
So, we'll give you a memo to describe the process that we used.
And then we hope to come to you in November with recommended threshold scores for the CAST test.
I also want to update you that we also have our human resources research organization, which is HMRAO.
That's our CASP independent evaluator.
They're in the process of evaluating the results of the CAST alignment study.
So now that we are getting our 2018-19 results in, they are able to conduct the alignment study and we'll have a report probably in spring 2020.
I also want to update information regarding the launch of the California Alternate Assessment for Science.
The item indicated that it would launch on September 3rd.
But districts are still in the process of reporting their student information to the department that would establish their eligibility to take that alternate assessment.
And so we need that step to happen first.
We hope and anticipate that will be done by the end of this week, and then we'll launch the assessment soon after that is done.
Also want to make sure that you are
I'm sure, anticipating that we will come to you with threshold scores yet again for that same alternate science test that will probably be in fall 2020.
So quite a few threshold scores coming before you for action.
We also just completed our annual assessment North-South information meeting in August.
At that event, we trained and updated over 1,000 district testing coordinators for the year.
So that was fun like always.
Now let's end this presentation from hearing from teachers.
So I have five California public school elementary teachers pictured here on the slide.
They're selected as finalists in this year's assessment contest called Science is Elementary.
Each of these outstanding teachers submitted a classroom activity using formative assessment processes aligned with the California Next Generation Science Test.
These educators, science standards, so sorry.
These educators will be featured at the California Assessment Conference.
The conference is October 16th through 18th at the Oakland Convention Center.
At that conference, attendees will get to learn from these teachers about how to systematically gather evidence and provide feedback about learning as it relates to science.
So now I want to show you this short video
Because I know this will be the highlight.
Science?
It's elementary.
And it's happening in elementary schools all across California.
So we asked elementary teachers throughout the state, what's so great about science?
Well, students love it.
My students are very excited about science.
My name is Joanne Ormondi, and I teach kindergarten at Art Furler School in Tracy, California.
Introducing children to science at a young age really helps to develop their critical thinking skills, their higher level thinking skills.
They become comfortable with exploration and hands-on experiences and interacting with others and collaboration and on and on and on.
It has so many benefits.
When I'm doing a science lesson, I know the kids are having fun because I can see it on their faces.
My name is Kristen Peckham, and I teach a combination TK, kindergarten class at Burt Ranch Elementary, which is a tiny little school in Trinity County.
I'm trying to be inclusive for all the students no matter what their abilities are and it is one area where if you're not the best math person or you're not the best language person you still can succeed in the science area because we use the multi-sensory lessons and there's all sorts of excitement that's going on and they can all push and pull each other and so they all feel included.
But what does it look like?
What do students get to do when they learn science?
Kids are natural scientists.
My name is Jillian Torres and I teach a first and second grade autism-focused special day class in Santa Fe Springs or Norwalk, California for the Little Lake City School District.
They naturally want to touch and explore and feel stuff and science gives them the opportunity to do that.
when naturally kids are told all day long, stop that, don't touch that, don't do this, don't do that.
Science gives them the opportunity that they need developmentally to touch that, to lick that, to smell that, to do all the things that they want to do.
And they say they feel very smart, and that's very important to me.
My name is Celia De La Loza, and I teach at McKee Academy of Arts and Sciences in Pico Rivera, California, because I want my students to feel competent.
I know that our goal for our next generation science standards is not just to inspire students to be scientists, but if they don't want to walk that path to be productive citizens.
If I were a student in my own classroom, I would feel safe.
My name is Jennifer Munoz and I teach in Del Mar Union School District.
I think that students love coming to the science lab because they may not be successful in other areas in school and the science lab provides them a safe place to be successful and to take risks.
Now wait a minute.
California students are diverse.
Is science accessible to all students?
Absolutely.
Science is very important to English learners and English language development.
It just provides all these ample opportunities for students to collaborate and express themselves verbally and in writing.
and formulate questions.
Students with special needs, like students in our IEPs, we use science as a great way for our students to participate with their typical peers.
Science is that even playing field where they get to explore too and the things that they come up with is their own and they can use that to their advantage also.
So for me, I know that in our school, science is really important because it's a time for my kids to get to be with their peers and interact and use science as that way of that exploration together.
Yeah, I think that science is a language.
And so even if you are a native English speaker, you're still learning a new language.
And I think that it also promotes equity when you're teaching science because everybody comes to the science classroom, the science lab.
and they all have to practice the same skills.
Those science and engineering practices are asking kids to create an argument, to analyze evidence, to obtain information, and those are all language acquisition skills.
Didn't I tell you?
Science!
It's elementary!
This video was produced for the California Department of
So we were very excited.
Sometimes we hold these small contests.
for our educators to share with us what they're doing.
And sometimes I worry.
It's like you send out a party invite, and you wonder if anyone will RSVP.
So I had that fear.
I was going to have a science contest for elementary teachers.
And I had heard so many stories about how science was not being taught in elementary school.
And we had participants.
We had teachers.
They had stories to tell.
And they were very excited to tell their stories.
I will tell you, we spent the day with them.
This is a very organic video of just them talking about what they wanted to talk about.
There were tears.
There was laughter.
It was a great day for them to really feel that people were acknowledging the great work they were doing.
So they will be featured at our assessment conference.
There will be a panel presentation
for them to share what they're doing.
We also will be taking their formative assessment resources that they submitted to us, and we will be putting them into the redesigned digital library when that comes out next year, so that their formative assessment processes will be available for other California teachers to have access to.
I think that's it.
So we'll turn first to Ting Sun who's one of our assessment liaisons to see if she has any initial comments.
Just really briefly, I think continuing that idea of the continuous improvement process, I think we continue to see that.
And I've said in the past, assessment was the first area out there.
And so we're at a point where it's very much around refining and deepening.
And I appreciate that, Michelle, you and your team, while you've been ahead of a game compared to accountability, let's say, that you and your team continue, and you haven't let your foot off the gas, that you continue to do that.
continue to work.
And so, with that in mind, that the CSA, I do appreciate that the recommendation is that we publish a range.
Because if this is a new assessment, it is different in nature in that it isn't, it's a voluntary test.
And so, I think starting out with a range is good, and then we can kind of see how this goes as we collect more information from year to year.
It'll go to public comment, and then we'll come back for a forward discussion.
Okay, public comment?
We have two for public comment, Jen Gustafson Correa and Carolina Serna.
Hi, good afternoon.
I'm Jan Casasin Correa, the CEO for CAVE.
Good to be back here again.
I just want to say we greatly appreciate the process of priority that's been given to create the Spanish language assessment and really the belief in it.
We've really felt that from the department and we really do greatly appreciate that.
We want to push the envelope a little bit though today and encourage the board and staff to approach the development and implementation of the CSA, not solely as a measurement of Spanish reading writing mechanics and listening, but rather be designed to be a part of a comprehensive little comprehensive accountability system that reflects
and values academic multilingualism.
You know, we passed Prop 58 in 2016 with three-fourths of our voters asking for multilingualism in our schools.
So we feel now is the time to have an assessment system that really measures that.
The results of the CSA and SBAC and even the LP indicators should not reflect separate language academic proficiency in English or in Spanish, but be connected and aligned to demonstrate the value of academic multilingualism and biliteracy a student has reached.
We are ready as CABI to really work with our team here to develop a comprehensive system for multilingual accountability.
Thanks so much.
Good afternoon.
My name is Carolina Serna.
I'm an associate professor of education at Biola University.
I'm here to share my perspective as a former bilingual elementary school teacher and a CAPE board member.
As an observer of the CSA standard setting group, I'm here to express my appreciation, first of all, for the work involved in the development of the California Spanish assessment.
Through my observations, it became highly apparent that while much work has been done, the writing and oral language pieces are missing and would make the assessment much more effective.
And teachers need that information to measure the bilingual abilities of their students.
GABA is here to help and be supportive in that process of making the assessment more robust and valid by including sections that assess the writing and oral language abilities of bilingual students.
Thank you for the opportunity to provide comment on this issue.
Great.
The floor is open to board members for additional questions and comments.
Yes, member Burke.
I'm sorry.
Member Strauss.
I just want to make a comment about the standard setting process.
So I was fortunate as this lays on to science to observe the cast setting.
And when Michelle showed us the slides about how they
decided what the standards were and if the student was approaching.
It was a fascinating process and first let me say we are so fortunate to have committed panel members who live in the Spanish language assessment area or who totally know our science standards and are doing early implementation.
that I just commend the CD and ETS who facilitated this process.
It was so impressive and thoughtful about how they really looked at the problem to decide if this item the student had to know what they had to know.
And I think we can feel confident about those who did this as volunteers to really help us get these standards set.
So I just wanted to make that comment.
Because everyone's wondering, how'd you figure out this?
And how do you know if they really know this?
Especially, for example, these are new assessments for us trying to get the standards.
And in science, for example, I mean, we're still adopting the materials.
So to really trust that we have panels that are doing elementary, middle, and high school and who live this day-to-day teaching students, we're just really fortunate.
And the collaboration of ETS and our Department of Ed, we're very, very fortunate.
So I just feel really confident with the process.
Test member Ortiz-Lacon, anybody on this side that I'm missing?
Okay.
Michelle, I wanna ask a question about the last comments we heard for public comment because I do think that if we're trying to measure bilingualism, multilingualism, we need the oral component.
But I also know that if I administer this assessment because it's optional and it's administered to a student who's not a Spanish dominant student,
I don't get reimbursed as a district, there is, you know, so there is a cost to administering this, there will be an additional cost I'm assuming if there's an aura component.
So, what has been the conversation has it been on this side of the street, or on the other side of the street, that we don't have the funding to one.
make this a more robust assessment.
And I think that there's, look, this is a higher rigor than we've seen before.
And I think that there's a lot that we need to learn because the type of model, language model of students attending, the percentage of Spanish, are they a 90-10, 50-50?
There's a lot of unknowns.
But we do know that if we make this more robust, there's added cost.
So where is that conversation?
Where is the missing piece?
Aqui o alla?
Well, yes, I don't have a stash of money in my back pocket.
So it's not here, right?
The conversations do need to occur elsewhere.
I will say that the comments where they express that they would like to see authentic writing as well as oral language is not new.
That is consistent from what we're hearing.
We did take the opportunity to conduct a small focus group, since we had teachers there, with our high school teachers and ask them, is this something that you would be interested in having?
And what kind of caveats do you want to give us about that?
And they are very interested, but they also made it very clear that they are very busy teaching.
And so they also don't want to be responsible for the scoring aspects that might come along with those components.
And so that's really important for us to know as we think about any resources that we might want to request is, you know, trying to find that benefit of teacher scoring because it is a great professional development opportunity, but also not have it be a barrier to those that may want to give this test.
You are correct.
The test could be enhanced, I would say, to more fully measure Spanish reading language arts.
It could.
But at this point in time, we just don't have the resources to do so.
So I'd just like to piggyback on this conversation and sort of the earlier
framing that you did, and then the comments that we've heard that, you know, where I think many of us are really pleased to see this test, you know, getting going.
The need for a Spanish assessment has been articulated over a long period of time, and the process, as Eileen mentioned, has been a really thoughtful process.
At the same time,
The assessment itself and the programs that it's measuring are not necessarily completely in sync with each other, right?
Because much of bilingual education is, particularly the early grades, is oral.
This is grounded in the English language arts standards in Spanish.
And quite often in bilingual immersion programs, the kids may be learning English language arts in English and doing their math in Spanish or whatever.
complete correlation between the programs and what they're doing and the assessment and what it's measuring, which we all recognize.
And so I know that you're planning to do some study on the nature of the programs and so on.
And we need to learn over time what the scores reflect.
You know, you were asking earlier, Felice, about, you know, will we have like a two to match against a two or a three to match against a three?
And I think it's a good idea not to have
threshold scores like that at this point, because we really don't know what they represent with respect to the programs.
The programs are evolving.
In the high school, this may be Spanish for native speakers.
It may be Spanish classes.
It's measuring.
People are using it for a wide variety of purposes.
And I think it's appropriate to give people an indication of what a student who's in a particular score range
This may reflect about what they can do, and it doesn't reflect writing and oral proficiency at this point, but we can say something about what it does reflect.
Then people can then think about how that maps onto what they're trying to accomplish in their programs and how their programs are structured.
Then we can evolve over time the notion of threshold scores that are mapped to a program
kind of accountability standard, but right now I think we're just at the very beginning stages of figuring out what this represents vis-a-vis what is going on in the schools.
So when we get to the point of a motion, I'm gonna suggest that we just modify a little bit the language of the recommendation from calling these threshold scores, which connotes sort of a benchmark for some kind of inference about what it's describing to
score reporting ranges, which is what Michelle described, so that we keep clear of the fact that we're in a process of trying to figure out how to describe what kids can do in part, not in total yet, and this is going to evolve over time.
Are there other questions or comments before we seek to have a motion?
Then I will move staff recommendation.
Should I read it?
Yes, would you make it with the modification I proposed?
Yes.
So we'll go with the summative student score reports for the first one.
And then the second one, the proposed Spanish assessment preliminary range.
Score reporting range.
Preliminary score reporting range.
Score reporting range, beginning with the 2018-19 administration.
Is there a second?
Thank you very much.
Just to clarify, also moving the last part of the recommendation about the direct authorizing CDE to... Oh, yes.
Yes, and including the authorizing CDE staff to make technical edits as necessary.
Member Rucker, do you still want a second?
Okay, just checking.
Any further discussion?
Okay, all in favor say aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
All right, the motion passes.
Thank you so much, we appreciate it.
Moving right along, we're up to item four, which is a public hearing regarding the transfer territory from the Denair Unified School District to the Turlock Unified School District.
And this will be presented by Larry Sherry of the California Department of Education before we commence the public hearing.
So Larry, you are welcome to begin.
Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
As indicated, today we have a territory transfer appeal from Stanislaus County Committee.
Is this on?
Excuse me.
from the Stanislaus County Committee on School District Organization to disapprove transfer of territory from the Turlock Unified School or from the Denair Unified School District to the Turlock Unified School District.
Before we get started on the actual appeal, I'm going to do a brief overview of what school district organization is.
We think of it in three general areas.
We have changes at the local level, changes to school district governing board composition and election methods.
That's solely a local issue.
The state board and the department get involved only when a district brings forward a waiver to remove some obstacle.
Most commonly you see that in the CVRA waivers that you hear every meeting to eliminate the election, to allow a district to move from at-large elections to bi-trustee area elections.
Formations of new school districts.
We don't see a lot of those anymore for reasons that aren't particularly relevant to today's presentation.
So the bulk of what we're going to be dealing with is transfers of territories between school districts and subsequent appeals of county committee local actions of those transfers.
You have at each county a local counterpart.
County Committee on School District Organization.
The County Committee was envisioned as an 11-member body that was elected by school district governing boards in the county, but over the years, the majority of counties have requested that the State Board approve disbanding the County Committee and transferring their functions to the County Board of Education.
The County Committee approves and disapproves all territory transfers.
and also does the same for certain formations of new school districts.
The County Committee only makes recommendations to the State Board on the formations of other types of school districts.
And importantly, the County Committee operates under the direction of the State Board of Education.
At the local level, in order to get a territory transfer proposal started, there are three general, three common ways in which that happens.
resolutions by all the effective governing boards asking for the transfer, a property owner request if the territory to be reorganized happens to be uninhabited, or the most common way is a petition signed by 25% of the voters in the area to be reorganized.
Once that petition is submitted to the county superintendent, it is determined whether or not it's sufficient.
And if it's sufficient, it's then transmitted to the county committee, who holds public hearings, takes certain actions, and then makes certain findings, and then takes actions whether to approve or disapprove.
The findings it makes are established in code.
These are the same
minimum threshold requirements that a proposal has to meet that the board has, the state board has to look at.
There are nine of them.
We look at the adequate size of the district after reorganization, whether or not the reorganization has a negative effect on community identity of the district, whether there's an equitable division of property and facilities, if the ability to educate students in a integrated environment is preserved, otherwise we're not promoting segregation.
There's no significant increase in cost to the state.
There's no disruption to educational programs, no significant increase in school facility cost, and the proposal is not designed primarily to increase anyone's property values.
That's kind of a late one added by the legislature.
And there's no substantial negative effect on the fiscal status of any affected district.
The county committee must approve, must disapprove a petition if all minimum requirements are not substantially met.
At least that's what it's supposed to do.
It can only approve a proposal if all those nine minimum threshold standards are, they find that those standards are substantially met.
Approval is a discretionary action.
Even if the minimum standards are met, the county committee is not required to do it.
They need to find a reason to approve a transfer.
The legislature has not been very specific about those standards, noting only that its intent is that local educational needs and concerns serve as a basis for reorganizations.
Once the county committee makes a decision, the petitioners or any affected district can appeal the action or findings of the county committee to the state board.
That's what we have here today.
The state board then may review the, the county is going to submit an administrative record of what happened at the local level.
The state board then has the option to review the appeal based solely on that administrative record, based on the administrative record plus a public hearing, or the state board may summarily deny review of the appeal.
The state board has incredible discretionary authority in these matters.
And that discretionary authority has given some people difficulties over the past decades.
And they wind up getting challenged in court, especially if the state board overturns a local decision.
Hasn't happened in the last couple of decades because the court has been very clear that the state board has this discretionary authority.
And for a number of reasons.
Statute provides for discretion.
and in the language.
The State Board is given in statute the ability to establish minimum standards and it has done so for a number of the threshold conditions through regulation.
In specific court cases have determined that the meeting the minimum standards does not compel approval.
That the State Board needs to go beyond
simply meeting these minimum threshold standards and find a reason or a compelling reason to approve a territory transfer in this, excuse me, or in the case of appeals overturning the county committee's action.
And unlike most appeals that you might think about in the judicial system, where you're kind of constrained to specific issues that are appealed, the courts have told you that this is a de novo
You can take into account anything you want, whether or not it's been considered at the local level or not.
You have a number of decisions to make.
Number one, you need to determine if the proposed reorganization meets the threshold standards.
If the threshold conditions are substantially met, you need to determine if there is a local educational need or concern to reorganize the districts.
In the case of appeal, is there a reason, a local educational need or concern to overturn the local decision?
I should also add that in line with your discretionary authority, even if you find one or more of the minimum standards not met, you can still go ahead and approve a reorganization, unlike the county committee does not have that discretion.
And then you're either going to affirm or reverse the action of the county committee.
Now on to the
current appeal, what I'm going to do is, instead of just reading through this description's background, I'm going to throw up a map of the area.
This is the transfer area in red.
It's in the Denaire Unified School District.
But as you can see, the solid black line is the district boundary.
It splits the city of Turlock, which is a very common occurrence for school districts around the state.
So the proposed transfer area is in Dener, but in the city of Turlock.
It's about 91 acres, undeveloped property.
And the petition was brought forward by the developer with plans to develop eventually up to 264 homes in the area.
The reason provided by the developer to transfer the territory is that to give all students who live in the city of Turlock an opportunity
to participate in Turlock Unified School Options.
So a much broader view of the area.
Denaire Unified is a small school district, about 1,300 students.
Turlock, much bigger, over 14,000 students.
Denaire has indicated that of its student population, about a third of their students live
in the City of Turlock area.
The Stanislaus County Committee unanimously disapproved the transfer because it found that it failed to meet three of the minimum threshold requirements.
District size, again, Denair is a small district.
Community identity, specifically finding that
And we'll go into these three conditions in a little more detail later, specifically finding that the Nair schools are closer to the territory than our Turlock schools.
Also noting that, if I can go back for a moment, that if the territory is transferred, it's going to create a peninsula of land where the area would be part of Turlock Unified, but surrounded by at least three sides by the area of the Nair Unified.
It also noted that when they held the public hearings, there were no community members that spoke in favor of the transfer, but a number of community members that spoke in opposition to the transfer.
Again, there isn't anyone living here.
This is undeveloped territory within the property, but it's community members from surrounding areas.
The third condition it found not met was that the proposal was designed to increase property values.
They didn't really agree too strongly with the developer's stated reasons in the petition, and they conducted a study of selling prices and determined that the property values were higher in Turlock than in De Niro.
Turlock, the developer who was a petitioner, didn't file the appeal.
The appeal was filed by Turlock Unified.
for a number of reasons.
They believe that all minimum threshold requirements are met.
They note that the transfer areas in the City of Turlock, and there's a strong sense of community identity between Turlock Unified and the City of Turlock.
Even though the schools from Denaire are closer to the territory transfer, they claim that the commutes to Turlock schools will be much safer than the commutes to the Denaire schools.
And they note that they already educate a number of students from Denair on inter-district transfer, about 350 or so annually.
And even though they receive LCFF funding for these students, they don't receive any because the residents aren't in the district.
They don't receive any funding property
assessed value funding for general obligation bonds, or in the case of this specific new development, they would not receive the developer fees, the developer mitigation fees.
And they thought that would be a fair offset for them in educating the students on inter-district transfers to receive those developer fees.
The NARA Unified opposes the transfer.
noting that there would be a significant negative effect on the district.
They would lose the developer fees, obviously.
They would lose the assessed valuation, which is used to offset the bond debt they have and also reduce their bonding capacity.
And also, if there were students coming out of there, they would not receive the LCFF funding for students.
They also, as with the county committee, note that their schools are closer within walking distance while
Turlock Unified Schools are much more distance, and they, like the County Committee, were concerned that the developers' business interests may well be the sole driving force behind the petition.
In terms of the first condition, and let me back up for a moment.
Again, as I noted, there are nine minimum threshold standards.
I'm not going to go through all nine.
I'm just going to go through the three that the county committee found were not met.
Again, this is a small territory transfer, no students, and it's very difficult for most of these conditions not to be substantially met when you have such a small territory transfer.
Regarding the first condition, which is that the reorganized districts will be adequate in terms of numbers of pupils enrolled, the county committee found that Bonaire is below 1,501 students.
which is, I mentioned that the State Board has regulatory authority.
The State Board has determined that 1501 for a unified school district is the minimum size, and the intent behind that is not to create any new direct service districts in the county.
They note that projected enrollment from the transfer area would help the district attain that 1501 goal, so they find the condition is not substantially met.
Turlock Unified, in the response, in its appeal, noted that regardless of whether or not the territory is transferred, Denaire is not going to be above 1,501 students.
And they also point out that the intent behind that number, the state board's intent, is not to create any new direct service districts.
And the proposed transfer of Terry Wood
Transfer of territory would not result in such creation.
We basically agree with Turlock, noting that for the past six years, enrollment has been below 1,500 in Denair.
And the district's own projections indicate that they're not going to exceed that value.
And we also agree with Turlock Unified is that the proposed transfer of territory will not result in the creation of a direct service district.
So we find the condition to be substantially met.
I'm now going to go through the community identity condition.
Just like in the last condition, we go through the county committee's findings and the appellant's response.
But I'm not going to leave those slides up.
I'll just go through those with maps of the area's background.
The county committee found that, again, the areas
there are a whole lot more, there's a whole lot more territory in Dinera that's in the city of Turlock than just this transfer area.
So there are a lot of territory that meets the same, has the same conditions, circumstances.
Again, they noted that this creates a peninsula.
And again, I've gone through a lot of these already, but there was no stated community support for the transfer.
Here is a different map showing the school locations in relation to the post-transfer area.
Again, note that their schools are closer to the post-transfer area than are the Turlock Unified schools.
Going back to Turlock Unified's response,
Again, they note that the clear identity, the clear community identity between the City of Turlock and the Turlock Unified School District.
And again, this property is in the City of Turlock.
They reference general plans, community general plans, noting that both Turlock and Denaire, the Board of Supervisors has approved plans that calls for a green belt or an urban buffer between Turlock and Denaire.
therefore, the Board of Supervisors intent is to have that distinction between the two communities.
And regardless of the distance from the schools from the post-transfer area, they claim that the Turlock Unified claims that
the commutes to their schools would be much safer than the commutes to the Denaire Unified Schools.
And that's based on the fact that Denaire is a much more rural district.
It doesn't have the infrastructure, the sidewalks, and the bike paths that you would see between the proposed transfer area and the Dutcher Middle School and the schools in Turlock Unified.
We note that, let me go back a minute.
We note that Turlock Unified is much more than the city of Turlock.
It contains two component elementary school districts, Keys and Chatham.
It contains considerable agricultural areas, some even spreading into the adjacent county, Merced County.
and a portion of the community of Keys itself.
So it's not just a one-on-one between Turlock Unified and the City of Turlock.
There's a whole lot more to that.
We also note that it's true that the Board of Supervisors has called for this buffer zone between Denaire and Turlock, but they also have called for the buffer zone between Keys and Turlock.
And Keys is within the Turlock Unified School District.
The district did not identify any negative effects of having that buffer between Keys and Turlock.
And we also, again, note with the county committee and with the district that during the three public hearings held, there was no community member that spoke in favor of this transfer.
The only community input was in opposition.
regarding the closeness to the schools or the safety of the commute.
I mean, there's no question that the near schools are closer.
But the claims of a less safe commute are based on current conditions there.
Once development takes place, homes are built, the master plan for the development calls for improved infrastructure.
So it's not going to put
That master plan is not going to put sidewalks and bike paths all the way to the near schools, but it's going to be considerably mitigated by adding additional sidewalks and bike paths.
So we find that we also have concerns with the proposed transfer area.
It's only a part of the master plan for the development.
So there are about 10 acres in blue here on the map that are in the master plan, but are not being proposed for transfer.
We also note that if this area is transferred, it's going to split the area of the city of Turlock that's in the Denaire Unified School District.
Once the development is complete, there will be access.
The streets will be built in the area that will connect to those areas of Turlock that still are in Denair.
Our experience with such situations across the state is that when you have kids in the Turlock area, in the city of Turlock, who are
commuting to schools in Delhi through areas of Turlock Unified, assuming this was transferred, then it creates some questions about why aren't we in Turlock, or how come there's a separation.
And so we have a concern that this transfer would create conditions that would promote further transfers of territory, similar transfers.
So in summary,
Regarding the community identity condition, we find little support for Turlock claims regarding community identity.
Again, we have a concern with the peninsula being created.
And the other conditions I just mentioned that we believe set up conditions that could promote future transfers.
So we agree with the county committee that this condition is not substantially met.
The final condition is that the proposed reorganization is primarily designed for purposes other than to significantly increase property values.
The petitioner, according to the county, who was a developer, provided no reason or purpose for the proposed territory transfer.
They conducted a survey of home sales and showed that sales in Turlock have a $5 to $7 per square foot increased value of the homes in Bonaire.
So they found that this condition was not met.
Turlock responds by noting that the petitioner clearly stated that the primary purpose of the territory is to provide choice for families who live there, provide the option for parents to be able to attend Turlock Unified.
And they note that the survey of home sales conducted was flawed.
Again, as I mentioned earlier, Denaire is much more rural.
than Turlock, so their claim is that really the differences they were finding were the differences between urban sales and rural sales.
Again, we agree with Turlock on those issues.
We note that the petitioner did state a reason.
You know, one of the things for us that goes into increased property values is if the community finds one district more desirable than another.
And there is no mention by any community member or any school district of the desirability of one school district over another.
And we also agree with Turlock Unified that the data on property values is inconclusive.
OK, so we find one condition not substantially met.
We're going to move into the next stage now is, are there reasons to either support the county committee or overturn the county committee's decision?
Turlock Unified has provided a number of reasons that they think would be appropriate for the state board to use to reverse the county committee.
One, again, is the, I'm going to go through them relatively quickly because we've already talked about most of them.
One is the safety of the commute.
community identity with the city of Turlock.
Again, significant numbers of students residing with the mayor already attend Turlock on inter-district transfers.
And since they don't receive any funding for facility renovation, they believe that the developer fees from this proposal, this proposed development would be a fair way for them to address some of the housing needs caused by inter-district transfer students.
Regarding these, we don't, as I've said, we don't particularly agree with the first two.
Regarding the developer fees, putting aside the fact that developer fees are supposed to be to mitigate the effects, production of students from a transfer area, inter-district transfers are voluntary agreements at the local level.
If there is a local problem with that local agreement, then we don't think that the state board needs to play a role in resolving the issues, that this can be resolved by some local negotiations.
I'm going to ask you to get to the recommendation so we have time for the rest of the public hearing because we're getting close to our.
OK.
And then we'll ask questions if we have them.
People do have the item in their packets.
Okay, so again, just here are some of the reasons that we've come up with.
Yeah.
In summary, we find the community identity condition not met, there's no compelling reason to overturn the unanimous county committee decision, and we recommend that the state board affirm the county committee disapproval of the transfer.
We really appreciate it.
And we're, I'm going to hit the gavel because we're opening a public hearing.
And we're going to hear first from the petitioners in favor of the territory transfer.
They will have up to 10 minutes.
Then we'll hear from the county or districts that are opposing the territory transfer.
They will also have up to 10 minutes.
After the presentation from both sides, there will be opportunity for public comment from any individual who has not already presented for one minute each.
And then we will turn to the board.
Thank you.
Very good.
Thank you to the ladies and gentlemen for allowing me to be here to speak on this item today.
My name is Barney Gordon.
I'm the assistant superintendent for business services for Turlock Unified School District.
And obviously we had a good presentation on what we are here to discuss this afternoon.
As the previous gentleman mentioned from the CDE that all the conditions with the exception of one were met according to the CDE.
Of those conditions, the proposal will result in equitable division of property and facilities of the original districts.
The CDE agrees that that condition is met.
The reorganization of the school districts will preserve each affected district's ability to educate pupils in an integrated environment and will not promote racial or ethnic discrimination or segregation.
Any increase in cost to the state as a result of the proposed reorganization will be insignificant and otherwise incidental to the reorganization.
The CDE agrees that that condition is met.
The reorganization will continue to promote sound
educational performance that will not significantly disrupt the educational programs in the affected districts, the CDE agrees that that condition is met.
Any increase in school facility costs as a result of the proposed reorganization will be insignificant and otherwise incidental to the reorganization.
Once again, CDE agrees that condition is met.
The reorganized districts will be adequate in terms of the number of pupils enrolled.
The proposed reorganization is primarily designed for purposes other than to significantly increase property values.
Condition met.
And then the school district of each are each organized on the basis of a substantial community identity.
And that condition the CDE does not agree is met.
So as far as
They do talk about compelling reasons to go ahead and overturn the county's recommendation, and those are on community identity, safety of home-to-school commute, and offset cost of inter-district transfers with developer fees.
So I want to start out with that community identity.
You'll notice this map in front of you.
You saw that in the previous slides.
From this area right here, you can see that transfer area.
It does appear to be very split between the Denair
city of Din and the city of Turlock.
But when we dig a little bit deeper, you can see that that area, once we put streets onto this map, you can see the city of Turlock on the left is much closer, that area obviously is much more a part of the city of Turlock than the city of Din.
When we get a little bit, do a satellite image of it, you can see the area between Din and
The city of Turlock is very much agricultural, so this is an area that will not be developed as part of this development of this transfer area, this area in red.
That area will remain agricultural.
In Central Valley, we have islands of cities with an agricultural barrier around them, so this area, there is no intention for that area to be developed.
So when we talk about safety of home to school commute, this is a big concern of ours.
As a matter of fact, this is one of the most concerning areas for me.
The CDE does state that we didn't provide any data to corroborate our safety concerns other than a general description of the commute and circumstances.
The CDE also indicated that based on their Google street view of the path, that they believe the shoulders along the road spans are sufficient to keep foot and bike traffic off of the roadway.
This first picture that I'm showing you is a view of Warring Road, which is in the northeast side of the development.
So this is, although the development will be built out with sidewalks and streets,
This is the area, this is the street students will be walking down, heading towards or coming back from Dinero schools.
As you can see, it's a narrow country road with no sidewalks, what I would not consider a safe path for student travel.
And there is no intention in this development to renovate this path.
Once you get down a little further, you can see this is Monta Vista Avenue.
So once you get down Warren Road, you'll turn right.
That's the main thoroughfare between Dinner and Turlock Unified School District.
Once again, it's a two-lane country road.
There's no sidewalks or safe paths to travel for students on this road.
And this right here is a view from Denair High School, the southwest corner of Denair High School, looking down that same road we were looking at previously, Monta Vista Avenue.
So this is where students would be coming up to the high school or leaving the high school, heading to the area that's in question.
As you can see, the sidewalk ends there at the high school.
And that road beyond that is not going to be part of the development.
That is rural country roads.
And we don't get a lot of rain in the Central Valley, but when we do, my fear is that the students who choose to bike or walk between school and home will be certainly walking in the road.
That is a major concern of ours.
And in contrast, looking from the southwest side of the territory in question,
This is the roads leading into Turlock and all of our area schools.
As you can see, it's a very wide road with parking on either side and sidewalks leading all the way into the school, into the town.
And then finally, offset costs with inter-district transfers with developer fees.
We have currently 336 students that are transferring in from Denaire to Turlock Unified School District.
Nearly half of those students live in that area that reside within the city of Turlock, the Dinera Boundary.
When we did the surveys four years ago, I think, when they first came to the county commission, we did surveys on the students and which district they were going to and attending.
Six out of seven in that area that lived in the city of Turlock, but the Dinera Boundary, were coming to Turlock schools.
So 336 students, that's
10 classrooms, that's an elementary for a lot of school districts.
That's a lot of developer fees that we haven't collected on.
In contrast, we have 57 students transferring out of Turlock into Denaire.
It was made mention that we have a choice to accept these students, and Denaire has a choice to deny the transfers going both ways.
But there is the Allen Bill that we all have to contend with when we don't really have a lot of choice or leeway when it comes to the Allen Bill.
So, as far as the CDE is concerned for moving the proposal forward, the CDE does outline concerns of allowing the transfer to the territory as follows.
He mentioned encouraging future transfers.
He's already shown this map.
Of the areas that are undeveloped, the only portion will be that small 10-acre plot that is within the city of Turlock, but the denier boundaries, that's the only portion that will be left
to develop.
Denaire Unified School District enrollment, according to the CDE's analysis, the agreement, you know, as I just mentioned, Denaire Unified School District agrees to allowing the students from Denaire into Turlock and vice versa as well.
So if enrollment was truly an issue, then local agencies would have the ability to handle
Increased property values as a motive for transfer.
According to the CDE's findings, the evidence provided demonstrates an increased property value appeared to be inconclusive.
Fiscal effects on Denario Unified School District.
Its absence would not predict a substantial negative effect.
That's according to the CDE's report, the absence of this transfer.
And unanimous local decisions to disapprove the property transfer.
I don't have anything to go with that because it was a unanimous disapproval from the county.
The world was a different place.
Denair was a different place.
They were in some pretty significant financial difficulties at the time.
I'm very happy to see that they've been able to come out of those and their finances are much stronger than they were.
Back then, you know, there is no community in this undeveloped area, so we did not have a lot of support, community support, and Dner did a good job of getting folks out there.
and we have a great relationship with our folks, with our neighbors in Din.
We oftentimes will find students that we, for whatever reason, are not successful in our schools because they're bigger or some other reason.
We'll find those students and we will suggest they look at Din first before some other option.
So a lot of our students are starting to go that way.
We've obviously been very
welcoming to any students who come our way, so that we can, you know, if there's programs that they're not able to get in Din or offer in Turlock, they're certainly welcome.
So in an era of local control, we ask you that you put it to the voters for them to decide.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, State Board, Board President Darling-Hammond.
My name is Keith Gray and I'm here today with the district's leadership team to oppose the appeal by Turlock Unified School District and to support the staff recommendation to affirm the decision by the Stanislaus County Committee on District Organization.
I have prepared my remarks in cognizance of the time that we have to make our presentation today.
Although we still support the findings of the County Committee, staff has presented to you a report with a thoughtful analysis that the proposed reorganization of the two districts does not support a finding that the petition supports the condition that the new boundaries would be organized based on substantial community identity.
In fact, this appeal, if approved, would be an unnecessary catalyst for other petitions being brought forward to transfer more territory
from Denair to Turlock.
And for what purpose?
Turlock Unified has brought forward a petition that was based on a permit application filed with the city of Turlock some five years ago, when as will be shared by Superintendent Metzger with you this afternoon, Denair Unified was in tough as it was recovering from a negative budget certification and dealing with declining enrollment.
To determine the effect
of the petition on the community identity of Denaire Unified and on Turlock USD for that matter, let's look at the 91 acres that is located on the western edge of Denaire's boundaries.
The geography of this proposal simply does not make sense.
So you have marked in red the proposed transfer of 91 areas.
The blue line as you have before you are the Denaire boundaries and the
Going to the boundary to the west, those are city inhabitants.
The staff report referred to the proposals having three sides.
I see it as a six-sided proposal with Denaire being completely on four sides, sharing one of the sides at the very top, the bottom basically of the L, and then Turlock being on the side that is most western, that is adjacent to Denaire.
Approving this appeal would subject remaining unoccupied land to transfer petitions.
It would subject the existing neighborhoods on hundreds of acres housing families of students who are currently going to Dinner to transfer petitions simply because they live they are located in the city of Turlock.
It would subject Denair to the unnecessary diversion of students and resources always planned for by that district and always budgeted for by Denair.
Clearly, this petition is only the beginning.
By looking at the map, it is clear that the city of Turlock zoned this area based upon its boundary with Stanislaus County and not because of the boundaries of the two school districts.
To determine substantial community identity,
CDE's position is there is no, quote, legal necessity, end of quote, for district boundaries to match city boundaries.
This configuration is a good illustration of why that's the case.
After all, if cityhood was the basis for the organization of school districts, in that instance, there would be no reason for district boundaries.
Although staff has recommended that you accept
that the condition of unified school district to have at least 1,501 students has been substantially met.
This transfer will not reduce Denaire's enrollment below that number and thus not create a direct service district, but we need to be concerned about this for the following.
Approving this transfer and others that may follow would serve to significantly reduce enrollment, which again may not serve to create a district of less than 1,501 students as is current, but would serve to negatively impact district financial and educational resources as that number continues to decrease.
So besides the goal of simply aligning district boundaries with city boundaries,
The appellant posits that the petitioners provide parents who will locate inside the 91 acres with choice.
However, Turlock USD parents are currently exercising their choices as there are plenty of students from Turlock attending Denaire schools on inter-district transfers, on employment permits, and by attending the two charter schools authorized by the district.
We estimate that that could be over about 350 students that are coming in to Denaire.
This territory transfer, along with the prospect of more transfers to come, will tear the fabric of this district.
Dinera has come a long way over the past five years to balance its budget and deliver quality education to its students.
This petition was considered by the County Committee, which in this instance is an 11-person committee, not the County Board.
Back when Dinera was just getting out of the headlines,
and working to restore the confidence of the community in its operations.
There was no dispute at the County Committee.
The petition to change the boundaries, to basically redraw this map, to take this land, students, and resources from Dinner was unanimously denied.
There is no need for the State Board to now step into Stanislaus County to mediate and resolve a local dispute.
There is nothing exceptional
or compelling, giving a compelling educational reason about this appeal that would support the board overturning the decision by the local county committee.
We ask that you agree amongst yourselves today and vote to retain the community identity of Dinner Unified School District and deny this appeal.
Now I have the superintendent who's following me, there she is.
Good afternoon, I'm Terry Metzger, Superintendent of Denier Unified.
I just have a couple of thoughts to follow up with.
So when this territory transfer was initiated, Denier Unified School District was in a very different place than it is now.
After a negative certification on the adopted 2014-15 budget, the district made cuts and employees took significant pay reductions that ultimately ended up resulting in a positive certification for the first interim budget in 2015.
So since then, the district has continued to make gains in its financial footing, as well as in the academic programming and student services.
So the bottom line is that in 2015, we were fragile.
And that's not the case now in 2019.
We really are on the brink.
So CDE and our county committee estimate that about 98 students will live in the disputed area.
And although 98 students would generate about $980,000 in annual LCFF funding, that would positively and significantly impact our $15.3 million budget.
This is bigger than 91 acres or 98 students.
So the adverse impact of this territory transfer, if it's allowed, is significant for our district.
There are an additional 330 acres of land currently in the denier unified boundary that are also within the city of Turlock.
So, on the map that you're looking at everything east of the blue line is denier unified and you can see that there are already many homes.
So if TUSD is allowed to take this 91 acres from Denaire, it opens the possibility that TUSD will go after the other 330 acres in part or in whole, which would be devastating to our district.
The addition of 98 students across Denaire Unified would allow us a better economy of scale, which would allow us to continue on our path of increasing academic programs and student services.
In comparison, $980,000 for TUSD is 0.6 of their $162 million annual budget.
When I was thinking about becoming superintendent and researching districts, I was drawn to Din because of the community pride.
Perhaps because we're all located on one complex, you can see us in the upper right-hand corner of the map that we provided, within earshot and eyeshot of the development.
And there's a close-knit family feeling from preschool through graduation.
The schools are an integral part of our community, and that community stretches far beyond
the Din census place.
We're actually not a city, we're a town.
And when I talk to parents and community members, they don't see the city border as the dividing line.
We are united through the schools and we're proud of the district's accomplishments in the last several years.
The district boundaries have been in place for many, many decades.
And as you can see from the map,
Rural, agricultural, and suburban areas are all part of our community identity.
We already provide bus transportation to the disputed area.
We have a lot of students that live right around that proposed development.
And so we already provide busing to that area, which totally mitigates the safety concerns.
and hundreds of students in the city limits already attend Din schools.
So that's why it was never a question that when these homes were built they were going to be part of our district because there's already homes right there in that area that are part of our district.
So I urge you to affirm the unanimous decision of the County Committee and the recommendation of the CDE staff.
Thank you.
Is there any other, well, I think we should first ask Matt for any comment.
Okay, do the public comment first?
Okay, any public comment?
Yes, there are six speakers for public comment.
Please line up.
Barney Gordon, Kathy Dunham-Philson, Terry Metzger, Ray Pratch, Keith Bray, and Martel Taylor.
Good afternoon.
My name is Kathy Dunham-Philson and I'm a school board member for Din Unified School District.
Community identity is more than where we buy our groceries or get our hair cut.
It's a feeling of belonging, a sharing of values, and a sense of pride.
For parents, it's knowing who is helping raise their child and whose child they've helped raise.
When a student begins in Din, whether preschool, elementary, middle, or high school, they become a coyote.
They wear purple and then they bleed purple.
They become
part of a school community that embraces and empowers them to be tomorrow's leaders through exemplary instruction and powerful, innovative programs.
The other evening, I was on my way home.
I slowed down as I passed the southernmost point of this property to take in my surroundings.
Denner High School's football stadium lights with the D, H, and S were clearly visible.
You could easily hear the crowd cheering for their 2018 state football champions as they ran onto the field, the national anthem playing, and the announcer calling for kickoff.
All of this reminded me that our Coyote identity is based on not a city limit, but rather the pride.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Madam President, board members.
I am Ray Prock, dairy farmer from Denair, California, school board member in Denair, Denair graduate.
and most of all, a parent of a De Niro graduate and a current De Niro High School student.
In 1990, my family moved our family dairy from, at the time, a growing area of Elk Grove just south of here, and I was attending Elk Grove High School.
Elk Grove High School at that time was only one of two high schools in Elk Grove School District.
Currently, they have nine high schools plus the continuation schools.
So I have the unique experience of having experienced two different high schools in two different sizes.
And I would tell you community matters and community pride is no bigger in a place than Denair, where you have graduates that have returned to coach that state championship football team.
Over half or nearly half of the coaching staff for that state championship team were Denair graduates.
And I don't think you will find that anywhere else in the state of California where there's so much pride in our community that those students will return to coach their additional alumni.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Martel Taylor.
I work for Turlock Unified School District for Facilities Planning and Safety, and I do salute the fact that Denair and Turlock, two separate communities, really have worked together in inter-district transfers throughout the years.
When we look at the paths that students would have to travel in this new area over agriculture area, it just doesn't appear safe.
And it's something that we've worked at over the years in other schools and making sure that there's a continuous path of travel to the different schools.
And while there has been choice of as far as people going back and forth to either district Having this is in denier the the bulk of the students are going to Turlock and We're not able to capture the funds to to do that with it in Dinner, thank you
make any comments before the board takes up the conversation.
Sure.
So I could talk about this for hours.
I've sat on both sides.
Please don't.
And it's on this one and I won't.
I so want to.
But I knew you would say get to the point.
It's okay.
I appreciate Turlock Unified's position.
I do appreciate that.
I also think that we have an obligation to watch out for the best interest of both districts.
And in this particular case, I can't find a compelling reason that would tell me that we need to overturn the unanimous 11-member vote of the county committee that would say that this is something that they would not support.
I think that when you get down to it and you sift through the fog on this, this is about money at the end of the day.
potential $1 million and $700 potential in ADA.
And rural school districts deal with this a lot because they cross multiple city boundaries in rural school districts.
And so as a result of that, this probably isn't the first or the last time we will see something like this when it comes to growth and opportunities that that growth provides for districts.
So what I think is, in terms of no compelling reason to overturn the 11-member vote,
I see that as an issue.
I also see that there's no, it's tough to align community identity when there's no community homes there.
There's no one there to actually say one way or the other what they think.
We're speculating on what they might feel about Din in terms of the residents of those homes.
I also think that there's no way to actually pull away the idea that this is not about property increases either.
So with those three issues, I think it's very difficult, although I appreciate Turlock's position, to say that we can anticipate and make a judgment for a community that doesn't exist about how they might feel about a particular district.
Any other questions, clarification, comment from other members of the board?
Yes, member Ortiz-Lacombe.
You know, I did an entire dissertation on schools and cities, so I appreciate it.
You could talk about this for hours.
So we could meet and talk for hours.
Please don't.
So what I see is a lot of potential to continue developing.
And I think there is a definite concern, and it should be a genuine concern, because there's no plans to develop yet.
But we're a mature state.
We are growing rapidly.
There is a lack of housing stock, and those open spaces will be eventually developed.
And so if we were to overturn the decision, we're also opening the door for more similar appeals.
In terms of the transportation and safe commute pathways, I think that's critical.
I also think that that's the job of the city or the county.
You know, I care about students and pathways as much as I care about Sweetwater Union, where students have to come across a militarized border to get to their schools.
We have students in Watts that are going through gang territories to get to school.
But they're never here.
They're not here asking us to reorganize the district.
And so I feel for this.
But I also think that there is a lot neglected communities that have higher pathway needs and we never hear from them.
And so to an extent, this is something this process has been a process that has allowed some voices to come in and make their argument before us when, in fact, that should be handled by their city or their county.
Thank you.
Any other.
I'll just say for my part, I think that, you know, overruling a unanimous county vote would be an extraordinary act for us to take being not in the middle of that community.
So I think Member Navo's analysis is very compelling to me, and I appreciate all of the due diligence from the department on this.
Are we prepared to make a motion?
to accept the, yeah.
I'll motion that the California Department of Education recommend that the State Board affirm the action of the County Committee to disapprove the proposal to transfer territory from Denair to Turlock.
Thank you, is there a second?
There were a lot of seconds over there.
I didn't catch which one.
Okay.
Brenna, did you second it?
No.
Felisa, okay.
They were pointing at each other.
I couldn't figure out.
All right.
With all of that enthusiastic seconding and motioning, is there any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Any opposed nay?
Any abstentions?
All right.
The motion passes.
Thank you very much.
We're going to try to do one more agenda item before we get to a break, and then we will take one at that point.
Item five is to discuss the state seal of civic engagement, recommended criteria.
And the item will be presented by Barbara Murchison of the California Department of Education.
How are you, Barbara?
Good to see you.
I wonder if we can talk
We still have quite a few items to get through today, so we're going to keep marching along expeditiously.
Thank you, Barbara.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, Superintendent Thurman, board members.
I'm Barbara Murchison, Director of the Educator Excellence and Equity Division here at the Department of Education.
It is my pleasure to bring to you revised criteria.
Thank you.
for the state seal of civic engagement for your approval.
And I want to tell you, I am super happy to be here today because the last week of August, I was called to perform my civic duty, jury duty.
And I called in every day for about four days, had to go in on the fifth day, was actually in the jury box and was trying to concentrate on what was going on, but the whole time I was like, I can't do my civic duty because I need to present the seal of civic engagement to the board.
And how am I gonna tell the judge this?
And fortunately, for some reason, one of the attorneys released me from the box and I am here before you today.
So.
We have updated the criteria and guidance based on the feedback you provided in July.
First, I'll quickly review the authorizing statute and process through which the criteria were developed, and then I'll share some updates to the proposed criteria with you.
This is an action item.
The CDE recommends that the board adopt criteria for the state seal today.
So here's a bit of education code to help ground us in the intent of the legislature.
is the intent of the legislature to establish a state seal of civic engagement to encourage and create pathways for pupils in elementary and secondary schools to become civically engaged in democratic governmental institutions at the local, state, and national levels.
As a reminder, the state seal of civic engagement was authorized with the signing of Assembly Bill 24 in 2017.
Ed Code requires the state superintendent to develop and recommend to the state board criteria for awarding a seal of civic engagement.
Students receiving the seal must demonstrate excellence in civics education and participation and have an understanding of the United States and California constitutions and democratic systems of government.
The statute requires the superintendent to incorporate the six proven practices for effective civic learning developed by the Education Commission of the state and any and all other best practices for civic learning and engagement.
The superintendent was also required to consult with a group of classroom teachers who teach history, social science on secondary schools as part of the development process.
The superintendent was also required to consider a number of other criteria
including completion of history, government, and civics classes, and participation in community service or extracurricular activities.
The statute also provides some flexibility for the superintendent to develop other requirements as appropriate.
So here are a couple of other key elements from the statute, again, to ground us in the legislative intent.
The statute does say that the criteria should provide all pupils with the opportunity to earn the seal,
and also provide some guidance that the seals should recognize outstanding achievement, but be something not necessarily tied to grades or other established measures of achievement, and should also provide benefit to students beyond high school to the extent possible.
So now that I've quickly gone over those statutory requirements, I'm going to quickly review the process through which the draft criteria were developed.
The CDE conducted an application process to identify classroom teachers to serve on the SEAL advisory group.
This group represented history social science teachers from across the state.
We hosted a video conference with this group in collaboration with our county office partners in Los Angeles, Ventura, and Sacramento.
We walked the advisory group through a set of prompts based on statute to solicit feedback around what should be included in the criteria, and then conducted a public comment period around that draft criteria.
Most of the comments we received were around making sure the seal is accessible to all students, not just those with good grades in history, social science.
We also heard that civics education should be the purview of teachers beyond the history, social science classroom, and that the state should encourage local civic action through the seal.
Early on, we met with members of the Advisory Commission on Special Education to seek their advice around ensuring that the seal was accessible to students with disabilities.
And during this period, we also asked CDE staff to review the draft criteria.
In particular, staff who serve English learners, migrant students, students in special education programs, foster youth, and youth who are homeless, to make sure that the criteria were such that all of those students could potentially earn the seal.
We also convened representatives from the Power of Democracy Group, the California History and Social Science Project, the Constitutional Rights Foundation, the Promoting Authentic College, Career, and Civic Readiness Assessment Systems, or PACRIS, Committee, the Los Angeles County Office of Education, and the California Civic Engagement Project to help refine that first draft that I brought to you in July.
We presented those criteria to you in July for feedback and are now presenting them to you
for potential adoption today.
Please note that the statutory deadline for the board to adopt, reject, or modify the seal criteria is January 31st, 2021.
The memo we prepared on this topic contains a typo that mistakenly states that the board must take action by the end of January in 2020.
I apologize for that typo and any confusion that may have caused.
I want to be clear, you have until 2021 to adopt, reject, or modify the criteria.
So after I presented the draft seal criteria to you in July, my team and I debriefed regarding all the feedback we heard.
And I have told everyone who I have had the opportunity to talk to me, that was the best board discussion I have ever had the privilege to stand here.
I have been presenting to this board since 2012.
And you all, I was just standing here like, listen, this was such a great conversation.
So we took a little moment to digest.
My team was taking notes furiously.
We went back and we analyzed everything we'd heard.
And then we've made some changes to the document we presented in July based on your conversation and these following topics.
We wanted to ensure that the SEAL is accessible to all students.
We want to make sure that the SEAL supports continuous civic engagement.
We want to promote diversity and inclusion.
We want to make sure that the SEAL provides opportunities to engage even our youngest students and to support civic engagement across the content areas.
Recall, there was also quite a lot of conversation regarding how the SEAL might be included in the accountability system.
Some board members suggested it be used as a local indicator, and others thought it should be included in the college career indicator.
So we prepared an August information memorandum regarding potentially including the seal as an element in the CCI to support your decision making today.
So I'm just going to spend a few minutes walking you through some of the changes we've made and the contents of the memo.
So first, we changed some language to clarify that per the statute, the seal should be accessible to all students.
We really appreciate the board for pointing out that the reference to the diploma in the previous draft might have represented an obstacle for some students.
Since we last met, staff circled back around with the Advisory Committee on Special Education to discuss the seal again.
And the committee confirmed that it would be very important to make sure the criteria language is as inclusive as possible and told us that they really appreciated our collective efforts to make sure that the criteria were inclusive.
So based on the feedback from you and the committee, we changed the language in criteria one from be in good academic standing and on track to satisfy requirements to earn a high school diploma to be on track to complete required high school coursework.
We also made a change to the guidance for Criteria 1 to emphasize that students on track to earn a certificate of completion should also be eligible for the SEAL.
You also suggested that students should be required to do more than one project in order to earn the SEAL and should be engaged in something more meaningful and long-term.
Based on that feedback, we changed the language of Criteria 3 from participate
in an informed civic engagement project to address real world problems, to participate in one or more informed action civics projects to address real world problems.
We also changed the accompanying guidance for criteria three, adding the definition of action civics, which you can see here on the slide and in the guidance on page four.
We have since learned
that the term action civics is somewhat controversial across the country.
Apparently, there is some concern regarding the term, and this concern has impeded civic education efforts in some states.
Those who oppose the term action civics feel that it might encourage students to protest and express dissent towards authority.
So.
I am not going to make any comments on that other than not making a comment.
But you may want to, and this again, this is new.
This is something we've learned since the item posted.
We may want to change the recommendation based on your conversation today.
We may want to revert to the original language, the language in the original draft to steer clear of this potential controversy.
I don't know that it's been a controversy here in California.
But our intent is to make sure that we support the implementation of this seal.
So if that's your preference, we could add language.
We could strengthen some language around continuous and meaningful engagement in the guidance and just change the criteria back.
So that's something for your consideration.
We also heard a lot of conversation regarding basically simply just caring about the well-being of society and our fellow human beings and having an appreciation for and not just a tolerance of different viewpoints and experiences.
So we changed the guidance for criteria five to prioritize these attributes in particular.
You can see an excerpt of some of this restructured and strengthened language on this slide.
And you'll see language concern for the rights and well-being of others.
and a desire to contribute to the common good, appreciating and seeking out a variety of perspectives and valuing differences, speaking and engaging others with respect and civility, especially those who are different and or have diverse or opposing views, demonstrating empathy and understanding through inclusion and helping to elevate the voices of others.
So we tried to really infuse kind of basic diversity and inclusion and caring about the collective more in this draft.
We also heard you say that we should encourage even children in the earliest grades to be more civically engaged.
Although students can't be awarded the seal until completion of some high school courses, Ed Code is clear that that first slide on legislative intent is clear about the intent to encourage and create pathways for pupils in elementary schools as well.
So we've updated some language on page two of the document to ensure that this is clear, stating, even the youngest students can engage in and demonstrate civic knowledge, skills, and dispositions.
Civic learning opportunities may begin as early as pre-kindergarten, elementary, and middle school, to just state very clearly that it is the intent of the state to support that.
We also updated the title of table two on page 11
to reflect our intention to curate resources for students in early education programs and all the way up through high school.
We plan to coordinate and organize resources and information in a way that schools and districts supporting students in all grades see their civic education work as an on-ramp to student attainment of the seal.
We heard your feedback regarding ensuring that civics education is not just the purview of history social science teachers.
And as I noted in July, we heard this from a lot of stakeholders during the criteria development process as well.
But we strengthened existing language with new language to make it clear that civic engagement activities can and should happen across the content areas.
And on the slide, you'll see a couple of examples from page five of the document.
So there was a lengthy conversation around whether or not the seal should be included in the college career indicator.
So we very quickly went and met with our colleagues in the accountability division to try and talk through what would be involved in making that happen, like what were some of the considerations.
We prepared an August information memorandum outlining some preliminary considerations to help support your decision making today.
Fundamentally, the criteria would need to be standardized to ensure that the measure is valid and reliable to be in a state-level indicator.
It would take quite a bit of concerted effort and time, but it is a doable thing.
We could incorporate civics into the CCI.
We currently can collect some data around some of the criteria
in CALPADS.
So we know which students are earning diplomas.
We collect that data already, and that's pretty cut and dried.
And we know which students are getting, say, a C minus or better in those government courses.
So we collect that right now.
That would be a good start.
But some of the other criteria, for example, how do you standardize civic engagement projects?
Like, how do we take what kids are doing at a local level and say whether or not it meets a standard?
And also, how do you quantify exhibition of particular character traits?
Like, we haven't met a kid, right?
So how do you standardize that to get into a state indicator?
That kind of conversation would require extensive developmental work and would take, really, some time to execute.
We would need to convene a work group to help us think through how we do that.
Ultimately, in the end, it's doable, but we think that the criteria would be extremely different from the ones that you have before you today, and are somewhat concerned that the standardization would reduce the number of students who would be eligible for the seal, which is inconsistent with our interpretation of the statute.
So if the board would like to pursue the option of including civics in the college career indicator in the future, CDE staff could explore the development of an advanced state seal of civic engagement or something that might be substantively different for that purpose.
But for today, we recommend that the board adopt the criteria that we are bringing before you today.
Speaking of which, here they are.
So students must be on track to complete required high school coursework, must demonstrate a competent understanding of United States and California constitutions, functions, and governance of local governments, tribal government structures and organizations, and democratic principles, concepts, and processes.
Here's criteria three that when I mentioned we might want to look at maybe not going with this one and reverting back to the old one.
participate in one or more informed action civics projects to address real-world problems, present a written or oral reflection of student civic engagement project activities, and exhibit character traits that support civic-mindedness supported by a letter of recommendation from a peer, educator, mentor, local elected official, or a non-familial community member.
So much more information regarding the SEAL is available on the CDE webpage.
Thank you again for providing such rich and helpful feedback in July.
It really was a great conversation.
Again, the department recommends that the board adopt the recommended criteria.
And I would be happy to take any questions you have at this time.
First, I'm going to ask Kim Petillo-Bronson as our liaison to provide any initial comments.
Then we'll take any specific clarifying comments.
And then we're going to take public comment and come back to our discussion.
So I just want to thank Barbara and there is a whole team of folks from CDE who I think jumped in to work on this to also facilitate stakeholder engagement with the state seal of civic engagement advisory group as well as the host of nonprofits that you had named earlier.
We did offer quite a bit of robust feedback and we thank you for taking that into account and obviously seeing it reflected on the page.
And I think I'll maybe just open it up from there.
OK.
So right now, if there's any just specific clarifying questions about the nature of the proposal, we can take those, and then we'll take public comment.
We'll take public comment, and then we'll come back and have
Philosophical discussion about the features of the seal of civic engagement.
We have six speakers for public comment.
Please line up.
Leticia Garcia, Huling Lee, Dave Gordon, Mary Perry, Melissa Moreno, and Nobi Hamagai.
Hello.
Good afternoon.
Am I on?
OK.
My name is Leticia Garcia with Riverside County Office of Education here in support of the recommended criteria for the adoption of the state seal of civic engagement.
We think it strikes a pretty fair balance between providing some direction for school districts while also providing flexibility in order for that criteria to be tailored to the local context.
In addition, our superintendent at Riverside County Office of Education, Dr. Judy White, just created a new unit in our county, the Unit of Leadership, Innovation and Outreach Services.
And one of their missions is to develop innovative strategies to ensure that more of our students are earning the seal of
of civic engagement.
And we stand ready to partner with our 23 school districts to make sure that they have the resources to implement this seal locally.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Mary Perry with the California State PTA.
And the PTA actually represents more than 700,000 civic activists in our schools and communities in California.
And we support the criteria for the state seal.
We believe it's really important, an important way to strengthen the civic mission of schools.
And we urge the board to go ahead and approve those now.
It's not clear yet how the state seal should be included, however, in the accountability system.
And there's time to think about that and really study that, and I think that would be a good thing.
However, this board and the department can emphasize the importance of civic engagement, and this coming election year is certainly an opportunity to do that.
The fact is, maybe you could have a civics, it's elementary contest, like a science contest only about civics.
But we hope that the department will commit resources to this.
Hi, I'm Hewling Lee and I represent POCRAS members and individuals, member organizations and individuals.
We've been partnering with the state on developing the student criteria for over a year.
We commend CDE and the State Board for its lawfulness in developing the criteria to prioritize inclusion and equity.
We would encourage the State Board to approve the seal criteria with the minor edit to rewarding action civics to civic engagement to ensure consistency and broader bipartisan appeal.
We appreciate the state's intent to signal the importance of civic learning as an integral part of the student learning agenda and support the idea of forming a group to explore its inclusion in the state accountability system and potentially include it in CALPATS so that we can actually ensure and
track equity of access to the SEAL.
We would like to be part of that group.
While we're eager for the SEAL's launch, we would also encourage the state to take us here to build up local guidance and support by working with systems of support to build awareness.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
Dave Gordon, the Sacramento County Superintendent.
Thank you, thank you, thank you for taking the lead on this and being so thoughtful.
I don't know that there's anything more important you will be doing in the next couple of years.
We're talking about raising a flag for our young people, beliefs, dispositions, and character traits, including all of our kids.
Just a couple of quick suggestions.
I think rather than just suggesting districts
work at the lower levels, that you try to seek some funding to incentivize them to really prime the pump at the lower levels so that when young people get to middle school and high school, they're going to have the core beliefs about inclusion, about caring about one another, and so forth and so on.
So please do that and do your advisory committee
to not just look at including it in the CCI, but in how do you do better the work at the lower level.
So thank you, and just want to invite you.
November 2nd, Saturday, we have a day of youth engagement where we cover three topics, mental health in schools, gender legislation, and the census.
You do a good moonwalk.
Yeah.
Do we have any more public comment?
That was a great way to end the public comment.
And so I think we're open for discussion with the board.
And Member Rucker is ready, and then Member Byrd.
Anyone else who wants to be on the list?
Okay, go ahead.
Well, first of all, I want to begin by saying thank you to the staff and to your leadership and the work that you've done to attempt to revise this.
I think this is not, is still not fully cooked.
And I'm going to give an explanation about why I believe this.
In trying to approve this today, I think we still need to agree to live with the question of one, how to incorporate this
into the CCI because I actually believe we're not going to be, with the criteria as they're currently written, we will not be identifying or expanding the number of students that will be captured or reported by school districts in the CCI.
I think it's still going to be the same relative group of students.
who will still be doing all of these other things to meet all of the other requirements to apply for or to compete successfully in their college admissions work.
And so I think that we still need to look at other ways to capture students who contribute to their school community and to the climate of school spirit and all of those other things.
that go into making some of the reasons why many students show up to school.
But I'm also mindful, just thinking about as I sit here, what a couple of speakers earlier who came to talk about the LCAP and parent engagement.
There were a couple of parents and one in particular who reminded me of something when she talked about the Voting Rights Act.
In the way the criteria is drawn right now, I want to remind you of some students
In my own personal history, because my mother was a high school English teacher at Booker T. Washington High School in Philadelphia, Mississippi, I don't believe those students would be captured by this either.
In September 1964, about a month after three civil rights workers were buried in an earthen dam not far from Booker T. Washington High School, a number of students showed up at Booker T. Washington wearing freedom buttons.
their principal told them to stop wearing the buttons or they would be suspended.
And the students continued wearing those buttons and they were suspended.
That case had to go all the way to the Supreme Court where the Supreme Court had to tell the principal
and that school districts, the students had the right to wear those buttons.
I'm not sure the way this criteria is written that children who participated in the civil rights movement, whether it was in Selma or the students who participated in that movement and in that moment,
in a little teeny dirt bag town in the backwater of Mississippi would be included in this because there's certainly just a footnote in the history books that they, and they should be recognized because they made it, they took an important step.
But I don't think that they would be captured in some way in this criteria because they were suspended for that activist civil rights or that activist civic engagement that's creating all of these problems across the country.
So I think we have to still do some more work.
The reason it's very personal to me is because my mother was a high school English teacher at the time this happened.
The one thing that they never investigated was who those students got those buttons from.
Hint, hint.
All right.
Member Burr.
So I have a couple of questions.
One is, because we have the intent language from the legislature, but is there anything in the statute that talks about the seal being part of the accountability system?
Okay, because I get worried about this.
For the reasons that were articulated in the memo, I really appreciate the memo, that if you want to do something like this, and we've had this conversation, I know, especially Member Sun and I over the years about the Golden State Seal Diploma.
that there's lots of stuff in there that is not standardized.
And so it requires a lot of work to get to a place where the state can validate and say, yep, that's what we're going to do.
Having said that, that doesn't mean that this isn't a great thing to do and a great recognition for individual students.
And so I worry that we're losing kind of the intent here of very specific student action that we want to recognize versus, no, no, let's dump everything into the accountability system.
So I just want to issue a big caution about that as we move forward on that.
And related to that, then, go ahead.
I just want to clarify that our recommendation is to adopt these.
No, no, I know.
I appreciate that.
Yeah, yeah.
No, no, I just wanted to clarify.
I just want to clarify the department's recommendation.
Yeah, because I just wanted to clarify, because people keep talking about, let's go back to the CCI.
I was a big advocate of local indicator.
I would back off of that.
I think we have to be clear about what the purpose here is.
And I'll just say that we also, by only focusing a SEAL at the high school level,
we miss opportunities at the lower levels, whether it's at an elementary level to say, we're gonna make it part of your pupil record that you've done these wonderful things, middle school, whatever.
And I worry about this because I just saw an update that we have, there's another bill to have a state seal of STEAM or STEM or something, right?
And we already have the state seal of biliteracy, but we don't issue that at the elementary level, right?
Okay, so anyway, I just don't want us to lose track of the fact, and when Superintendent Gordon brought up the notion about incentives at the elementary level, I think there are other ways to provide that.
So I know that that's probably not within the purview of what you're working on because of the statute, but I just wanted to issue that as something for all of us to think about as we go forward.
The last thing I wanna mention, and I do this with trepidation, because I have complete respect for what you described, Member Rucker, and I think it is action civics.
I'm not really a big fan of that term, and not because I think it's politically correct or I worry about protesting, because I do think maybe part of it started in California, just a little bit of it.
But I don't think that it's not plain speak.
To me it sounds jargony.
And so I'd either recommend that you kind of go back to civic engagement or some variation of that that mirrors the statute, and just avoid stuff that we are too, I think all of us have a tendency to speak and edu-speak, and I would try to avoid that if we can.
Other comments?
I would also agree with this idea that action civics has a whole different set of connotations,
I wasn't aware of when we initially looked at it and have subsequently been brought forward.
I did want to return, actually, to Criteria 5.
And I think it has, sorry, it's Criteria 5 in the memo, which is exhibit character traits.
Yes, OK, it's the same on this.
And I want to recognize and lift up that I think the department has already done really great work of including
sort of language that talks about concern for the rights and well-being of others and a desire to contribute for the common good of variety of perspectives and valuing differences.
But to board member Rucker's point, I do think there is something uniquely still unstated about what civic participation means and what a notion of the body politic means
that's a little bit more explicit than just saying others.
I think we certainly sometimes use vague terms like others or even more inflammatory things like subgroups, which have a particular under and less than connotation that we should think about sometimes.
But in particular, I do think part of civic participation, because it has
not always been one that has included women or people of color, because civic participation used to not be broadly available, that the onus is on us to not hide from those words and to actually include them explicitly.
Remember, son?
You're kind of motioning like maybe you were ready to.
Yeah, thank you.
I just didn't want to drag the conversation out.
But first of all, I just want to thank you, Barbara, for the memo, the memorandum, because it was very helpful.
I was one of the ones pushing for this on the CCI, and I think it was very helpful to read the analysis that the department did.
I am supportive of these recommendations.
I like the idea of still maybe thinking about exploring
it once we've got the criteria established and we've got the seal moving forward.
I still like the idea of somehow maybe that super higher level inclusion in the CCI, because I think it's worthy of recognizing schools that really promote that kind of engagement.
As far as action civics is concerned, I agree with board member Burr.
I think it's become a term of art in California.
but I've been involved in another professional development for teachers and that ActionCivic is one of the components of this program and I always find that we end up having to have conversations around it or define it in some way so it isn't intuitive for all folks and I think if we're going to utilize that we should need to either define it or
describe in such a way.
It's nothing to do with my you know having an issue with action civics at all.
And I think that I think those were the comments I had.
Okay.
I think we have member Ortiz-Lacon.
I think Superintendent Thurman is waiting.
I have a comment to make as well and is there anybody else who wants to be in the queue?
Okay.
I had never heard of the term action civics, and I was like, oh, I like that term.
But now I didn't realize it was problematized.
But I think whatever we call it, I do think we need to give parameters, whether it's action civics or civic engagement.
I think we do need to make sure the field knows what that looks like.
Board member Sun mentioned that the LCAP, she's been the policymaker and the practitioner.
So I've had the experience with civic engagement where I've been the one blocking the street and then the one worried about the students blocking the street.
So I've been on that.
You've been on both sides.
Yeah, I've been on both sides.
I've been that activist.
And I remember when LAUSD students walking out and walking onto the freeway on ramp worrying about them.
But again, there is that difference.
There's some civic engagement spirit that drove those students to walk out.
And it was for a very worthy cause.
It was a debate around immigration reform.
And at the same time, those are our babies.
And so we do need to make sure that it doesn't become a punitive thing, that we do maybe advise on some parameters of what that means.
But I also do like the idea of going lower, to the lower grades.
And I'm not sold on the accountability.
And again, I've been kind of like the accountability with capital A, I know.
I'm not sold on it because I do think that we need to make sure that this becomes accessible.
And last week we were training our teachers with my other organization, what I do, on using computer science to promote census in the Latino community.
And so I think that we're in a very unique time where we're
You know, we want to have the gold seals for steam and for this and that, but there's ways that we could connect some of these projects.
And I think looking at computer science to look at genuine need in the Latino community, first time that this census will be administered online.
What does that mean for our communities that have been,
part of the digital divide that don't have computer literacy.
You know, so what does that mean when we want to make sure that they're counted in an era where they may not have access to?
So, I think that there's definitely ways that we could try to create nexus between some of the big initiatives we're promoting.
Let's go last.
So, I'm going to take the opportunity to add my comments.
I really want to agree with the notion that we want to make this widely accessible.
And I'm worried even about the language that says on track for completing high school requirements.
Some students come with very little education from other countries and are going to need five years.
And do we mean by on track that you can't earn this if you're needing to make up extra credits?
Some students who are in alternative schools who've had to stop out for
you know, childbirth or incarceration or whatever else or employment or whatever, they may not be, quote, on track in some standard way.
And I think, you know, when we say we want this to be available to all kids, it's a different dimension of learning that I don't want that to become a barrier.
So I would urge us to consider that term and see if there's another way to represent, you know, engagement in academic work in a productive way.
that doesn't cause us to exclude.
I mean, we right now have a graduation rate of about 80%, a little bit above 80%, but that's still one in five students who we would be excluding, and maybe more, because some of those 80% were not on track at a moment in time and had to go to summer school and other things to catch up.
we could be excluding quite a large number of students from it.
I really love the idea that we will think about this going all the way down to preschool.
So nothing that says we can't have a seal of civic engagement for
you know, well, my grandson's two, so.
I don't know how far we can push this, but I do think we wanna think about how to really build it into the way people are growing up.
I think there's a kind of, I'm hearing a sort of a consensus that while we want kids to be active in their engagement in civics, we don't wanna use a jargonistic term that's gonna be a red flag of some sort so that we will,
I aim for that earlier wording of the informed civic engagement in that.
I am among those who think that we should be looking at some way to incorporate perhaps an advanced seal of civic engagement in the CCI or the CCCI to really
honor the serious engagement with this.
There are ways.
I mean, you mentioned there are challenges in thinking about some of those things, but there are ways to do them.
When you become a member of the State Bar, there's a means by which your character is evaluated for that high-stakes judgment about whether you're a member of the State Bar.
There are lots of people working on
project criteria for performance projects of various kinds that can be carried over into this domain.
So I think it's worth us keeping it on the table and getting this moving and then continuing to iterate on whether there are ways to have some kind of recognition that really talks about the democratic, that allows us to recognize
the democratic purposes of schools and all of the metrics and accountability that we engage, which right now exclude that fundamental aspect of what it means to be an educated person.
So we'll just let that conversation unfold over time.
We're going to need to figure out if we're going to make a motion, how to incorporate the various,
know amendments to the language and I don't know whether there's an easy way to do that or whether we need to bring it back to do that.
Okay so we'll put member Rucker go ahead.
I would like to ask that we bring this back because what I heard in the comments was a request to do some more amending
Because as I said, we want to make sure that we are expansive and inclusive in whatever the term of art is that we use to define
the ideals of civic engagement because we want to make sure we're not just including our board member here who obviously would receive this seal.
We want to make sure... Can she meet all five criteria, right?
I certainly hope so.
I'm going to say yes because her parents are still here.
Right, right.
You need to say yes.
But I also want to make sure we're figuring out how to include those students who show up every week and paint the signs for the football game, or who create the floats for the homecoming parade, or who write the columns in their local newspapers about activities going on in those schools.
All of those things are civic engagement.
I want to remember the high school students in Solano County who met me at my car when I brought in those voter registration forms to start registering
16-year-olds because they were all standing in line and waiting to do that because they were very excited about that.
I want to make sure that we're capturing that.
I also want to make sure that we remember students like those kids at Philadelphia, in Philadelphia, Mississippi who were suspended by their principal for engaging in something the school said was wrong, but it was correct and it was the correct thing to do.
So we have to figure out a way to capture those things that are important, not only to us, because we sit here in this lofty room and have this conversation.
at the 5,000 foot level.
But if we're trying to create a recognition of civic engagement, students choose to get engaged in improving the culture and climate of their school for reasons that are intensely personal to them.
And this definition still does not capture that element.
So I really want to make sure we continue working on this and thinking this through.
We still have time to work on this.
I think we should take the time.
Thank you, Madam President.
Thank you, board members, for the direction that you're providing to staff and our team.
I'm going to ask Ms.
Murchison if she would address the president's last question about how we ensure that on track to graduation, how that sentiment is addressed broadly, because I believe that the board gave direction at the last presentation about that being a way to keep the door open and broad rather than closed for who would have an opportunity
I also wanted to ask a question for clarification to board member Rucker so that we could so that we can act on the suggestions that you were making and when you gave the example of the students in Philadelphia, Mississippi, I wondered if you.
I certainly appreciate the sentiment.
I think a lot of times people have different interpretations of what civic engagement or community service.
I'll use a parallel.
Community service gets defined differently.
It's not always something that has a signature form and you get a permission.
Sometimes it's what you do in the community to help someone in your community who needs help.
And in that same way, I think civic engagement can have lots of different
interpretations, and you raised one that I would normally call social disobedience.
And I was wondering if you, and I understand that we've called it different things, and now we have students who've walked out of class to help us improve school safety and community safety.
And I agree with you, it should be broad.
But are you asking for there to be a broad catch-all that ensures that things like social disobedience
would be included so that students didn't get discouraged just because some adult didn't agree, some non-student didn't agree with what the students were actively being civic about.
I want to thank you, Superintendent Thurmond, for asking that question.
I would say an unabashed yes.
I gave the example on Philadelphia and Mississippi on purpose because those students were suspended by their site administrator.
If this is a state seal that is decided by the school leadership and they decide they don't like the behavior that students are engaged in, we have to make sure
that there's guidance in the criteria that recognizes that even if their local leadership may not like what the students have chosen to do, to be engaged.
Because again, in the point that I made, students get involved a lot of times in their school and in their school activities for reasons that are very personal to the students.
And those personal reasons are more important than what the school may say
are the hallmarks of a good citizen.
I want to remind you, even when Martin Luther King was leading the civil rights movement, there are a lot of people in the African-American community who didn't agree with what he was doing.
So it's not whether or not we like what they are doing, it's whether or not it really meets the hallmark of what engagement in the community is supposed to mean.
So yeah, I think we need to look at a way
of looking at leadership is about how you can engage people either in a positive or a negative way.
And there are a lot of examples of people in history who we may not have agreed with or we don't like, but let's be clear, they had an impact on their community.
So we have to think about that.
And we're going to get our last word from our student board member appropriately.
So Brenna, you get the last word.
Yeah, I definitely agree that civic engagement can take so many different forms, and I think that this criteria really has to embody that.
Like you said, students who are more civically engaged could probably, or you know, what we call civic engagement, meet these requirements, but I just don't know if like present written or oral reflection.
Some students who
maybe aren't as privileged, this might not be like their first worry or their first priority to sit down and write or create a presentation, but that might not mean that they aren't engaged in their communities or making a difference.
So I think there needs to be a way to just allow, I don't know, more interpretation based on wherever you live and what kind of situation you are in.
had another robust discussion of the seal of civic engagement.
We really appreciate all the work that you're doing, Barbara, and that all the stakeholders who've been involved in this conversation.
have brought to this.
I think we have a consensus that we'd like to bring it back one more time, or maybe more than once, but hopefully we'll be able to.
Yeah, right, right.
We just like having you present to us and coming to this.
I do like being here.
I think with this new direction to focus on making this a local thing, we can adjust some of this to make it really clear that we were trying to bridge two worlds.
Are we going into the CCI?
Are we going to be a local?
So I think we'll take this and be able to come back with something stronger that reflects a lot of your conversation today, and I appreciate it.
And I think that the notion that there could be two tiers or something, where we develop local criteria, and then if we wanted to move further, we think differently about what needs to be standardized, allows you to be more flexible in the first round of the work that you would be trying to do.
So we'll look forward to seeing you again.
Thanks.
And we're going to take a little break now.
We'll try to come back by 3 so that we can go to the waivers and complete everything.
We're going to be aiming to get out of here by 5 o'clock if we can.
So come back with bells on.
Okay.
I'd like to reconvene the board and move to our consent calendars.
I like the way that member Sun is sitting.
All right, well, I really like the way that member Rucker is sitting and member Pangelinan.
All right.
We are ready to go.
We're ready to rock and roll.
So, we are going to move to our consent calendars.
First, we'll take up the waiver consent items, waivers 1 through 12 and 15.
We will have two votes on the waiver consent items because of member recusals.
First, we'll take up 1 through 12 and 15.
Is there any public comment on waiver 1 through 12 and 15?
No.
Okay, do I have a motion?
Thank you, Member Sandoval.
I move approval of the consent items number 1 through 12.
And 15?
And 15.
All right, let's not forget about 15.
And what about a second?
Thank you, Member Rucker.
Any discussion?
All right.
All in favor?
Aye.
Any opposed?
All right.
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Now we'll take up item W14.
Member Rucker, I believe you need to recuse yourself.
You have to recuse yourself later, I think.
Well, let's see.
You might.
OK.
OK, great.
All right, is there any public comment on waiver 14?
All right.
Do I have a motion?
Is there any discussion here?
Okay.
Do I have a motion?
I move approval of waiver 14.
Thank you, Member Sandoval.
And a second?
Thank you.
I move approval of the CDE recommendation on waiver 14.
And is there a second on that motion?
Thank you, Member Byrd.
Any discussion?
All right, all of those in favor say aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Okay, member Rucker, woo!
All right.
All right, now we're all back.
So now we're gonna take up Waiver 13 and Waiver 16 for separate action.
First, with respect to Waiver 13, the request by Dublin Unified School District to waive Education Code Section 56362C, allowing the caseloads of resource specialists to exceed the maximum caseload of 28 students by no more than four students, is up for discussion.
This will be presented by Kristen Wright of the CDE.
Kristen, please begin.
Thank you.
Good afternoon Chair Hannon and board members.
It's great to be here with you today.
I'm Kristen Wright, Director of Special Education Division here at the Department of Education.
I am here to bring up two waivers, the first of which is Dublin Unified.
These waivers, as you know, are regarding statutory language that allows for
a 28 student caseload for education specialists, RSP teachers, and in order for them to go above that, which is a cap at 32, they need to seek a waiver with you all to get approved.
So this particular waiver is for one teacher.
We
Last time we were here in front of you, you asked us to look into some additional information on waivers in general.
So just wanted to make sure you knew where we stood.
We looked to see if when waivers, if there were any waivers in the past with these particular districts, and if so, how many and when.
So for Dublin, we didn't have any previous waivers.
Again, this is for one teacher in one school up to the 32 caseload cap.
And we recommend to you that you approve this waiver with conditions.
And as you also know, part of our waiver process is to ensure that we've asked whether or not the union has been consulted on waivers.
and whether or not the teacher has agreed to the waivers.
And so all of that went into weighing our recommendation to you of approval.
And so I understand there were some conversations between the union and the school district.
When we first received the waiver, we understood that there was a neutral position, basically, and
In talking to the district and the union, there was some communication issues, I believe, around this particular issue.
We learned that perhaps the district was not in favor of the waiver, but I'll let them speak to that if they wish to do so.
And so that's that.
I'm sorry, the union.
I'm sorry, I did not mean that.
I meant the union.
And then, thank you.
And then did you wanna do this waiver first and then go into the second waiver?
Okay, so our recommendation from CDE is to approve the waiver with the conditions that you see and just ensuring that the district, I believe in this case, the district reported that they had put out for this particular position and had difficult time filling it.
And as you know, we're facing a shortage in the state around special education teachers, so that's what we have.
OK, so I first want to ask Nikki Sandoval as our liaison if she has any initial comments.
And then we'll go to public comments, and then we'll have a conversation with the board.
I don't have any initial public comments.
I'd love to hear the public comment.
I'd love to hear the other perspectives that are here today.
Presentation from the district.
We have two public comments, Michael Juba and Tara Kyle.
OK, thank you.
Long afternoon.
Good afternoon, everybody.
Good afternoon, Mr. Allen Hammond and esteemed board members.
My name is Michael Juba, and I'm speaking on behalf of CTA.
CTA does not support this waiver for the following three reasons.
A special ed teacher took on this caseload of more than 28 from fall of 2018 to 2019.
And during this time period, there was no meeting, no bargaining session, no time allocated for the resolution of the caseload over its issue.
Two.
Communication.
And although the Dublin Unified School District made the Dublin Teachers Association aware in a very informal manner, there were no formal discussions or planning or rationale or solutions from the district so that this does not happen again.
M3, awareness.
The Dublin Teach Association brought this to the school district with this issue of the caseload to try to solve it, yet there was no response and it was never really formally discussed in a formal manner.
And it's for these reasons that we recommend that you deny this waiver.
So thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Tara Kyle.
I'm the assistant director of special education for Dublin Unified.
And I worked with staff and I submitted this request for the waiver.
And I'd like to just make some comments because I understand there was some concern specifically around the specific teachers caseload and the consult with the teachers union.
So I personally did have two conversations with the bargaining unit president, let her know that
We had been trying to fill this position.
I had had conversations with her.
She knew it was posted.
So I had two conversations with her in person.
I asked her when we were going to apply for the waiver.
I let her know that part of the process is discussing it with her and getting approval or not approval from her.
She asked me to put the information into email.
I did that.
I sent it to her.
After two weeks, I had no response.
So I followed up with an email and still received no response.
At that point, it was the end of May.
We'd been working on this for probably two nights.
and still received no response until CBE requested information from her and at that point she replied.
I'm told that we're permitted to ask questions of the district and perhaps also your party if there are any.
So maybe we should see if anyone has any questions for them before we
engage in discussion.
Does anyone have any questions for the district representative or the union representative?
Okay.
I guess I do have a question for the district representative if that's okay.
So I would just like to kind of hear what the process was for trying to
avoid the caseload overage and the search process and so on.
I don't feel like we have an entire sense of how it evolved.
The 18-19 school year, when school started, we realized right away that we were going to need to keep a close eye on the caseload.
I don't know if you know Dublin Unified, but it's
one of the fastest growing districts in the state, if not the fastest growing.
And so that particular summer, we had an exorbitant amount of students move in, more than we had planned on.
So we knew right away to start watching caseloads, because there were more students than we had planned on.
Within probably the first month and a half of school, we knew that we needed to look for additional staff because we knew we were approaching that case load max very quickly.
So in October, we started discussing staff.
We had a position posted, I believe, in November or December.
And we're trying to recruit actively for several months until we got to the point
March where we started looking at the waiver in December, one teacher actually did reach that 28 and then went over.
So that's when we started looking at it.
So up until December, no teachers were at that caseload of 28.
You want to continue with the question?
Well, I'll let member Rucker ask the follow-up question and then I'll come back.
OK, so while you were talking and while
President Darling-Hammond was asking you about what you had been doing on this.
I read this letter that came from Roberta Kreitz, the president of Dublin, and I'm struck by two statements that she made that seem to differ
with what it is you explained that has happened in your conversation on the waiver.
First of all, it says that the district office didn't work to resolve or bargain a resolution to the issue of the large caseload when it was first raised to their attention in the fall of 2018.
And then the second statement that's in this letter says
Dublin Unified did make the Association aware of the waiver.
This letter says in writing that Dublin Unified said no from the very beginning, but what you wrote on the waiver
is that the association was neutral.
So the association is putting in writing that they said no from the very beginning.
You wrote on the waiver that they said that they were neutral.
So while I'm willing to chalk all of that up to a communication problem, my concern is that this was raised as a bargaining issue.
In the past, what this board has done, when we've been made aware that this has been a bargaining issue, we've tabled waivers like this to the next board meeting to ask you,
both of you, the association, the district, to come back to us at the next board meeting and tell us, are you going to be able to resolve this or do you still need the waiver?
Is that something that you would be able to do?
Yes, in the spring.
No, I don't think I asked the question right.
So what I'm suggesting, because there seems to be even a disagreement about what the content or the depth of your conversations were,
either at the bargaining table or whether or not the association has always been adamant in not supporting the waiver.
Because you wrote they were neutral, but they said they have adamantly not supported your waiver.
I'm asking, is there a way to simply table this waiver today and have you come back in November and be able to report what your conversations with the association has been so that we're not getting in the middle of a discussion that you had either at the bargaining table
or in your ongoing conversations that people don't seem to know how it was resolved, actually.
Would that be a problem?
To come back?
Absolutely not.
Okay.
I'd like to invite you to go ahead and finish explaining whatever you wanted to say about the spring.
Oh, and I was going to say something that I think is not addressing the question.
Oh, that's OK.
I was just going to say that in the springtime, we were in the middle of negotiations also with our bargaining unit when all this was going on, all of our conversations.
And as part of the agreed upon contract, it does state in there there's caseload caps.
And we already know that in EdCode, the resource is a 28 cap.
But a cap went in for our special day classes as well.
And a dollar amount for every student that goes over that amount.
But it also said for resource students that a waiver will be requested.
And so at that point, I would consider that the union was agreeing that, yes, you would go forward with a waiver.
But of course, that doesn't mean on a specific waiver that they would agree with the process on that specific waiver.
And just another comment, in the paperwork,
I think if I said it was neutral, I don't know if there was a way to say that there was no response.
I in no way intended to say that they told us they did not have an opinion because there wasn't one.
There had been no communication at all that I'm aware of that they were opposed to it at all until the email was sent to the CDE consultant in June that they did not
So definitely, the communication is not where it should be.
We have several folks ready to ask questions.
And if the gentleman from the union also wants to be available for questions, we will direct them in both directions.
Member Sun, member Burr, I'm sorry, member Strauss, and who else?
That's it?
I guess two points of clarification that I know that it is required for the bargaining units to put an opinion in on a waiver it is we don't necessarily need to follow that they can just provide their response but it's not a condition of waiver or you know doesn't impact our decision right I'm just want to make sure
And then the other is the individual teacher that we're discussing here.
If I were to clarify, that question seemed like it should have been directed to Danielle.
So let's put this in some order.
So if people have questions for either the district or union representative, let's do those first and then come back and ask questions of Kristen Wright.
It can go to whoever, it just doesn't belong going to this person.
Yes, so my question is that on waivers, when we solicit whether or when the district solicits the response of the bargaining unit, we have that information, but it is not part of the consideration of the waiver itself or the staff's recommendation?
Is it?
I don't know.
It's information for you to weigh into the process.
So we make sure that we have, I think the, the, if I could guess what the idea of it was, the intention was, is to make sure that everyone was aware of what was going on.
So this is just, we do ask the question as part of the waiver process.
and we report back to you on it, on what we found.
Great, thank you.
And then this question I think is more prudent.
So the teacher we're discussing, he or she is aware of the caseload, and he or she will be compensated for the additional students, right?
And are we hearing any protests from that particular teacher?
No, so this was from last December through May.
I see.
He was compensated part of the waiver process.
The waiver process itself doesn't include compensation, but we agreed to compensate.
Right.
Then it was added later as part of the contract.
So he's been compensated and now his caseload is okay.
Within the thing.
Okay, thank you.
Member Strauss?
district question so I understand you're not huge and the number went over and this is a last year it's 18-19 so my question is so he's been compensated from last year it's now in your contract what is the current state this year for your caseloads?
school post loads are all, we've got, we added this year because of the increase, one full-time resource specialist and one half-time resource specialist.
And so they all have, they're all running around 25, 26, 27.
And which is still higher than we'd like it to be.
I mean it's still something that we're having to really keep an eye on.
And hopefully we won't have to look for a teacher mid-year again.
Member Nava.
So the supplemental waiver form that the resource teacher has to fill out, they agreed to go over.
OK.
And this is last year.
So maybe Special Ed Director Kristen Wright can answer this question.
And I believe I know the answer to this.
If it's already post, already happened,
What's the consequence of the denial?
So what happens?
The question is, is what happens if you deny it?
What happened?
Yes.
If it's already happened.
It has already happened.
Yes.
And so if you deny it, then we would do probably, we would do a similar activity that we would if you approved it with conditions, right?
We would.
So if, so if you deny the waiver, the waiver, it already occurred, the student, the teacher already had those students.
So we can't go back and correct that or tell them they can't do it.
right?
They did it already.
I think what we want to collectively want to do is assist them and make sure that it doesn't happen in the future, right?
We want to make sure that teachers are not having huge caseloads that impact students and impact them and impact retention.
And so what we would do is we would follow up on it and we would ask them to probably show the same evidence and proof that they would if you approved it with conditions.
Which was my point.
Because the reality is, is they've already corrected it.
But if they hadn't, what would the consequence be then?
Then it would have been approved with conditions, because you have to have a place for those students to go.
So essentially, you can't deny a student a case manager, even if there's no waiver.
But you would follow up and say, you need to put some steps in place so it doesn't happen in the future in this situation.
So I don't know if what I appreciate board member Rutgers table it.
I'm not sure what we are gaining by that.
The board member.
Board Member Rucker.
Okay, so but as it relates to the OSEP report that you have to submit next year, there are some things concerning compliance that this district would have to address if the way or have to report if the waiver was denied as it relates to that compliance report.
Is that correct?
No, because I'm not sure exactly what you're talking about, but usually we report on highly qualified teachers.
Okay.
not on number of teachers within a statutory state statutory caseload.
So to board member Novel's point, you know, the reason why I was recommending that because, because I, you know, we tend to want to support the district in their effort and approve it.
But I understand his point since it's already been corrected, they've hired the teacher denying it does not have a consequence at this time.
And the reason why I was recommending table it, because there seems to be a dispute about how it was handled, the assistant superintendent said that tabling it would not be a problem because it would give them a chance to finish out their conversation with their association and let them report, here's what we've agreed to do with the association going forward.
So tabling it or denying it does not have a sustained effect or negative impact.
the district because they've already attempted to resolve it.
What I'm trying to do is make sure we don't interfere with the work they're supposed to be doing with their association if the association feels the district misrepresented their opinion or their position about the waiver because what you reported is that you're giving us all the information that's known.
It's not correct that the information about the association's position was accurately reported.
So the association representative is also raising his hand.
I'd like to invite him.
I think it's also important to make sure that you know in terms of the waiver process, it's a drop down menu that says approve, oppose or neutral.
So there's not like an extra box that says a situation necessarily.
So it does, it makes it a little more difficult.
Yeah.
Would you like to please come to the podium and make the statement that you were hoping to make?
Michael Juba, first time CTA liaison here.
And this is trial by fire.
I love it.
I think, just real quickly, I'm a fifth grade elementary school teacher about six miles down the road in the Elk Grove Unified School District.
So I've been a Title I teacher my whole life.
My parents were teachers in Antioch Unified and Oakland Unified.
So I have kind of a peripheral view on this as a regular classroom teacher working with special ed teachers.
So I understand the caseload issue.
I'd like to read the verbiage that I got so that
guys could be caught up to speed on what the history was from what we got from our perspective.
May I?
The district office did not work to resolve a bargain to resolution of the issue of the large caseload when it first raised to their attention the fall of 2018.
The teacher was offered a deal by the Director of Special Education without any communication to the Teacher's Association or Human Resources.
This deal included an offer of time card hours for the time the student
or students above the legal limit was in their class and or their caseload.
The teacher proceeded to log in all the data, complete the time cards through the spring, and in 2019, turn them in.
Teacher was not paid what was agreed to in this deal, and they sought union intervention to receive the compensation, which is how the teacher association leadership was made aware of the deal.
In April 2019, the association reached a bargaining agreement
and the language included special education compensation retro to that July 1st, 2018.
So now we had a situation here.
Upon ratification, the director of special education decided the teacher would be paid using that formula and not the formula used for the deal that was spelled out.
So the Teachers Association intervened to the level of the superintendent to ensure that the teacher was paid the amount owed starting in November 2018.
So it seems like a big ball of yarn.
I wanted to make sure you guys were aware of that.
Thank you for the ball of yarn.
I think that there's a lot of issues on the table.
One is kind of a process issue for how these things get addressed in local districts.
And what we decide, whether it's approval with conditions or denial, may send a message about that process and whether the process is followed, even though it will have no different impact
on what goes on in the district.
So I think that's one of the questions.
A second question about the way in which these overages are handled for me is that, and particularly in light of the very high caseload in California law, which is more than twice what it is in many other states, it's usually about 12 to 1.
in the states that have caseload.
And that's for the protection of the students.
It's for the safety and protection of the students and the proper, free, appropriate and education of students with special education needs.
So even if one could strike a deal with an individual teacher to increase their caseload and pay them more, certainly there's more work involved.
There's also, you know, risk to students when we, you know, approve very, very high caseloads of children who have special needs with respect to the degree to which they're getting properly taught.
So there's separate issues around, you know, how we handle these waivers that have to do with the welfare of children on the one hand,
and the way in which employees work.
And we know that, of course, caseload is a big issue for the retention of special education teachers right now, many of whom are putting in their credentials, trying to return their credentials to the CTC so they won't be asked to teach special education because the combination of the high caseload and the paperwork and the demands of the job is just so severe.
So I think in a case where we have a question both about the process
and about the outcome, it's useful to at least stipulate conditions and potentially to deny because it's not going to have an effect on what the district does other than to say this is not good practice.
And we should be trying to encourage better practices among districts.
And when they're not able to enact those practices,
we should bring it to the attention of the district to improve their practice.
So I think that's a framework just within which to think about the questions that are before us.
I invite any other questions to Kristen Wright or any other discussion that people have before we take a motion.
It's understandable.
Director Wright, if I could just.
So just to clarify, there is ongoing communication with the district.
And there's been improved communication between the association and the district.
So there's no, I don't.
OK.
Right.
So if we choose to accept the CD's recommendation with conditions that there'll be ongoing support connection to help address the caseload matter, if we choose to deny it, the same activities will occur between the department and the district.
And then we can't assume that there is any improved communication or problem solving effort between
the district and the association.
We don't know, that's not clear at all.
Which if I may, that's the reason why I was suggesting maybe we table it and ask the district and the association to clarify what they're trying to resolve and if it's actually been resolved given the details that he's had here and that would help us to make sure we're making an informed decision about what to do, whether to approve with conditions in November or deny.
That's the reason why I was suggesting that.
as an option.
It already has happened.
The situation has already gone through resolution.
Since we're clear that there was not good practice that happened here, it's not clear whether or not the district and the association can resolve, given everything that Michael Juba just explained about what went on.
I think, and the assistant superintendent said it wouldn't be a problem to table it and allow her to have that conversation and come back to report it to us.
I think that that's an option as well.
I guess I would say.
This is getting beyond the scope of what the waiver is about here.
So as part of the waiver process, the district needs to consult with the union.
There seems to be a question about when that consultation happened, were they neutral, the dropdown menu.
But some of the issues regarding pay, back pay, whether the teacher felt, all those kind of things.
Oh, I'm not raising, let me be clear, I'm not raising the issue about the negotiation.
I'm raising the issue that it seems
in the consultation process something was misrepresented or misreported.
And I do believe the assistant superintendent that there was no intention to misrepresent what their conversations with the association were, but I think the consultation process
did not occur as it was intended in this process.
So, I'm not, I don't have any dispute about the bargaining.
I'm not, that's not an issue for me.
I'm saying it was what something was misreported here.
Well, I was just concerned because we were talking about improved communication and things like that.
I mean that's, there's some issues going on in this district that are well beyond the scope of the waiver.
I guess that's what I wanted to emphasize.
Yeah, so that's not the issue within the scope of the waiver.
Right, and that's not the issue I'm raising.
I'm saying
that given how they have to use the tool, and I do, again, let me emphasize, I don't believe that there was an intent on the district's part to misrepresent what they did with the association, but they did not give the correct information about the association's perspective in this process.
So that's what I'm saying.
Give them the opportunity to resolve that and come back to us with the waiver in November.
That's what I'm suggesting.
I guess I'm not quite sure what would be different in November.
Just to clarify to Ms.
Wright and to Judy, my understanding is this happened last year.
They did compensate.
There was some communication problem.
But they did ultimately, excuse me.
Okay, but they did complete in negotiation some plan going forward for teachers who were over their caseload.
And this year it is,
not a situation, they've hired to address it, and whether we deny or approve with conditions, the follow-up will be the same from CDE.
And this is a single teacher situation that the district has now hired to address.
Are those facts right so far?
And the question that Member Rucker's bringing up is the communication between the district and the teacher in the union.
That's what we do.
That's right, I understand.
Okay, thank you.
Okay, do we want to take a motion?
Member Sandoval?
Yeah, so I appreciate all the discussion around this and I will move approval of the CDE's recommendation to approve the waiver with the conditions outlined in the recommendation.
Is there a second?
I'll second.
Member Sun, any further discussion?
Okay, all those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Nay.
One.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Motion passes.
Thank you.
Yes, you are.
You may not go away.
I'm still Kristen, right?
Now we will hear W-16, which is waiver request by Manteca Unified School District to waive education sections 56362C, allowing the caseloads of resource specialists to exceed the maximum caseload of 28 students by no more than four students.
The CDE recommends denial.
This item will be presented by no other than Kristen Wright of the California Department of Education.
Please begin.
This is similar, but a little dissimilar to the last in the sense that this is just this is a situation where we have
12 resource specialists in the District of Manteca that are over the caseload of 28 students.
And the reason that we're, there's two reasons that we are requesting denial.
The first one is that there are so many.
And so the second reason is that the reason that we were given was housing growth, so growth in general in Manteca.
which doesn't necessarily represent something you couldn't have predicted was going to happen.
And so in this scenario, we do recommend a denial.
However, if you decided to approve, you could approve with conditions which we listed out in here, which would be similar.
to the last one.
So I think in general it's fair to say that when we see situations or get complaints from teachers or a district on their own, like in this situation, came and requested the waiver themselves, I think one thing to think about is
there is a disincentive to outing yourself around having a higher caseload because the ways we would necessarily be able to know is if a district told us and applied for a waiver or if we were in the district monitoring or we got a complaint.
And so in this scenario, you have our recommendation and I'm here if you have any questions about that.
As you can see, if you look at the item, there were 12 different instances requested.
Yes.
Member Sandoval?
I have a question about how we are connecting and supporting in this particular case with so many sites having the same issue.
Sure.
So one of the things to consider is typically we look at when it occurred that they needed this, like what part of the year was it.
And sometimes, as many of you know, kids don't get referred for special education until later in the year.
And so what we tend to see then is, is that that's when the caseloads would go up.
And it is really hard to hire a teacher mid-year.
I think, you know, that was one of the things our last presenter said, but to have this, to have this many is just,
it causes you to take a moment of pause.
One of the things to also think about is that it was across many schools.
And so the question is, well, why was it across many schools?
One way to look at it is that, um, this, the students would be served in their, maybe their local school, which, which may be a positive in some ways than having them all bused to one school.
So, you know, um, I,
There are pros and cons to this, but we went more in the area of denial because, again, we would have assumed that you would have been able to predict this wasn't like some thing you couldn't have predicted.
And secondly, that we do know that it's difficult on teachers and on students when you have really high caseloads.
Well, and if you have growth and if you have
everybody up at the max already, you're going to have this challenge.
Member Navo.
I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
I didn't mean to cut you off.
That's all right.
So if we accept the motion to deny the waiver, what kind of help will we be giving the district?
So we would be working with the district first to ensure that they were doing everything that they could.
I think the second piece is it would be more about us having regular check-ins with them.
I mean, every place in the state is challenged with getting enough special educators.
And so we have monitors that work with specific regions that we would assign, and we would work hand-in-hand with them if there was anything we could do to assist them.
So it would be more about us looking at the specific issues related to what the causal factors were and that sort of thing.
But we would certainly offer our assistance and partnership.
I'd just like to add to that that in the last year, $50 million was allocated for innovation grants for getting and keeping special ed teachers, which includes paying attention to retention as well as to recruitment.
And money was allocated for teacher residencies, for special ed teachers, and for service scholarships and forgivable loans.
So there are tools and resources that districts can now begin to rely on when they're in a situation that they are struggling to staff classrooms.
I also forgot to point out that the union was in favor of this particular waiver.
Matt, Member Navo?
So this one is interesting because of the union support of this particular way, if I understand.
So how would the denial be different from the approval with conditions actions, based on the last conversation we had?
They'd be the same.
The same application.
Yeah, it would be the same.
OK.
So at this point, all we would be doing is sending a message to the district.
It's already happened.
We want you to go through these steps and work with CDE to resolve the issue, to make sure this is beyond the barriers that you're having are beyond your control or influence.
In other words, you're posting flyers for hires.
You're doing everything you can to outreach for qualified candidates, and you can't get people.
We're trying to get to the root cause if we deny.
Yeah, OK.
And hopefully you're working with your teachers to make the workload and the context one in which they won't leave, right?
Member Sun, did you want to?
Okay.
Are there other comments?
Public comments.
We have one public comment, Susan Turner.
Good afternoon.
My name is Susan Turner, and I am the director of special education in Manteca.
And I am very pleased to be here to be able to explain things further.
One of the reasons that we applied for 12 this year is because we did have agreement with our bargaining unit that we predicted that we were going to exceed our 28 cap because we had a large
referral for initial assessments in the month of actually late February and March.
And so I suspected that it was likely we could go over before we were able to hire an additional teacher to try to absorb those, even if 75% or 80% of those initial assessments turned out to be eligible students.
But the agreement we had with our bargaining unit was that, for the best interest of students, we would not exceed going over by two.
Although the state allowed, in the waiver process, to go over by four, we didn't feel that was good for our students, so we would only go over by two.
Our average at elementary level was 26 for caseload.
I thought I was speaking, actually not as a comment, but I believe I signed up to speak, did I?
Maybe I misunderstood that.
And then at the high school level, our average caseload for resource was 22.
So we did have low numbers.
What occurred is that the numbers kind of exploded at particular sites.
And because we didn't want to go over by two, actually, I think we went over, it was an average of 1.58 in the end.
students.
Some had went over by one, some went over by two.
By the time we hired a person, which we did, I hired a person in late February.
By the time her fingerprinting and paperwork was completed and she was able to get into the classroom at the late part of March, we had already gone over like by one
or two at these sites.
But I wanted to be legit about the entire process, file the waivers, and then ultimately we were able to serve students with no problem for the remainder of the year after we got the new resource teacher on board in late March.
So that's kind of how it happened.
It's just that we couldn't, I went out, recruited a teacher, but it took a while, about a month or so to get her actually on board and in the classroom ready to serve students.
Our teachers actually are very committed to their students at their schools.
They were compensated.
They were very pleased to be able to keep their own students that were their students at their sites.
Our bargaining unit was in agreement to that because the teachers, everybody was in agreement with that and how it happened.
We were putting great efforts forward to get somebody hired.
As of this year, I hired three at the elementary, three new additional special ed teachers at elementary level, and then two additional special ed teachers at the high school level.
So we're trying to make sure we are allowing for
like Kristen said, at the end of the year where you kind of get this increase in referrals.
And then also, one of the other things that we're doing as a district, we're kind of dealing with our, we're putting our own conditions in place.
We, I as the Director of Special Education am, I am in constant collaboration now with our
director of HR in the certificated part, so that we together can make sure not only do we have enough space for in the resource class, but we have enough space across the grade levels in general ed.
One of the issues also we faced was when we went to overflow,
a student, we did not have a general ed spot for that student.
We had the research spot, but we didn't have the grade level for that student in the general ed spot to be able to overflow that student.
So we had a cluster of resource vacancies, but they unfortunately weren't at the right schools.
And I think part of that is, yeah, we have growth, but with that growth in our communities, we serve for cities and towns people when we have new building.
happening, people up and tend to move between the four cities and towns.
So where you think you might need the space for resource, sometimes it ends up being somewhere else.
And you know what I mean?
So that is kind of what we're facing.
It's kind of constantly trying to strategize and place your teachers at the right schools.
Thank you.
Yeah, did you want to have?
Okay, should I have Director Wright come back?
I was going to let her go and let Director Wright come back up and then we can, if we have any more questions and comments, go ahead.
I just have to say I appreciate the challenge mid-year in running a school in a district and
guess where students.
The other thing is I understand the process of identifying a student, doing the assessment, and believing they need support, an additional support.
And a student who's already struggling mid-year and then gets identified for support, and then asking them or saying you need to move because the support is across town at other schools, that's another extra challenge for a kid that may already be struggling.
So, I just think it's complicated.
I think President Darling-Hammond and saying staffing lower.
So, you give yourself enough flexibility is always the best strategy, but I think we have to be thoughtful in the end.
What's our best for our kids, especially come February, March, they've already spent six months and.
to get identified and then you have to place them again.
So I just think it's not a black and white answer.
I think let's lower staffing given the resources, which is always the best option, because then there's places when kids do get identified.
But I get concerned about moving kids mid-year when they're already having identified problems and then they have to change schools, which can be really a trauma for lots of kids.
Anyway, just a comment.
Comments?
I'm not seeing any other comments.
Do we have a motion?
Yeah, thank you.
I appreciate all of the information presented, and I really appreciated hearing from the district representative about the special education director.
And I know that in this particular case, there were so many schools involved, so many students affected, so many resource specialists.
So I do appreciate the department's recommendation to deny the waiver.
However, I do feel that because the results are going to be the same and I would recommend actually approving the waiver that's being presented and not going with the CDE's recommendation to deny the waiver.
Imposing the same conditions, absolutely.
Approval of conditions is your motion?
Yes.
Is there a second?
In the item, I'll refer to the actual page.
Yeah.
But there are actual conditions that are listed in the item.
So for example, if we decided to approve the waiver, they recommend specific conditions, and they're listed in the item.
It says right on the second page, page two, it says, however, should the SBE disagree, the district must submit to the special education division documentation of the district's efforts to recruit and employ fully credentialed resource specialists for 19-20.
And now mind you, this waiver was supposed to be heard last time, so that's part of it saying that the start of this year, which already started.
The district, and it sounds like they have hired, and so we will verify all that.
Right?
Postings of flyers, job listings in newspapers, online listings such as EdJoin, participation in career employment fairs, active recruitment at universities, involvement with IAGEs, Institutes of Higher Education for programs on teacher training, and use of LEA-based teacher training and career ladders for current staff.
Those are the things that we'll check back in with the district to verify and discuss that they show us evidence that they're doing those things.
And also at the top of page three was the last condition.
Thank you, member Sandoval, for being such a good reader.
And that's the documentation piece, that all RSP teacher caseloads are at 28 or less by the beginning of this year.
Correct.
Do we have a second to that motion?
I will second that.
Thank you.
Is there any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Motion passes.
Thank you.
And we've already had our break, so we're going to, you may feel like you need a break, but we are going to continue.
Now we're going to take up the, I think the regular consent items at this point, right?
And we have a few recusals that will occur.
First we'll take up items six through 10.
Are there any public comments on items six through 10?
Yes, one on item eight, Katie Nielsen.
My name is Katie Nielsen.
I'm a registered credential school nurse and a board member with the California School Nurses Organization.
And I would like to encourage you to approve the vision screening guidelines.
Thank you.
Any other comments?
I guess not.
So, are there any other comments from the board members?
Shall we just vote?
Do I have a motion?
Move approval.
Member Strauss?
And a second?
Member Navo?
Thank you.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
All right, motion carries.
Now we'll take up consent item 11 to approve the 2019-20 consolidated applications.
You're not leaving yet, Felicia.
We need two separate votes for this item because of member recusals.
Member Navo and Strauss have recused themselves.
Now we will take up the CONAPs for the following four districts, numbers one through four and attachment one, which include Arcadia Unified, Ceres Unified, Boosting Unified, and Monrovia Unified.
Are there any public comments for the CONAPs for these first four districts listed in Attachment 1?
None.
Okay.
Seeing no public comment, I'll ask for a motion on Item 11 for the CONAPs for the first four districts listed in Attachment 1.
Member Rucker and a second?
Member Sandoval?
Any discussion?
All right.
All those in favor say aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Members Strauss and Navajo can return to the dais.
All right.
A little bit of musical chairs here.
We should have some music playing so that people can run to their chairs.
All right.
Now we'll vote on the rest of the CONAPs, and members Ortiz, Lacone, and Sun have recused themselves for this vote.
Are there any public comments on item 11 for the remaining CONAPs listed in attachment 1?
No.
All right.
Seeing no public comment, we'll ask for a motion on item 11 for the remaining.
Thank you, Member Rucker, and thank you, Member Strauss, as a second.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Retrieve our members.
Yes, please retrieve the members.
Okay.
So now we're at item 12 to discuss a revised timeline for the mathematics framework.
CDE recommends that the SBE approve the revised schedule of significant events, 2021 revision of the math framework for California public schools, and this item will be presented by Stephanie Gregson.
So, Stephanie, please begin.
Yes, good afternoon.
I know I'm your last action item, so I will be quick, but I do have visuals.
So as we all understand, time is precious and valuable.
So with this item, we are recommending the gift of time in the math framework process as we want to ensure we have built in time between significant actions of the Instructional Quality Commission and the State Board of Education.
The framework process is a public, transparent, and inclusive one that has many opportunities for input and also several decision points as outlined in this timeline.
The recommended timeline revisions include moving Instructional Quality Commission recommendations of the Curriculum, Framework, and Evaluation Criteria Committee members' Framework Guidelines to November with State Board action in January.
The other revisions include providing leeway in Instructional Quality Action on the drafts of the Math Framework as it moves through the development process.
And we've learned quite a bit about the implementation of the California Common Core Standards and Mathematics since they were adopted.
And we want to ensure that we are providing ourselves with the necessary time to incorporate all of the recent research and our new learnings within the updated math framework.
So this is our recommendation to revise the timeline.
That's it.
Any clarification questions needed from the?
I think we're almost brain dead.
I was going to take public comment, if there is any.
Yes, Angela DeRamos.
Did we lose our commenter?
Oh, here she comes, great.
We were under the understanding that the timeline also had an item about the Ethnic Studies Model Curriculum, but I think I'm in error.
Okay.
All right.
So, I do want to ask Member Rucker, as our liaison, if she has any initial comments, and then we'll go to Member Straus and any other comments that folks have.
Well, I'm very excited to see this work begin.
And Dr. Gregson is correct.
We've learned a lot about the MAS adoption.
I want to say for the committee members who worked on the previous framework, that was the very first framework that the department and the board and the IQC undertook after the adoption of the state common core standards.
We've learned a lot about the standards adoption process, but also we've learned a lot about how the framework needs to frame
the conversation of implementation.
So I'm very excited to see us now come back full circle.
This was the first framework and I was appointed as the liaison for this.
I'm very excited to see us come back now and come full circle to this framework.
and apply a lot of the things that we've learned.
Going back to something that Board Member Burr continues to say, we are focused on continuous improvement.
What we do with updating and improving this framework will be a clear model of the board's commitment to that, living with the question and the practice of continuous improvement.
So it's a very exciting thing to see begin.
Yeah, it is.
All right, Member Strauss.
Member Rucker and I liaison to IQC and to many of the adoption framework processes and following this framework which we were involved with, the subsequent frameworks, ELA and ELD, ELA, ELD, history, social science, and the follow-up, we improved our format of the frameworks and included vignettes and snapshots.
So I actually totally support and just want to enhance the comments that
member Reker and Stephanie Gregson have said, which is we're getting better at our frameworks and those who've implemented the Common Core math standards and have been out there coaching and collaborating and working with principals and teachers know now more that we've implemented that we can really do a really stronger enhancement of this framework.
So I think the subsequent frameworks have standard chapters that we will add in our
our next iteration of this.
So I think it's really exciting.
And it will even be stronger than our first shot out the gate.
We've really been working on this for a long time.
Thank you.
Any other comments?
Easy item.
All right, we're going to move on.
No, we have to move it.
I'm sorry.
We're going to move on to move it.
Who would like to make a motion?
I move approval.
Member Rucker?
All right.
We have a staff recommendation concerning the change in the significance.
I'll second.
All right.
I'm sorry.
Was that Member Strauss who seconded?
Okay, great.
All right.
Any other discussion?
All those in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
Any abstentions?
Motion carries.
Thank you, Stephanie.
Agenda item 13 is our state board projects and priorities item to take up our minutes from our July 2019 meeting and SBE liaison reports.
The SBE staff recommends that we approve the preliminary report of actions minutes for the July 10, 2019 meeting.
Do I have a motion from a board member to approve those, the preliminary report of action meeting minutes?
Member Nava, thank you very much.
Is there a second?
Member Burr, thank you.
Any discussion?
Before we take a vote, someone signed up for public comment, so we should probably call that.
Oh, on the minutes?
Okay.
William Templetto.
Sorry.
Was that intended to be on the minutes or for general public comment?
It was signed up for this item, but the individual doesn't appear to be here, so we can move on.
Okay, we'll proceed.
Is there any discussion on the minutes?
All right.
All those in favor say aye.
All opposed?
Any abstentions?
Thank you.
And the motion carries.
Now I want to invite members to report on any liaison activities that are not related to any of the items on our agenda.
We're going to go in reverse alphabetical order, so those who are at the end of the alphabet feel privileged in the way that those at the beginning of the alphabet have traditionally been privileged.
So, member's son, you get to begin.
Woo-hoo!
All right.
So there's just two quick things.
One is that the California Joint Workforce Pathways Committee is meeting on Friday.
We will be looking at the first initial draft of the Perkins plan.
So we're looking forward to that.
And I will report back at some point
In the January time frame, it will be coming to the board as a draft as well.
So just wanted to give you guys a heads up on that.
The other thing I just want to bring up, I received a letter from a student from Howell Middle School.
And this was sent back in May.
So I feel badly that I did not raise this in July.
This is from Jonathan Law.
And he was given an assignment to raise awareness of an education issue.
And so he hoped that it would be mentioned.
And so he did write a very eloquent letter regarding financial literacy and the need for financial literacy in education.
So I wanted to raise that because he ends that he is appreciative of my and the colleagues' contributions and to help youth gain new insights into their future and be a pioneer in the school system and recreate the American dream.
So I very much appreciate that, and I just wanted to mention that.
Again, Jonathan Law, who wrote that letter.
Very good.
Thank you very much.
And Vice President Strauss.
So I have a couple of items.
One, right after the State Board meeting in July, I went to the Education Commission of the States National Forum because our meeting was one day, actually, and I got to attend.
And it's really interesting because they really talk about the top educational policy changes across the country because there were so many leadership changes at State.
level and the challenges.
So they do some comparisons, a 50-state comparison.
So they are serve as a resource to us in California.
And so they do all kinds of resources and research.
And so that is a tool for us to use.
And as a member, we do have that as an opportunity.
Lupita Cortez-Acala did a highlight on one of the state spotlights, so we were there to share about the California dashboard and the system of multiple measures.
Lots of positive feedback in the session, so that was really nice for people to see what we're doing in California.
There was a session on high school reform and kind of follows up on our college and career discussion so there's some resources there as we continue this conversation about so what are the pathways for college and career, how do we use high school time those of us have been high school leaders know that's a challenge of what high schools should look like so.
and a lot of work about the future of work and lifelong learning.
So there's great resources from Education Commission of the States and a lot of recommendations about transforming teaching into a high status profession and many things like that.
So I just thought I'd highlight that.
Their website's available to us and they are a resource to us and we do have a team.
And also we talked a lot about continuous improvement and building capacity in schools and districts, which is what we're doing.
The second thing, I made a comment before about the CAST standard setting.
We'll hear about that when it comes back to us future with science.
But I just have to say the comments from the panelists, the teachers who help set the standards, can give good comments to us and the CDE staff on what should we be telling teachers and principals about science implementation.
And so comments about reading's hard, it's rigorous, that kids have to understand models, they have to understand graphs.
So we asked the staff to come up with recommendations from the panelists who set the standards to help us in continuing our science implementation.
There's a lot of people who are doing science of the new standards who realize how hard these tests are that we're testing.
And so we have to take that experience and translate it so that we can get the kind of results and implementation that we want.
So just to kind of foreshadow for what we're doing in science as districts are now doing adoptions and materials.
The account the Credential Commission met the beginning of August.
They're doing a lot of standard setting on the administrative performance assessment, and also talking about with President Darling Hampson talking about the integrated undergraduate programs to address teacher shortages and particularly
in the areas of special ed, stem, bilingual.
So lots of conversation with all of us knowing how important is that we recruit and train our teachers.
And the last comment is on the state website there is a deadline in early October for our commissions that we will be interviewing for.
So member Ortiz-Lincon and member Portia Bronson will be working with me on the screening along
student, so it's not too late to talk about people, two people you know who would be great committee representatives.
So the students will be recruiting, our Advisory Commission on Special Ed has openings, our Practitioners Advisory Commission that deals with accountability, and an Instructional Quality Commission.
We need math, history, social science, health, arts, and we need a student member.
That's new for us.
We haven't added a student member before.
So just to ask you to, if you know people who are strong in curriculum instruction but also can work as a group to help us move the work forward, we really need some strong applicants.
And we'll be working with that so that in November, to the best of our ability, we'll be bringing recommendations to the board.
Oh, and charter advisor, too.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Thank you very much.
Member Sandoval.
All right, special education.
The Advisory Commission on Special Education met last month, and a work group is forming to define medically fragile, and that's for accountability purposes.
And this is part of the chronic absenteeism indicator, because we do have students who are participating in home hospital programs.
And so there's discussion about defining what medically fragile is for those accountability purposes.
And we also learned about teacher residency grants.
This is stimulating new residency pathways for education specialists.
Of the 33 grantees, 27 are in special education and two were special education with bilingual authorization.
So that's really gonna help stimulate new pathways.
Visual and Performing Arts.
The Visual and Performing Arts Curriculum Framework and Evaluation Criteria Committee
had the last of its 12 meetings this past month.
And we want to acknowledge all of the members of that group for their work on that project.
And the draft framework will be going to the Instructional Quality Commission, the IQC, next week on September 19th.
And then after that IQC input, then the framework goes out for the first of two 60-day public comment periods in October.
and the state board will vote on the final draft in May of 2020.
So that's continuing.
California State Summer School for the Arts, 505 students completed the 33rd session of the California State Summer School for the Arts.
Michael Fields is the executive director.
He's lived through 30 of these sessions.
And he says that this was among the strongest ever.
And I also want to mention, in addition to a really rigorous and profound creative experience, emergency preparedness and safety was also an important focus.
And there were campus-wide earthquake and fire drills.
Food and water was stored on campus for emergency purposes.
for 10 days for all.
There were special storage boxes around campus that contained everything from medicine to emergency supplies, and there were satellite phones in case of communication disruption.
So that was a very important element that was included in this year's school.
So that concludes my liaison report.
All right, thank you very much.
Member Rucker.
Well, I don't have the need to repeat what's already been reported about my work by Board Member Sun.
She is the lead for the work that we're doing with the Joint Pathways Project and the work to develop the statewide plan.
And Board Member Strauss has already spoken about the work we do as liaisons on the IQC.
So in the interest of saving us time at the end of this long day, I'll say my report's already been made.
Thank you very much.
Whoa, all right.
Great modeling.
Remember Patia Bronson.
Feel free to take as long as you need.
I will aim for brevity.
I'll just highlight one body that will be accepting applications online.
The Early Childhood Policy Council was created in the state budget that was adopted at the end of June.
There will be a parent subcommittee, so please share with your networks.
There will be a provider and teacher subcommittee, and there will be appointments made by the superintendent, by the Speaker of the Assembly, by the Rules Committee of the Senate, and by the Governor's Office.
Many of the applications are hosted online or are going through those individual offices, and we'll have an opportunity to do some of the work of
better blending together the early learning systems and the K-12 systems to work together better.
Lastly, I'll just share a special thanks to folks.
I'm not sure if the accountability folks from CDE are still here, but in appreciation for the student reports that went out and were online and just
As a data size of n equals 1 at my own daughter's middle school, there was literally a line out the door of parents who were looking for their access portal TA in order to get their CASP scores for their kids at back to school night.
And this isn't, by the way, not a technology challenge by the state.
It was actually that parents had forgotten their logins.
But there was then a cohort of parents actually who were eagerly exciting and dissecting the SBAC scores and were very widely remarking on how accessible the data was.
So thank you again.
All right.
Thank you.
And student member, Rana.
I will just be attending the Student Advisory Board on Education conference in November in the selection process for the new student board member.
Perfect.
Thank you.
Member Ortiz-Laco?
First I want to welcome board member when a pendulum in to the state board we were I was privileged to be part of the screening committee that helped narrow the pool.
I want to congratulate her parents and her family you are champions for staying the entire time.
So, thank you, and it's great to have our first Chamorro student.
I have two nieces that are Chamorro.
Their last name is Pangilinan, which is why I know how to pronounce it.
And I know it's Pangilinan in the mainland, Pangilinan in Guam.
So, my actual report, you might have heard that the ethnic studies model curriculum was out for public comment.
Might have.
Yeah.
So we received about 20,000 public comments and in American money.
And so we will, the IQC will be discussing this item, this model curriculum next week on Friday, September 20th.
So I look forward to coming back with additional information on my report.
Thank you.
Very good.
We'll look forward to that.
Member Navo.
So I have two liaison reports, and I haven't officially started yet, so I have nothing to report.
Board member Burnai did a handoff from the CCEE, so I'm looking forward to the work with the CCEE on the system of support.
I do wanna welcome you, Brenna.
We're new together, so we'll learn together, and I do wanna congratulate your parents.
I'm sure that they've put a lot of effort and time into getting you to where you are today, and I'm sure they're very proud.
And I want to thank Superintendent Thurman for your staff today.
They're so incredibly thoughtful.
And I really want to thank Barbara for going down the rabbit hole on the Civic Seal.
But they're very thoughtful and they're doing what they can to take all of the thoughts that we have and consolidate them and put them into something that we as a team can stand behind.
I really appreciate that.
I will just, for my report, reinforce that thanks to the department staff and the State Board staff who have just done extraordinary work to keep us moving along on a very ambitious agenda for a number of years, and that feels like the pace of that agenda just continues to accelerate as we continuously improve.
So, many, many thanks for that.
And Member Burr, you get to
be the cleanup hitter.
Thanks.
I'll try to be fast.
I'm going to start with charters.
I'm sure some of you noticed we didn't have any charter hearings today, which contributes to our one day meeting.
But I did want to mention that I'm sure most of you have read about the passage of AB 1505, which represents a significant revision to the Charter Schools Act and potentially significant changes to our role as a state board.
Now, the bill still has to be acted upon by Governor Newsom, but I've asked our staff, the state board staff, to write a memo in collaboration with the department staff for a presentation to the board in October.
So I just want to give you kind of a heads up, again, dependent on the action of the governor.
I'm not presupposing any of his action, but I think it will be of interest to us because, as I said, it will be a significant change to the work that we do relative to charters
On that topic, I also want to call to your attention the August memo, and thank especially the department staff.
I see Lisa in the back, who I know is doing two jobs at this moment.
But there's a lot of detailed information about every charter school that the board authorizes, both financially and academic.
And sometimes I think that gets missed, and it's a ton of work, so I just appreciate everything that the department and the state board staff did on that.
Just to reinforce again what Eileen said, we are recruiting for the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, and virtually every member is up.
So we need school district superintendent, charter school representatives, charter school teachers, parents, members of governing board districts, and county superintendents of schools.
So if you know of folks that want to serve in that role, please point them toward that application.
The last thing I will say is I am delighted to pass on the leadership baton to Matt to be the member of the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
President Darling-Hammond has designated him to be her representative.
So this will be my last report.
We met August 1st.
Just want to call to your attention a couple things.
The $13.5 million has been made available for joint administration between the department and the collaborative.
to recreate or to start a new California School Leadership Academy, CSLA 21.
And the applications are out for that, for grant funding, so people should be aware of that.
It's done collaboratively, again, with the department and CCEE.
There's also $37.1 million provided
Again, jointly administered by those two entities for the educator workforce investment grants.
And that's to provide professional learning in several substantive areas, implementation of the EL roadmap, special education, school climate, and there are a few other ones.
I'll also mention that on the collaborative's agenda, if you're interested, there's a very substantive conversation about what the goals are for the collaborative in the upcoming year.
So for people who are following that,
Please take a look at that.
And we had two presentations, one by a professional learning network on foster youth, which was really fascinating, and one by LAUSD.
We worked with one of their local districts, Local District Central, as a pilot.
And they focused very specifically on progress of English learners and had fantastic results.
So I encourage you all to look at that.
And that closes my presentation.
I want to renege and go back to my comments.
And just acknowledge Member Burr's report made me think of this because of her longstanding contributions to the board and moving forward.
How much we rely on each member of this board in liaisoning to all these committees and how much we really appreciate the substantive input and impact that longstanding board members like you and Vice President Strauss and newer board members as well who are
coming in our making to our ability to get this work done in a really thoughtful way that is leading the country in many respects.
And so I think it's worth acknowledging the board itself for the intellectual grist that is driving that forward.
We will now take up agenda item 14, which is general public comment.
Public comment is invited on any matter that is not included in the printed agenda.
So, are there any public comments?
Would the following speakers please line up at the podium?
Nancy Albaron, Claudia Rossi, Ryan Labue, Melissa Moreno, Norby Kumagi, Dominique Williams, Mario Galean, and Lupita Torres.
All right.
And we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board president, superintendent, board members and staff.
My name is Nancy Albron and I'm the superintendent of San Jose Unified School District, the largest district in the Silicon Valley.
I thought that this was a very opportune time to come.
I know there's been a lot of transitions at the state level.
And I thought it was a good time to share my perspective about a matter of principle.
Several years ago, our teachers association in the district jointly agreed to a three-year probationary period and a fair and transparent dismissal process for teachers.
Unfortunately, we were unable to implement our contract because our request for relief through a waiver had been denied by the board.
Similarly, the CDE federal program reviewers are also being inflexible, causing our staff to perform unnecessary and excessive work.
Simultaneously, we see evidence of flexibility and accommodations for other public schools, such as charters.
Today, I ask for consistency.
If a charter school can be moderately compliant, then so should San Jose Unified, and I look forward to your support as we move forward together to provide our best services for students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Claudia Rossi, and I am a member of the Santa Clara County Board of Education.
I traveled a long way to be with you today.
I appreciate the challenges the city faces overseeing charter schools authorized by the state board.
As we move towards new roles and responsibilities for charter school oversight, I want to encourage you to be cautious with your decisions and mindful that schools under your oversight may soon be transferring from the state to local agencies such as the one that I serve.
I urge you to ensure that all charter schools currently under your jurisdiction are in compliance with their approved charters as well as all applicable laws and policies, especially the ones that address student safety.
Thank you for having CDE staff work with school districts and county offices to ensure that all instances such as compliance issues are addressed before the charters under your authorization seek renewal from local agencies.
Thank you.
Hello, Madam President, Superintendent, members of the board.
My name is Brian Labue.
By day, I'm a high school physics teacher in San Jose, California.
My part-time job is as a board of trustee member for the Ocrow School District in San Jose.
Today, I'm here to ask you to take seriously your responsibility to perform oversight on the charters that have been overturned by this board.
I had occasion today to visit Perseverance Charter School, and what I saw was 34 students in a church basement co-located with social programs providing substance abuse help for some of our neediest residents in San Jose.
What you may see on Google Maps is that they also are neighbors to two fraternity houses next to San Jose Unified.
I'm not here to throw stones at people doing important work for some of our most needy citizens, nor am I here to impugn the I'm sure
Spotless reputation of the fraternity houses, but I ask that this board sitting a hundred and twenty miles away having overturned to locally a time to local refusals take seriously its Job and make sure that the permits that were put in are actually held by this charter They have not even been applied for
Greetings, Melissa Moreno, Professor of Ethnic Studies.
I'm here as a private citizen on behalf of the state of California Ethnic Studies, not as an elected official.
We'd like to see you.
Thank you.
Welcome.
All right, take two.
Melissa Moreno, greetings everyone.
I'm speaking here as a private citizen on behalf of Safe California Ethnic Studies, not as an elected official.
Thank you for your service, deeply appreciate it.
The Safe California Ethnic Studies organization was surprised to read the board's statement a few weeks ago.
We hope that the Department of Education has rethought its
position misperceptions and misrepresentation of ethnic studies model curriculum.
We plead that you please fix the educational pipeline for students, all students, especially of color, by keeping the current model curriculum with some revisions and edits.
Maintain the curricular framework and include some input by the members of the advisory committee when appropriate and approve or improve.
I mean, transparency.
Currently, we have thousands of supporters.
Thank you.
Good afternoon Superintendent Thurmond, members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Norb Kumagai.
I reside in the Davis Joint Unified School District.
I was president of the Public Comments on Ethnic Studies Curriculum.
This past spring I'm here in response to the statement on Ethnic Studies on August 12th.
I'm certain that most if not all of you agree the vast majority of the entire K-12 educational curriculum is heavily biased and neurosensory.
Let's consider that.
For example, the forced detention of Japanese-Americans during World War II, such as my mother and my relatives, is rarely taught in our history courses.
Yet the lessons learned from these experiences in American history is appropriate for this current time.
Please help take the model curriculum draft that will allow the core of the project to move forward, along with any necessary revisions to be made.
I thank you for your time.
Now we need to raise the podium.
Hi, my name is Dominique Williams.
I am an ethnic studies teacher here in Sacramento and Sacramento City Unified School District and also a member of Ethnic Studies Now Sacramento.
And, um,
along the lines of leading the country in education.
I hope that we can continue to lead the charge for ethnic studies in California.
And I would like to ask that we revise the draft in places that revisions are necessary without scrapping the entire draft.
I would like to also ask that we maintain the integrity of ethnic studies as a curriculum that addresses issues of power and justice, but it's also inclusive and critical.
And I would also like to ask that in the revision process that you all, members of the board, rely on the expertise of the writers of the curriculum, teachers like myself, and other community members who can help nuance and flesh out some of the things that were public concerns.
Thank you for your time.
My name is Mario Galvan.
I'm a member of the Ethnic Studies Now Coalition here in Sacramento.
I'm here to support the draft model Ethnic Studies curriculum and to urge that it be kept with modification as the core of an ongoing model curriculum project.
The board's August 12th statement on the model curriculum says, a model curriculum should be accurate, free of bias, appropriate for all learners in our diverse state.
This should be true of any and all curricula in the state.
but as a product of California public schools and a retired teacher, I believe that the vast majority of our K-12 curriculum is, and has been since its inception, Eurocentric and heavily biased.
If this model curriculum draft is being condemned for not meeting a higher standard than everything else being taught right now in our schools, then this is a condemnation of our entire educational system.
The August 12th statement's call for a new draft to be developed is disappointing.
It seems to be a concession to a heated political and media reaction that came largely from outside of communities of color.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Lupita Torres, and I'm a concerned parent from the Davis Joint Unified School District.
We've been working with the district to implement K-12 ethnic studies, and we're very interested in the model curriculum coming through as soon as possible.
We are aware that there was a process in order to obtain this model curriculum, and a lot of people put in long hours and hard work.
I asked that you not dismiss the curriculum and rewrite the draft.
If there's any changes that need to be made.
Then so be it, it would be a shame for the kids have two more years to wait until they start learning about their history, I didn't learn about my history until I was a student at UC Davis.
Sadly, I didn't even know Mexican-Americans had a history.
I was 19 years old.
I have my four-year-old son here that's about to enter the district next year as a kindergarten.
And I would love for him to learn about his history.
There's no reason to postpone it, make the changes, modifications needed, but there's also no need to censor the truth.
And there's a lot of things happening in this century that need to be spoke about.
Thank you.
Hi, Angela DeRamos on behalf of CTA.
Now, if it's okay, I'd like to speak on the model curriculum as well.
CTA believes that the integrity of the ethnic studies curriculum must remain intact and that a revision should strengthen the work of the advisory committee that they've already begun.
We believe the current timeline and process should be allowed to happen.
all feedback as planned to go to the IQC and then create draft two.
If you adopt a new timeline and start over, we recommend that you also convene the original group of educators so that they can provide feedback and continue the good work that they've been doing.
Thank you.
Okay.
There's no other public comment?
I have a public comment.
On behalf of the board and the people of California, I think we should congratulate Dr. Linda Darling-Hammond for being confirmed by the State Senate as her appointment on the board.
Well, I'll just take this opportunity both to thank you for that recognition, but also to say that I am quite sure that every member of this
And certainly those of us who issued a statement in August are strong supporters of ethnic studies and having an excellent ethnic studies curriculum in our state.
And we will get there soon.
And with that, I think we have finished everything that we needed to do.
And I adjourn the meeting.
4.32.
Whoa.
And a lunch break.